[Musique]
Philippe bujol bonsoir bonsoir nous vous
recevons pour une chaîne internet qui
s'appelle Serview nous sommes en direct
est-ce que vous pouvez vous présenter
succintement alors je m'appelle Philippe
Pujol je suis écrivain journaliste à la
base journaliste d'ailleurs écrivain
réalisateur de de documentairirees et
euh principalement sur les thématiques
on va dire on me résume souvent au
stupéfiant mais de manière plus vaste ce
que j'appelle moi le monstre
c'est-à-dire euh tout ce qui va toucher
la corruption le clientélisme des choix
politiques un peu hasardeux pour le
moins et des et des aussi des des choix
des choix économiques parce qu'il y a
pas que les politiques qui font des
choix hasardeux qui sont pour des
intérêts propres et non pas pour des
intérêts collectifs tout ça j'appelle ça
le monstre et je suis un peu un
examinateur de ce monstre là un
observateur et mon terrain de de
d'observation est principalement
Marseille mais pas que parce que pour
moi marseille est une ville qui qui
permet ça quoi prix Albert Londres prix
Albert Londres en 2014 s donc sur une
série qui s'appelait quartier sheat qui
était la saison 2 de mon de ma première
série qui s'appelait French de
connection et le tout condensé a été mon
premier livre qui était une série d'
deux séries d'articles collés et qui
s'appelle French de connection donc la
French Connection mais inversé
c'est-à-dire qu'avant la French
Connection on faisait la on faisait le
le la drogue à à Marseille alors c'est
plus complexe que ça mais à Marseille on
produisait on vendait aux États-Unis et
ben maintenant on produit la drogue
ailleurs Mexique ou enfin Colombie ou
Maroc et on vend à à Marseille et dans
dans nos cités donc il nous arrive
aujourd'hui ce qui arrivit aux
États-Unis dans les années 60 70 donc
c'est pour ça que j'appelle ça French de
connection alors je sais qu'on dit
normalement disconnection mais moi au
journal à Marseille quand je travaille
dans la Marseillaise un journal
communiste de de de Marseille je t'ai
fait diversier là-bas et quand j'avais
mis French disc connection on m'avait
dit mais est-ce qu'ils vont savoir à M
pe si c'est un quartier de Marseille
est-ce qu'ils vont savoir ce que c'est
disconnection donc j'ai choisi des
connection ce francissisme de de
l'anglais donc ce soir on va parler
drogue arme alcool
politique
prostitution sujet colichon ça et des
choses plus surprenant au milieu de tout
ça parce qu'en fait ça c'est un petit
peu la la je dis c'est tout ce que tous
les mots clés qu' VI cité qui existe et
qui sont vrais c'est justement le le le
le l'angle qu'on a habituellement unique
et en fait malheureusement c'est plus
vaste que ça des fois à tort on a
tendance à dire de moi que je que je que
j'amoindris le problème alors qu'en fait
je trouve que je pense que la situation
est bien plus grave que celle qui est
décrit par les par les le les médias et
les politiques actuells euh parce que on
n'est pas dans un problème de mafia pour
moi ou de cartel on est un problème de
société et pour moi c'est bien plus
vaste parce que ça serait simplement un
problème de de cartel ça serait grave ça
serait dû à un groupe de bandits et ça
serait pas dû à la société en général or
là pour moi on va y venir c'est un
problème de société qui ressort et qui
permet au banditis d'exister et moi ça
fait depuis des années depuis 2003 que
j'écris sur ces sujetsl et que je fais
partie de tous ceux qui écrivent ou qui
racontent justement comment cette
société en déliquessence permet la
sortie de de lésion et ces lésion ce
sont les trafics de stup par exemple le
trafic de stup c'est pas c'est pas le
problème c'est la lésion du problème
dire si la la la la si on a une maladie
grave le trafic de stup c'est la la la
sont les les les les lésions les boutons
de cette maladie grave la maladie grave
c'est ce que moi j'appelle le monstre
corruption clientélisme alors en France
c'est surtout du clientélisme il une
petite sucité on va en parler et ensuite
ce que je disais les choix politiques et
économiques totalement foireux pour moi
le monstre c'est ça et aussi je mets
chacun devant sa responsabilité aussi on
donne tous tous tant qu'on est un petit
peu de de de de on met un petit peu de
de de d'énergie dans ce monstre aussi on
fait on fait nous-même des choix on
prend nous-même des décisions qui font
des fois à l'encontre de de de la
société on commence macro ou micro
est-ce qu'on commence par
l'International les producteurs est-ce
qu'on commence du côté violence par
exemple en ce moment affrontement en
Suède entre cartel ou gang ou territoire
on commence par Marseille on commence
par l'A on commence par les routes de la
drogue non on va commencer par les
clichés le cliché aujourd'hui c'est
mafia donc mafia système pyramidal un
par un des lieutenants des adjoints des
soldats ça c'est le système jusqu'au
milieu des années 90 cette lecture là
n'est plus valable depuis 2006 je vais
dire pourquoi ces dates mais donc
aujourd'hui on a on applique une lecture
sur une grille qui qui est plus la bonne
qui a été vrai he la French Connection c
la French Connection c'était une méthode
et une période c'était pas une mafia
c'est une méthode une période mais il y
a eu quand même des gros de la freine si
on connaitt les noms les ampales et le
Belge et quelques autres qui qui qui ont
été des si c'est pas des Parin au moins
des gros caïdes avec un système
pyramidal mais ça ça n'existe plus en
tout cas en France ça existe ailleurs
aujourd'hui on a une ubérisation de de
la drogue et je je vous raconterai
comment on y est arrivé mais en tout cas
la situation d'aujourd'hui c'est des
grossistes qui sont des producteurs même
avant les grossistes des producteurs
donc producteurs cannabis au Maroc un
petit peu Afghanistan dans tout ce coin
là mais pour ce qui concerne Marseille
c'est pratiquement que le Maroc la
France et principalement le Maroc et un
petit peu pour le nord de la France qui
prend d'autres pays mais principalement
le Maroc pour le cannabis et cocaïne
c'est Colombie qui produit et les
Mexicains qui depuis des années 2010
2009 8 9 10 qui sont les transitaires on
va appeler ça comme ça qui vont faire la
distribution et je te coupe tuas pas
suivi les Chinois avec le fintanil oui
mais là on parle de cocaïne cheat à
Marseille Marseille en France le
problème principal qui est mis au devant
de la scène c'est-à-dire les réseaux de
stup qui sont un peu partout qui vont
pousser un peu partout c'est pas le
fontaineil c'est pas encore la MDMA et
compagnie qui existe aussi c'est pas
toutes ces drogues là qui existent c'est
un souci c'est un souci santé publique
surtout mais c'est pas un souci de
trafic on a une exception alors elle est
très parisienne donc on en parle
beaucoup c'est le crack mais le crack il
est principalement à Paris si je prends
Marseille il y a 50 craqueux à Marseille
ils sont tous à une cité je vais pas la
dire on va pas faire la promo mais il y
a une cité à Marseille qui fait du crack
et le craque ne prend pas mais la
plupart des villes le craque ne prend
pas c'est pas la drogue qui est attendue
en fait le craque c'est une drogue de la
disparition prend cette drogue pour ne
plus exister pour disparaître le
fantanil c'est une drogue de la
disparition encore plus et nous en en
Europe en France particulièrement en
France on n pas besoin enfin il y a pas
une demande de drogue de la distribution
de la de la disparition sauf peut-être
pas encore tout ce que je dis c'est
maintenant après évidemment les choses
évoluent sauf que je pense pas qu'on
tout de suite pourquoi parce que la
drogue de la disparition elle est ici
Porte de la Chapelle c'est connu on en
parle des reportages qui sont très bons
on voit c'est vrai mais quand on voit la
population c'est vraiment une population
souvent de migrants ou de marginaux qui
ont besoin de disparaître ces gens-là
ils sont pas dans toutes les villes euh
donc il y a pas un marché suffisant pour
avoir des dealers de craque de partout
donc demain même il y aurait des dealers
de craque de partout il y aurait pas la
consommation et le fantanil va arriver
sur la France mais qu'il y aura les
consommateurs de fantanil aujourd'hui
moi je pense pas plus que ça parce que
la drogue de la disparition n'est pas la
demande pas du tout on a déjà l'héroïne
et la héroïne ne marche plus on a déjà
l'héroïne s'il faut disparaître il y a
déjà ce truc là il y en a très peu
l'héroïne il y a une cité à Marseille
que je connais qui est historiquement
dans l'héroïne mais il y a quoi il y a
100 types qui prennent de l'héroïne
peut-être pas plus quoi et la fume il il
se l'injecte presque plus le sida est
passé par là quoi et
donc ça on y reviendra sur ce sur sur
pourquoi telle ou telle drogue ce qui
est donc on nos producteurs producteurs
c'est les grossistes ces grossistes là
vont travailler avec des transitaires
les transitaires c'est des bandits
souvent qui sont multiartes qui font pas
que ça qui sont issus eux-mêmes alors
pour les Français qui sont issus de la
French Connection héritier de la French
mais pour les Anglais c'est encore un
autre héritage pour les Portugais les
Espagnols chaque pays a ses bandits les
Algériens les Marocains il y en a
vraiment partout hein et ces bandits là
sont transitaires ils amène de la drogue
du grossiste au au pays en question
parlons de Marseille la la drogue va
arriver par fret quasi exclusivement
évidemment il y a des il y a des des
voitures qui vont temps en temps au
Maroc par l'Espagne il y a des choses
comme ça évidemment il y a des
initiatives personnelles mais le gros
les 90 % ce qui va alimenter les 160
réseaux deupe des bouches du Ron c'est
c'est c'est du fret et donc ce fret là
il est fait par des anciens la freng
combien de kilos combien de
tonnes là je peux pas dire de chiffres
moi mais ce que je peux dire c'est que
ils vont farcir des conttainurs de de 20
tonnes 20 tonnes c'est le le matériel
dedans par exemple du charbon de bois ça
c'est le top du top hein pour les pour
les trafiquants du conteneur de 20
tonnes et dans ces 20 tonnes on va
mettre une tonne 2 tonnes et on fait ça
à peu près toutes les semaines donc moi
je peux pas dire quelle est la quantité
de stup qui passe de toute façon
personne peut le dire parce que on se
fit au saisis et on se fit grosso modo à
la consommation ce qu'on suppose de la
consommation souvent on a tendance à la
surévaluer la consommation elle est
moins forte que ce qu'elle est que ce
qu'on annonce parce que on oublie
quelque chose c'est que quand on achète
un produit qui a une tonne qui arrive ça
va être revendu coupé en deux en 2 fois
500 kg à une autre cité qui va la
revendre en deux fois en tris fois 1 et
cetera et on a tendance à additionner
quelque chose qui en fait se divise donc
là aussi dans les sommes qu'on a qui
sont annoncé dans les quantités de stup
sont annoncé on oublie quand même que
c'est pas c'est le même produit qui est
vendu à plusieurs étapes il é coupé
entre- tempemps et en plus il est coupé
avec du N on va y venir ça c'est un
problème de santé publique majeur donc
on a notre transitaire notre transiter
nous amène notre drogue issu de la
French issu de la France-Afrique de la
corse-arique on est avec le Gabon on est
avec l'Angola pour les Anglais on est
avec toute l'Afrique du de l'Ouest par
exemple on sait faire avec l'Algérie on
sait faire avec le Maroc on a tout tout
ce coin là des fois le Mexique passe
tout seul sans sans sans étapes hein
c'est possible on a l'Espagne
euh ces transiteurs là ils sont très
puissants et ils ont des alors ils ont
des pouvoirs de de corruption importants
dans les autres pays les pays de départ
ou les pays de transit par exemple le
Gabon un pays de transit là pouvoir de
corruption très fort et ils n'ont pas
besoin de corruption quand ils arrivent
en France pourquoi parce que quand le
containeur arrive moi je j'ai une très
bonne connaissance de la douane j'ai
grandi moi entouré de douaniers mes
parents m'end tout le monde était
douanier donc j'ai vraiment une culture
de douane même si je l'ai pas été j'ai
l'impression d'avoir été et j'ai
toujours entendu quand quand j'étais
plus jeune que la corruption après des
donnes se faisait des bandit expliquit
que que j'ai pu connaître aussi un
certain un grand banditisme expliquer
que il suffisait d'offrir une voiture à
un doignier pour qu'il mette le tampon
sur le sur le conttainur en question les
voyou aujourd'hui me disent on a plus
besoin de faire ça c'est plus nécessaire
on a même plus besoin de filer une Clio
équivalent pourquoi parce que depuis le
début des années 2000 pour faciliter le
transit et l'économie légale on
a créer quelque chose d' extraordinaire
pour les transitaires là les vrais
transitaires transitaires de métier on a
fait l'autoc c'estàd qu'un transporteur
aujourd'hui se contrôle lui-même ça veut
dire tout simplement le comptainur
arrive tu te contrôles toi-même est-ce
que est-ce que j'ai payé mes taxes
est-ce qu'il y a de la contrefaçon
dedans non est-ce qu'il y a de non c'est
bon je me suis bien contrôlé c'est tout
bon je me mets le tampon moi-même que
mes télédoigners avant dire c'est bon et
c'est pass et c'est passé les douaniers
peuvent contrôler l'autocontrôle c'estàd
de temps en temps ils peuvent en prendre
un au hasard et voir si c'est vrai c'est
vrai que si tu te fais choper tu vas
prendre cher mais en fait c'est rare la
réalité c'est rare sur le port de P
Saint- Louis du Ron 300 containurs par
jour de charbon de bois je sais
plusieurs milliers de containurs qui
arrivent du monde entier il y a cinq
doiniers qui vont faire du contrôle de
de de conteneur directement et ils sont
pas naïfs quand ils discutent ils font
ils te regardent comme ça tu disas le
contrôle hican quoi hein ils font exprès
de dépoter un containur sur bon de boîte
ben voilà il ouvre ça tombe voilà
qu'est-ce on fait on le vide 20 tonnes
on le vide non on le vide pas tu mets
les chiens ils sentent rien on peut pas
sentir à travers du du containur et tu
faux passer le scanner tu vois rien
c'est la même densité donc charbon de
bois c'est mort finalement les seuls qui
chopent c'est c'est le type qui allait
faire du du du kite surf ou du surf au
vers le Brésil là-bas en revenant il se
dit je vais m'amener 2 3 kg ou 20 kg
pour moi-même pour les Vendes pour me
faire des sous lui il va se faire avoir
parce que lui on le voit arriver à 3 km
on passe le scanner et lui on le chope
et on dit on a chopé un dealer non on a
pas chopé un dealer on a chopé un
consommateur un peu naïf qui voulait
vendre derrière mais c'est pas un dealer
et donc ça on en attrape des comme ça
mais les dealers organisés pour les
attraper il y a que deux méthodes le
renseignement donc en gros qu' qu'
qu'une partie adverse ou qu'un au qu'un
quelqu'un balance faut une balance hein
enfin balance c'est pas le bon n je
parle un peu comme un Corse euh pas une
une voilà non mais qu'il qu'il qu' a une
information c'est ça le bon terme qui a
une information et ou alors il faut
avoir un coup de mal chance de la part
ou coup de chance de la part de la
police ou un coup ou de la douane ou un
coup de malchance pour pour le pour le
dealer c'est-à-dire que le le conteneur
devait arriver dans tel port Marseille
il est dérouté pour X raison alors qu'il
a pasêt contrôlé à Marseille bom le
voilà contrôlé au havavre et c'est là
qu'on fait des 2 tonnes 3 tonnes au
Havre d'un coup alors que c'était pas
prévu et on se rend compte que c'est
bien un containur qui devait aller
ailleurs donc la deuxième méthode elle
est tellement dû au hasard que on laisse
tomber la première méthode c'est
l'investigation ils ont fait des progrès
clairement des progrès qui ont été fait
mais je pense que là-dessus il y a un
travail international à faire de
coopération de renseignement le problème
c'est que la diplomatie
la géopolitique fait que tu as pas
tendance à t'entraider en ce moment
c'est pas le c'est pas l'air du temps
l'entraide on a plutôt tendance au
contraire à se à se faire des poussettes
hein à se donner des foises infos on n
pas dans la plus grande période de de
l'entraide internationale donc les
dealers se joue là-dessus les dealers
d'une manière générale que soit au grand
échelon ou petit échelon vont se mettre
dans les vulnérabilités soit les
vulnérabilités des systèmes donc des
états des des institutions soit dans les
vulnérabilités ça c'est le bas des
personnes sancien ur informatique ça
ouais je l'ai été ouais j'étais oui j'ai
tendance à et puis j'ai été aussi
éthologue ça ça va venir j'ai fait pas
fait j'ai fait des études en éthologie
étude des comportements animaux donc
j'ai une approche un peu biologique de
pas grand monde aujourd'hui faut que
faire gaffe parce que V vu ce que
j'observe il fa pas que je raconte
n'importe quoi làdessus non c'est c'est
par contre j'ai des méthodes
scientifiques en effet je suis un
journaliste un écrivain qui vient de de
de des études scientifiques qui a été
informaticien au milieu alors c'est
c'est un mauvais parcours hein j'ai
glissé là hein c'est je regrette j'ai
pas fait exprès mais en tout cas j'ai
gardé cette logique de fonctionnement
qui fait que j'ai une analyse qui va
dans ce sens-là qui va dans une analyse
euh de de procédure comment ça
fonctionne et et pareil en fait moi j'ai
eu des études en écologie pas l'écologie
la politique mais pour devenir écologue
mais bon quand j'ai eu fin des années 90
ce diplôme il y avait pas de boulot hein
à ce moment-là donc donc je suis devenu
informaticien puis journaliste derrière
et du coball j'ai fait du coball ouais
pour ceux qui ricanent là en entendant
ça du coball alors encore aujourd'hui
même prix alberland sur litine on
m'invite on me propose du boulot pour
être Cobol il cherche des ingénieurs
Cobol [__] il pourrait voir un près
alberland ça fait pas du Cobol mais bon
de toute façon jeaurais pu le faire et
et mais bon ça m'a servi pour avoir ce
cette logique la logique de boulet 1 là
si ça donc ça alors ça voilà ça m'a
servi à ça j'ai cette approche là et ce
qui fait que j'ai une approche logique
des choses et à la fois je quand je vais
parler plus jeune vous verrez je mets de
l'empathie de l'émotion parce que c'est
des humains mais quand je parle d'un
système je mets pas d'émotion je dis pas
c'est bien mal je c'est pas mon r voilà
ça marche ça fait ça parce qu'il y a la
possibilité si ça c'est possible et bien
ça voilà je fonctionne comme ça donc
quand mon semi grossiste il quand mon
transitaire amène ma drogue à Marseille
il a réussi à passer assez facilement le
conteneur et là lui il a terminé son
travail de semigrossiste il a un rapport
commercial avec le le le grossiste non
je reprends et le le transitaire un
rapport commercial avec le le grossiste
le mexicain et le Marocain le semioss le
transitaire pardon il est très puissant
force de
corruption des alliances politiques y
compris avec la France hein c'est
souvent des anciens de la Corse Afrique
ou de la france-arique hein très souvent
ou alors quand c'est des Algériens c'est
des anciens avec des des acquintances
aussi avec des gouvernements pour X
raison souvent lié à des à des à des
moment politique notamment des années 90
pour l'Algérie ou quand c'est des des
Espagnols il y a encore une autre
histoire derrière à chaque is une
histoire politique qui fait qu'un bandit
est là pas parce que il est bon
peut-être qu'il est bon peut-être qu'il
est compétent mais parce que à un moment
il a servi il a été utile et et donc il
a une sorte de liberté qu'il prend
toujours pareil une faille il va dedans
c'est les mauvais herbes qui poussent
tout le temps hein
et le le le conttainur arrive à
Marseille il va à por Saint-Louis Duon
donc un port pas très Marseille le port
de Marseille c'est pas ça il arrive à
per Louis du Ron quand il est là-bas il
va va il va être mis il va être dépoté
donc dépoté c'est le jargon pour dire on
prend le contenur on le vide il va être
dépoté dans un dans un hangar qui est
officiellement un hangar qui travaille
quelque part en zone gendarmerie c'est
important tu mets en zone gendarmerie la
la la la discussion entre gendarme et
police n'est pas parfaite alors elle est
moins moins pourrie qu'avant 2012 je
vous expliquerai pourquoi 2012 mais elle
reste imparfaite pour des raisons
principalement pour des raisons
politiques et de et de et de de budget
quoi même si il y a eu des
rapprochements mais tu veux pas que
l'autre ait le succès pour toi il y a
parfois des questions d'ego mais c'est
pas non plus la masse il y a parfois des
des questions de vengeance en interne
mais la plupart du temps c'est
simplement c'est toujours les autres qui
tirent les marons du feu tu vois alors
que c'est toi qui a mis les marons
dedans donc là il y a des améliorations
à faire les institutions sont conscient
hein ils apprennent rien en m'écoutant
ils savent très bien ce que je dis et et
euh donc jandamerie c'est dépoté et là
on va partager la tonne allez je vais
prendre une tonne al je suis nul en
calcul je vais me débrouiller pour les
il y a une tonne et on va faire TR trois
tas de 333 kg chacun euh un il va être
on va dire après avant c'était bleu
rouge et jaune par exemple on mettait un
tampon bleu rouge et jaune maintenant on
met des marques Yoda des Yoda ils sont
un peu disparus mais la frappe des a
mafia corleéon c'est des groupes c'est
des moi j'appelle pas ça des c'est pas
des mafias pas du tout j'appelle surtout
pas ça des cartels je vais m'expliquer
et euh ce sont des franchises pour moi
ce sont des marques donc bon c'est quand
même des marques puissantes mais c'est
les marques
euh une fois qu'ils ont fait ça les les
les les les les containurs vont
ensuite il va y avoir l'échange entre
une clé USB qui va avoir des codes qui
permet de de d'engager des paiements
avec une clé de voiture qui va se faire
par exemple je donne un exemple sur le
parking du du du Grand Littoral c'est un
un grand centre commercial à ciel ouvert
comme les centres commerciaux américains
là et bon il va y avoir un échange à cet
endroit-l d'ailleurs la police tourne
souvent là-bas pour pour essayer de
choper ça et on va donner à à
semirossiste marseillais ceux qu'on
appelle les
dealers qui sont en les vrais dealers
locaux ils vont avoir la clé et une
adresse et ils vont aller chercher la
voiture mettons à la destrous qui est
une petite ville toujours en
jeendarmerie où on va avoir mis la
voiture dans un dans un box qui est
souvent des personnes âgées ou des gens
qu'on qu'on qu'on qu'on qu'on imagine
pas être des nourrices qui le sont
généralement de façon rétribuée mais
parfois sans même vraiment savoir ce
qu'il y a et parfois forcé il y a les TR
cas al je pourrais pas dire quelle
proportion j'eni aucune idée mais les 3
cas tout est
possible et là c'est le moment où c'est
un peu compliqué parce que la voiture
mettons qu'elle 300 kg faut la mener de
de de la destrous à une cité et là c'est
un passage où tu es à découvert donc le
premier risque c'est la concurrence
l'attaque de la diligence c'est le
premier risque c'est pas la police la
police ne tire pas la police ne tue pas
en France ENF elle tue pas la police ne
tire pas sur des dealur tout ça il peut
y avoir des bavures ça mais on est sur
autre chose on n pas de de de
possibilité comme parfois au Brésil où
on rentre dedans et je suis pas pour ça
moi mais ce que je veux dire c'est que
ils n'ont pas une peur bleue de la
police ils voudrai pas se faire attraper
parce qu'ils ont peur de la prison à ce
qu'on dit mais c'est pas ils vont pas
mourir par contre la concurrence elle
tue la concurrence elle cherche pas à
comprendre donc il y a une période
un moment il y a de l'information où est
la voiture tout ça donc là il y a il y a
quelque chose qui se joue important
c'est là qu'il y a des des hommes
importants qui sont la sécurité
généralement c'est une voiture dedans on
y met
l'appareil les profils c'est des gens
qui n qui on qui ont l'air de tout sauf
de dealer donc soit des petits jeunes
mais des petits jeunes bien bien sur eux
hein soit des soit des mères de famille
ce pe des mémés et qui vont conduire une
voiture qui qui a l'air de rien et il va
y avoir une voiture devant une voiture
derrière qui ouvre et une autre qui
ferme et on va les amener doucement
jusqu'à la cité et là après à la cité on
est dans un lieu clos à nouveau
distribution donc on est au
semi-grossiste à Marseille j'estime à
aujourd'hui en activité il y en a plus
beaucoup mais une vingtaine de
semi-rossistes une vingtaine de non je
pourrais moi jeis pas le faire mais je
pourrais en citer de têtes comme ça 10
15 je vais pas le faire mais une
vingtaine de noms après il y a ceux qui
sont connus qu'on voit sans arrêt à la
télé hein il y a parce qu' comme ils ont
créé des marques on les voit hein c'est
devenu les les les les Steve Jobs de des
stubes quoi mais euh mais euh ils ont
eux-mêmes un entourage
entre ceux qui font leur sécurité ceux
qui font les transporteurs enfin ils ont
un entourage C costo j'estime à 150
bonhommes sur Marseille qui sont des
dealers et je pense qu'il y en a entre
1500 et 3000 en France qui sont des
dealers là vraiment on a du du de de des
donc c semirossiste avec beaucoup
d'argent beaucoup de problèmes pas
beaucoup
d'argent alors là c'est là que c'est
compliqué parce que ils font des
millions mais font des millions qui
dépensent principalement en frais
d'avocat en voiture blindée en
hôtel vidéo surveillé pour pouvoir se
planquer en téléphone parce que il
téléphonent qu'une fois avec un appareil
et en puce et donc il gagneent beaucoup
de sous pour pouvoir avoir une vie
normale c'est très étrange comme choix
de vie enfin au début ils choisissent
pas on va y venir mais mais une fois
qu'ils y sont en fait ils font des super
vacances alors certains à Dubaï d'autres
alors ils sont des vacances à 300000 €
hein ça je pas dire que c'est les les
petits dealers ils vont plutôt en
Thaïlande et les gros dealers ils vont à
Dubaï alors les très gros vont au Gabon
vont en Mexique et donc là il y a a
c'est c'est presque c'est presque image
d'Épinal hein prostitution donc les
prostitué de luxe belle voiture là on a
le truc classique donc ils ont des très
belles vacances qui pouront te donner
l'illusion de beaucoup d'argent je parle
des CEI grossiste les TRG les transitair
ils se GAV c'est c'est c'est énorme et
est tendu hein AFF flu tendu mais les
semioss ils font du fric mais ils ont
des carrières courtes avec ponctué de
beaucoup de prison donc c'est des gens
qui font régulièrement le million qui le
perdent qui vont gagner 10 puis perd ça
va ça vient en tout cas ils sont pas
riches longtemps et parfois ils sont
extrêmement riches ça ça bouge ben je
vais prendre là on peut dire des noms
parce qu'ils sont tous dans les médias
si je prends la D mafia qui n'est pas
une mafia même si le nom et
j'expliquerai pourquoi je pense ça au
début c'est créé par Med Laribi ditick
qui a tourné dans le film de Cab de D
qui s'appelle Ramsa et c'est le P
personnage principal de ce film un très
bon film le gamin que vous voyez c'est
TIC celui qui a créé la donc TIC c'est
son surnom dans le film qui est resté et
lui il s'appelle Med Larbi un type Mino
très enfin Mino il plus Mino maintenant
mais très intelligent très très malin et
qui a pour avocat Erric Dupon moréti
donc il a une très bonne connaissance de
la D mafia puisque il a eu c'est son
client
et lui il est rentré en prison en 2017
pour un pour complicité sur un triple
homicide pendant une guerre avec son
frère qui était lui l'assassin enfin qui
était condamné comme assassin la le
frère est toujours en prison mais d il
est sorti au bout de 3 ans alors qu'il a
pris 9 ans donc du pour mauity il est
très efficace une fois dehors je vous
expliquerai comment il crée la des mafia
et mais il reste pas longtemps
puisqueavec les les les les les guerres
qu' a eu en 2023 les affrontements les
morts dans tous les sens ça a mis la
police ça a mis d'abord les médias les
politiques et la police et et c'est pas
bon pour les affaires ça ce qui est bon
pour les affaires c'est les les bons
bandit ils sont silencieux les bon
bandits ils sont pas brouillants donc
ils se sont retrouvés tous en tole quoi
à part dit qui est en Caval mais bon il
finira probablement par y rentrer les
autres et là il y a le fameux Félix
biengi on dit pas bengi on dit biengi
Félix biangi qui est dit le chat qui
vient qui vient d'être extradé depuis
l'Algérie ou le Maroc le Maroc et qui
qui va être condamné ici donc ça c'est
justement c'est c'est ce migrossist me
costaud mais Félix il va passer sa vie
enfin il a déjà passé pas mal de temps
en prison il est reparti pour longtemps
son pognon il va le dépenser en avocat
en en en cantiner pour cantiner
c'estàdire en gros pour bien vivre en
prison faut 3500 € minimum par mois pour
quand je dis bien vivre c'està dire à
peu près bien manger regarder sa télé
avoir une cellule où tu choisis ton
codétenu où tu en as pas c'est-à-dire
avoir une vie qui est même pas une vie
normale quand on est dehors c'est-à-dire
finalement ils ont gagné beaucoup de
sous pour pour ça je le raconte dans mon
bouquin dans cramé je raconte que je
connaissais assez bien nordinaashouri
Nono le patron de la casséane alors une
relation journaliste bandie mais je
connaissais depuis assez longtemps il
aimait beaucoup mes livres et on
communiquait quand il était en prison il
me il me régulièrement le vendredi à 17h
j'avais un facebook je sais pas comment
on dit où on se voit là une sorte de
FaceTime sur Facebook je sais pas
comment s'appelle où en fait on
discutait alors il se savait sur écoute
on faisait pas n'importe quoi puis moi
je veux pas savoir qui a tué qui tout ça
c'est pas mon problème c'est pas mon
c'est pas mon but moi je veux savoir
comment ça marche et lui-même je lui
raconéis comment bosser les journalistes
et et je voyais bien lui il avait gagné
de l'argent lui cl ment il avait gagné
de l'argent il avait fait des millions
il avait sûrement mis de côté il avait
placé type intelligent tout ça bon mort
été 2023 de 24 balles de calashnikov
dans la tête à 43 ans donc voilà on va
me dire grand le banditisme c'est ça il
a fait des millions 43 ans la vie s'est
arrêté après avoir fait plusieurs années
de prison donc voilà il faut toujours le
rappeler hein parce que faut pas faut
pas en joliver trop ces viesl ils ont
des vies une fois qu'ils sont dedans il
te le disent il te dis je peux plus
sortir je peux plus sortir donc ils y
sont et quand ils veulent sortir ça
marche pas on a encore hier le gros Dédé
euh André sermolac alors lui cétait pas
les stupes mais qui avait 70 ans ils ont
mis trois balles dans la tête peut-être
pour des faits peut-être qu'il avait
fait quelque chose qui remonte à plus de
20 ans donc on t'oublie pas on t'oublie
pas tant que tes ennemis sont en vie tu
peux pas tu tu peux pas dormir
tranquille donc ça faut s'en rappeler de
ça hein faut pas idéaliser je dis ça
surtout pour les jeunes qui fantasment
du du du ce que j'appelle moi le
calashnic of dream le rêve de l'argent
facile par les stupes c'est un fantasme
pur et donc ce fantasme là qui est
moteur qui est un des moteurs des stupes
euh donc un élément très important pour
faire fonctionner les stupes bien il
faut un peu rappeler que ben voilà le
myth de Scarface faut se rappeler qui
meurt Scarface que lui-même il fait du
mal à peu près à tous ses proches et qui
meurt Scarface c'est pas mal hein ça te
raconte vraiment le vrai truc sauf que
les Minos ils ont oublié le passage ils
ont l'impression que c'est un petit
pororicain si je me rappelle bien un
cubain qui qui devient le meilleur des
meilleurs d'un coup ouais mais au prix
de renoncement énorme et il meurt il
meurt assez jeune mais c'est la vraie
vie c'est ça des renoncements énormes tu
vas faire du mal à tes proches beaucoup
de mal à tes proches et tu vas mourir à
la fin ou alors tu auras une vie à la
con donc ça il faut le rappeler après tu
me tu me demandais le pognon bah là par
exemple les les anciens patron de la des
a mafia parce que ça bouge tout le temps
ils avaient quand même acheté trois ou
quatre étages à Dubaï c'est-à-dire ils
investissent immédiatement dans
l'immobilier donc dans des paradis
fiscaux idéalement donc ils ont quand
même eu cette surface financière là les
routes financières parce que les stupes
tu payes pas avec ta carte bleue tu
payes pas avec des
chquers quand tu tu vas acheter du Real
Estate à Dubaï il faut forcément que ça
passe quelque part en fait les flux de
blanchiment d'argent quand je parle de
de pour mon transitaire et pour mes
semirossistes ce sont exactement les
flux de d'évasion fiscale c'est dire on
passe exactement par les sociétés
deécran et puis il bosse avec les mêmes
personnes tu as les mêmes conseillers tu
as les mêmes en fait c'est comme s'il y
avait des il doit y avoir ça d'ailleurs
des des boîtes spécialisées pour bah
pour de l'évasion fiscale al ça va être
on va te dire que c'est de la de la
c'est pas de l'évasion c'est de
laoptimisation de l'optimisation mais
ces mêmes sociétés peuvent très bien
aider à un moment des trafiquants à à à
blanchir donc là il y a un gros travail
à faire là-dessus évidemment là pareil
de la coopération du travail d'ailleurs
c'est des demandes il y a beaucoup
d'associations anti antimafia et pour le
coup là je parle de mafia de ce côté-là
le côté bandicisme international c'est
des mafias en effet il y a ces là quand
on parle maintenant de de l'autre partie
du banditisme parce que je disais il y a
la il y a la il y a mes semigrossistes
mais eux ils vendent à des à d'autres et
après tu y a les vendeurs de terrain
c'est les superettes c'est superes ceux
qui s'entretuent aujourd'hui c'est des
superettes c'est pas des cadeor c'est
pas des grands bandits tout ça c'est des
superettes c'est pour ça que c'est des
gosses qui tuent des gosses la nouveauté
c'est ça et je vais venir après sur le
blanchiment comment je je je te lance
après je je te r donne la parole comment
on est passé de ni femme ni enfant ah on
arrose tout le monde
2000 années 90 tu comprends je comprends
complètement des années 90 Schengen
arrive ça ouvre le les les frontières on
commence à avoir des gens qui
travaillent euh à l'international avant
c'est plus compliqué fallait avoir une
assise financière costaud fallait avoir
des liens c'était plutôt les anciens de
la French voilà c'était quand même des
gens qui avaient souvent été dans la
dans l'administration coloniale qui
avait travaillé pour l'armée la FR dans
la douane d'ailleurs aussi dans la
douane il y a eu l'affire Fiévé qui qui
qui avait qui a planqué pendant des
années et après on ne sait pas si c'est
un ripou de la douane ou si c'est un
type qui avait tellement bien fait son
boulot lui il défend ça moi je vais pas
prendre partie là-dessus il a il a il
est soupçonné d'un côté d'être un ripou
et de l'autre côté il est adulé en
disant c'est un des meilleurs indiques
qu'on ait eu je ne sais pas bon moi j'ai
pas la réponse en tout cas il a pas été
condamné mais il a été viré de la douane
donc il a eu il a pas eu de réponse
aussi de l'autre côté et euh mais mais
là c'est une autre époque les années 90
ouverture de de
Schengen se met en place ce qui va
devenir le ce qui va ce qui va se qui va
devenir le trafic international de de le
petit trafic international de stup plus
l'héroïne l'héroïne c'est vraiment
structuré l'héroï je rappelle juste un
truc l'héroï c'est pleine de la B opium
base donc le Liban qui va être
transporté jusqu'à Marseille par des
Arméniens parce qu'ils savent parler
avec les Libanais les Arméniens sont
ultra présents à Marseille se parce
qu'il a eu le génocide arménien ils sont
tous venus à Marseille donc il y a
beaucoup d'Arméniens donc parmi ces
Arméniens des bandits j'ai pas dit les
Arméniens sont des bandits j'ai dit
parmi ces Arméniens des bandits et
ceux-l vont travailler avec les cors
pourquoi des cors parce que les cors les
Corses communistes des années
40 avait étit avait avait fini dans les
camp de concentration alors eux ils
étaient pas ils étaient pas dans les
camps de la mort ils étaient au
nettoyage des librairies des camps de
concentration et ils sont tombés sur les
recettes de l'héroïne de baayère et donc
ils ont récupéré il av le sens du du
business ils ont vu tout de suite que
eux ils allaient pas en faire des
médicaments ils l'ont récupéré et à la
Libération ils sont sortis avec avec
l'héroïne la plus pure possible avec les
recettes allemandes donc Bayer le le top
du top le savoir-faire allemand quoi
vraiment au top du top quand l'État
français part en guerre en en Indochine
ou plutôt défend l'Indochine
imine fait du du du
du fait de l'héroïne et donc pour
empêcher pour pour casser les
financement d' chimine on va payer on va
faire nous-même de l'héroïne l'État
français et on va prendre
l'administration coloniale c'est les
Corses donc on connait les Corses donc
on prend nos corses et ils disent ben
nous on sait faire de l'héroïne ils font
de l'héroïne là-bas la guerre est perdue
quand même et là comme fait souvent
l'État français on t'a aidé puis après
on te lâche enfin tu nous a aidé plutôt
il les lâche il les lâche il rentre à
Marseille plutôt au panier donc c'est là
où il y a les cors et une fois qu'ils
sont sont là les Arméniens sont là
l'opium base elle arrive par là la
causeanostre commence à vraiment donc
donc dire la mafia italienne aux
États-Unis et en place on est dans les
années 50 hein ça commence par là hein
le et et à ce moment-là on voit la
possibilité de mettre en place cette
méthode c'est-à-dire des chimistes qui
vont faire de l'héroïne à Marseille et
ça va partir ensuite par par par bateau
principalement dans des voitures et pour
pour arroser New York où il y a et là
c'est les Italiens qui vont de là-bas
par que mais entre autres et donc et là
c'est important à New York dès les
années 60 ils connaissent ce qu'on
connaît nous maintenant exactement
pareil regardez un épisode de Stark HCH
c'est en version sympa ce qui se passe à
Marseille ou ce qui se passe c'est
exactement ça on a les mecs qui dambul
un peu camé des tocars qui qui qui qui
sont prêts à tout c'est c'est pas du
tout un grand banditisme c'est un
banditisme c'est plus du banditisme de
survie non plus mais c'est un are c'est
un banditisme que je dis entrepreneurial
voilà donc
90 Schengen ça change un peu la fin de
la French Connection le dernier réseau
de French Connection c'est le réseau
océan et le réseau Topaz il tombe en 98
99 je sais plus exactement la date par
là qui en a dans le réseau Topaz Tony
Languille un type que je connais très
bien je l'ai je l'ai filmé plusieurs
fois et je m'entends bien avec lui
Antoine cossu son vrai nom beaufère du
belge qui a comme protégé Farid beramin
euh un jeune de de enfin jeune à
l'époque de Saint-Joseph une cité
populaire Marseillaise et qui va faire
ses classe de banditisme à Marignane et
donc plutôt dans les machin à sous au
début c'est plutôt ça les bingos et puis
après les stupes un peu enfin il faisait
déjà l'héroïne topase océan mais après
il va faire des stubes sur place et
finalement berama dit le rôtisseur c'est
celui qui tuait les gens et qui brûlait
derrière mais lui il faisait pas ça il
faisait ça pour une seule raison lui il
faisait ça pour faire disparaître les
traces pour soit plus long donc il
savait quelle quantité d'essence fallait
mettre il savait et après les les jeunes
derrière ont eu l'impression que CIT une
signature qu' fallait faire ça et il
brûlit mais il brûlait à moitié il brûle
et en fait ils ont pas compris que le
but c'est de de tout brûler soit tu le
fais bien soit tu le fais pas et et
berama donc Gil rossisseur un mec ultra
intelligent ultra violent j'ai bien
connu sa niè qui était plus âgé que lui
qui m'a raconté beaucoup de choses sur
lui un type qui avait un cancer de
l'estomac qui a pris de la coque toute
sa vie pour la douleur ça le rendait
complètement violent et qui a au moment
où il allait se faire opérer une
opération il y avait une chance sur deux
de de de s'en sortir ou de mourir il
s'est plus ou moins laissé tuer comme un
viking je dirais c'est-à-dire il va à un
endroit où il sait qu'il va se faire
buter et il va arme la main il tend en
tuer un ou deux passages il meurt voilà
c'est c'est c'est 2006 et là c'est 2000
2001 il n'y a pas de règlement de compte
à Marseille éro en 2000 un seul en 2001
pourquoi pas parce que le banditisme est
faible au contraire parce qu'il est très
fort et donc pas de concurrence le
règlement de compte c'est le le c'est le
uniquement le le l'indicateur de la
concurrence de rien d'autre ça ne veut
rien dire d'autre et donc 2001 pas de
pas de concurrence euh il se sent
pousser des ailes ou plutôt il voit
qu'il va de toute façon mourir de son
cancer donc fu en avant il s'attaque à
des Corses il tue ro Colombani un Corse
qui faisait la machine à sous il le tu
de façon atroce vengeance en 2006 il se
fait tuer et là quand il se fait tuer il
a il a 13 lieutenants c'est très très
biblique il a 13 lieutenants une fois
qu'il est mort en 2006 donc il va y
avoir plein de morts ils vont
s'entretuer pendant un moment et ensuite
sur entre 2006 et je dirais 2010 il va y
avoir des morts li à la fin de berama
donc des tentatives de ils arrivent pas
à reprendre l'Empire berama mais ils
essaient de reprendre des des bouts de
trucs et c'est là que le que que ça va
se transformer c'est là qu'arrive c'est
là que naissent ceux qui sont
aujourd'hui à la tête des enfin qui ont
qui ont été parce qu'ils sont tous en
prison qui ont été à la tête de la D et
Yoda et
compagnie les gros bandits encore en vie
sont en prison vont pas tarder à sortir
ça faire mal euh les frères va faire mal
parce qu'ils vont vouloir reprendre le
terrain pour utiliser leur jargon
c'est-à-dire que on te dit que un un
dealer gère de sa prison non il se
débrouille de sa prison il gère pas
c'est un milieu le deal qui un milieu de
trahison le milieu d'entraide c'est le
braquage le braquage c'est de l'entraide
il y a un conducteur un qui est avec
l'arme un qui surveille un qui remplit
et tout le monde dépend de tout le monde
dans les stupes c'est un lieu de
carotage de de carotage c'està-dire
c'est carotage c'est prendre le produit
de l'autre ce qu'ils appellent
l'enveloppe à Marseille ça change d'un
endroit à un autre c'est le raquette
c'estàdire tu tu travailles là mais moi
je te fil je teis tu me files le pognon
et puis de coups de pression permanent
de trahison interne ça n'arrête pas
c'est pour ça qu'il y a beaucoup de
frattereries qui travaillent ensemble
parce que ça limite quand même les les
les risques mais des fois même des
frères c'est pas toujours ça et même des
copains d'enfance souvent ils se
connaissent au club de ballon ou à
l'école hein c'est c'est ça le point de
départ c'est rarement communautaire
c'est rarement les Algériens c'est très
très rare ça c'est plutôt le club de
ballon le le le pied d'immeuble en
France c'est plutôt rare mais en
Belgique en France en France en Belgique
tu vas avoir plus de communautaires
ouais à molembec il y a une
particularité enfin une particularité je
sais pas mais en tout cas c'est nous on
a moins ça après moi je connais très
bien Marseille je connais un peu la
région parisienne mais je je je pense
que c'est un peu plus communautaire en
région parisienne alors là si je devais
parler de ça mais je veux pas le faire
tout de suite ça serait mon ma casquette
marseillologue parce
que Marseille a la par particular a été
de de concentrer toutes les
problématiques françaises en un seul
lieu et a réussi aussi à avoir le pire
et le meilleur c'està-dire il y a des
choses qui marchent à Marseille
notamment la la comment appeler ça sans
utiliser un mot galvodé mais le le lien
social c'està dire que on n pas très peu
de communautarisme à Marseille on s'en
fout de savoir c'est algérien tout ça
après oui hein tu tu le revendiques en
permanence he moi mon côté Corse je
revendique ça ça mais ça c'est autre
chose mais ça travaille ensemble dans le
légal dans l' illégal dans le voilà ça
travaille ensemble sans trop chercher à
savoir il y a peu de communautarisme tu
vas avoir des îlos mais ça dure pas
généralement quand il y a un îo de
communautarisme si je prends le
banditisme il va y avoir actuellement
les comoriens qui vont travailler
ensemble sur une ou deux cités un peu
plus il vont s'appeler le gang des
blacks pas très original et eux ils sont
violents pourquoi ils ont pas d'autre
choix parce qu'en fait ils ont peu de
lien ils viennent d'arriver depuis pas
très longtemps ils ont peu de de ils ont
peu de réseau et donc quand tu as peu de
réseau tu as meilleure comp c'est la
violence elle est elle est tout de suite
mobilisable
violent il y en a peu qui sont capables
de le faire déjà faut se rassurer il y
en a peu qui sont capables d'être
vraiment violent je parle pas mettre un
taquet je parle casser un bras scarifier
couper un doigt il y en a peu qui savent
faire ça heureusement et mais ceux qui
savent faire ça et après faut penser à
faire aller dessus il y a l'exploitation
d'ailleurs d'une faiblesse he pour aller
là-dessus et en fait voilà là on va
avoir un communautaire mais très
rapidement on se rend compte que quand
le réseau black se met en place petit à
petit on va avoir le copain du foot qui
rentre un Algérien on va voir un copain
de cors qui rentre puis qu'il y a encore
pas beaucoup de corses dans les dans les
cité un petit gitan qui va arriver on va
vooir voilà petit à petit le réseau des
BLS il y a des blancs dedans tout comme
la des mafia Algérie il y a pas que des
algérien mais alors ça aucun rapport
quoi d'illeurs je vous dirai com comment
c'est né vous verrez que l'Algérie ça
aucun rapport
mais en fait voilà c'est c'est c'est
c'est cette cette ce communautarisme il
faut faut faut faut l'enlever quoi
islamisme du du du daeschien qui recrute
il y a eu il y a eu alors toujours
Marseille hein il y a eu deux deux
points de stup qui étaient liés à de
l'islamisme on peut les nommer parce
qu'ils ont été médiatisés il y en a un
qui était à à à saintmoron quartier le
plus pauvre de France là où j'ai grandi
dans le 3isème arrondissement c'est des
noyaux villageois tu as l'impression que
tu es dans un village et pas du tout
dans une cité j'ai fait un film sur haré
qui s'appelle péri sur la ville qui est
sur YouTube sur le sur ça où je suis
dans un réseau de stupe je filme le
réseau au quotidien visage découvert
et donc à côté de ce là où je filme un
peu plus loin il y
avait ce qu'on pensait être des
salafistes mais c'est sûrement vrai
d'ailleurs et ils ont eu peur que ce
soit des tacfidistes c'estàd des
salafist qui passe à l'acte et qui
finance des actes armés je peux pas dire
que ça serait arrivé ou non toujours
est-il qu'en effet ils avaient le pied
des deux côtés je pense moi mon avis
perso pour connaître des gens qui
étaient que c'était plus des trafiquants
qui s'étent un peu déguisé un islamiste
histoire de de d'avoir la paix que des
vrais islamistes qui voulaient faire
leur pognon mais comme au milieu il y
avait des vrais islamistes notamment un
imam qui a été viré je sais plus son nom
qui était viré en Algérie bon ce mélange
là a fait qu'on a tapé dedans et la
police a évidemment c'est normal à à
enlever ça il y a eu le réseau des
Olivier qui est une cité qui a qui a une
cité souvent violente en qui est souvent
citée on l'entend souvent elle est elle
est prês de la fac saint-gérôme enfin
c'est c'est un lieu un lieu important
des stup à Marseille à un moment il y a
eu il y a eu l'islam à vitolle l'islam
avait pris à un moment un réseau mais
avec les armes quand je dis l'islam vous
voyez ce que je veux dire des des des
islamistes des barbus quoi des mais ça
dure pas pourquoi et pourquoi à
Marseille l'islamisme est pas très fort
il existe hein il y a des il y a il y a
al le côté traditionnaliste oui tradit
le voile les truc ça c'est c'est un peu
monté mais c'est tradit c'est pas
l'islamisme c'est tradit et souvent en
plus ils sont tradit l'hiver et l'été
ils sont moins tradit quoi parce qu'à
Marseille lestait c'est cool donc les
filles elles se voient à un moment puis
ellesarrêtent les mecs pareil enfin
l'islamisme il a enfin ce côté trad j'ai
fait un film qui s'appelle j laabas
basket là-dessus ça ça va ça vient en
c'est très bien comme ça en plus hein ça
ça s'adapte en fait ils ont un islamisme
tout relatif et
euh et donc il y a pas vraiment ça il y
a même un autre phénomène c'est comme il
y a c'est des gens pragmatiques c'est
des gens pauvres à Marseille comme c'est
des gens pragmatiques il laisse pas
monter les l'islam il parce que un jour
c'est un un type à moi un type qui a
grandi avec moi à saintmoron qui est qui
est un boxeur qui a été c'est le fait
que tu dises un type à moi ouais c'est
un petit peu un côté voyou c'est un type
à moi il est dans mon mon corp alors en
plus lui pas du tout hein lui il peut
m'écraser avec un doigt en une seconde
il a été champion de boxe et euh il a vu
tellement d'horreur dans le monde de la
boxe d'horreur dans le sens coque truc
voilà une dépravation qui y allait pas
du tout il a lâché il est devenu plus ou
moins islamiste hein VO pas plus ou
moins je crois qu'il a même étaé un des
hommes à un moment alors il y a de la
légende du vrai de de Ben Laden donc il
était quand même il allait assez loin et
un jour je je vais boire un un thé à la
menth avec lui à à Félix Piat et il me
montre des Minos il me fait tu vois eux
les premiers qui les prêchent les
remporte le réseau au moins exactement
il a dit exactement ce qu'il faut dire
le premier qui les prêche les remporte
sauf qu'à Marseille le réseau il prêche
plus facilement que que que l'Islam sur
pareil c'est fragile puis en plus moi je
veux pas m'accommoder du fait que
l'islam radical ne monte pas parce que
on a un réseau de stupe on peut pas non
plus faire ça par contre faut se
rappeler aussi que l'islam radical monte
pas pour de bonnes choses très
marseillaise une identité locale forte
alors qui se voit dans le club alors il
y a les pour et les contre là il y a
tous ceux qui détestent l'OM tous ceux
qui adorent c'est pas la question chaque
ville a son club et le club il est
important pour une ville voilà et donc
et en fait c'est un étendard ça permet
de de de de montrer son son sa fierté ou
plutôt le fait d'exister collectivement
et et à Marseille l'identité elle reste
encore elle est parfois
fragilisée notamment par les années de
politique Godin qui a fragil disait ça
en en en découpant la ville mais moi je
suis pas un fan de jou vous le
comprendrez aisément mais par exemple la
hype autour du rap marseillais de des
Marseillais voilà c'est ça veut bien
dire qu'il y a une sorte de fédération
autour de ça et puis euh donc voilà il y
a cette identité marseillaise qui est
forte ça c'est une force marseillaise
qui est rare pour une ville de cette
taille parce qu'avoir une identité à une
toute petite échelle de village on l'
hein dans les clubs de rugby on le voit
ils sont à fond mais à l'échelle de 1
million d'habitants ils sont ils sont
800 et quelques mais avec le pourtour tu
fais un million très vite c'est rare et
et la deuxième chose c'est le le tissu
social qui est exceptionnel à Marseille
parce que il date du 19e siècle avec les
le catholicisme social qui avait mis en
place tout ça et ensuite les communistes
qui se sont greffés sur le Catholic
social il sont pas mis en concurrence et
on a beaucoup eu de prêtres ouvriers à
Marseille il y en a encore aujourd'hui
dans mon film pér sur lav en a un et et
qui fait du social malgré le manque de
moyens encore de façon très efficace
dans le sport dans la culture dans c'est
vraiment un exemple plein dire il y a
pas d'équivalent en France de ce qui est
ce que Marseille est capable de faire en
social c'est pour ça que je supporte pas
quand je vois des associations
parisiennes je dis parisiennne je parle
comme un Marseillais c'està direire des
associations non marseillaises ça
s'appelle des parisiens pour nous qui
vont profiter de la misère marseillaise
pour aller dire on va on va aider les
gens là-bas on va pas aider les gens
là-bas on va prendre des subventions
pour pour aider les gens ça ça
m'inupporte je suis totalement contre je
vais pas dire des noms mais il y a du
monde et ils viennentonnaont ils se
reconnaîtront et et ça c'est un calvaire
quoi c'est mais c'est un calvre à
Marseille ça va être un calvre quand ils
vont faire pareil dans la BAN
strasbourgeoise ou à Toulouse au Mirail
hein c'est la même histoire hein quand
on on voit la valeur des pauvres voilà
les pauvres une valeur marchande y
compris dans le social à Marseille il y
a du clientélisme autour de de
l'associative qui est ancien qui a qui a
mué qui a qui a qui a qui a muté hein il
on est passé d'un clientélisme du riche
dans les années 90 début 2000 avec guini
ça veut dire je donne beaucoup d'argent
à des assauts et elle me rendent ça mais
par contre elle bosse on est passé à ça
un clientélisme du pauvre ou celle qui a
succédé à à Guerini ne donne rien aux
assauts rien et celle qui veulent vivre
sont à ses pieds et ell donnent la béqué
on est dans de la survie et ces gens-là
ils travaillent ils font ce qu'ils
peuvent souvent il ils s'impliquent
beaucoup mais droit elle a droit de vie
de mort sur eux et donc ce clientélisent
mais pire que l'autre c'estd tous les
clientélistes sont pas les mêmes hein et
donc aujourd'hui ce clientélistent du
pauvre qui permet en fait les sous non
utilisés pour le clientélisme associatif
il est utilisé pour l'immobilier tu
donnes du pognon aux copains de
l'immobilier qui vont faire du blé sur
les quartiers qui se paupérisent parce
que les trafics de SUP ils servent à ça
ENF c'est pas pensé moi j'y crois pas
hein je vais pas là-dedans il y a pas un
moment des gens qui sont réunis qui on
dit on va paupériser ça se fait à à
l'opportunité des quartiers populaires à
Marseille c'est la majorité de la ville
donc Marseille c'est quand tu dis
quartier populaire c'est quartier pauvre
ce que vous vous appelez les banlieux
mais nous on n pas de banlieux non mais
vous vous les Parisiens
ce qu'on appelle les banlieux euh nous
il y a pas de banlieux les banlieux
c'est les banlieux pavillonnaire on a
l'impression d'être aux États-Unis on a
l'impression d'être dans le film junau
ou un truc comme ça c'est ronnac Gignac
vitrol hisre c'est alors c'est pas riche
c'est pas pauvre non plus c'est du
pavillon il y aurait de quoi raconter ça
serait super d'ailleurs il devrait y
avoir des films parce que c'est
visuellement très très France France
périphérique aujourd'hui ça vote à
l'extrême droite alors qu'avance à voter
coco c'est intéressant hein c'estes liux
hein mais c'est pas la banlieue tel
qu'on entend Wh tout ça c'est pas ça
nous les wesh il sont dans la ville et
le quartier le plus pauvre il est au
centre ville ça c'est les villes
américaines c'est Baltimore c'est des TR
c'est c'est pas c'est pas les villes
françaises il y a pas d'équivalent en
France et donc on a on a la moitié
un/ers de la population sous le seuil de
pauvreté 300000 habitants la moitié de
la population qui est pauvre dans dans
la classifications et on a le premier
quartier le plus riche de France après
les quatre quartiers parisiens
donc c'est la cadonelle à Marseille qui
sur l'ISF donc on a le plus riche hors
Paris plus riche de la province dans
Marseille c'est la capitale Paris c'est
la capitale de la France Marseille c'est
la capitale de la province c'est
vraiment comme ça que je perçois c'est
pour ça que souvent les gens aiment
beaucoup Marseille sauf Paris qui aiment
pas Marseille parce que justement il y a
ce y a cet antagonisme là et et
je te rassure on aime bien Marseille
ici il y a une sorte de il y a une sorte
de après le Marseillais paranoïque il
est là pour ça le Marseillais paranoïque
he c'est c'est c'est c'est c'est on est
là pour ça quoi mais euh c'est des c'est
des c'est de la de la rébellion petit
prix hein la rébellion marseillaise
c'est de la rébellion pour pour
continuer à exister et ça marche hein
par ailleurs hein et donc tu es dans un
un un système social qui fait que depuis
la fin des années 70 donc là je fais de
la marseillologie mais mais ça raconte
vraiment la France en fait depuis la fin
des années 70 Marseille était construit
sur les colonies c'est le business
colonial alors pas la pas pas la
bordelaise avec des des des des issu du
commerce triangulaire il y a très
longtemps donc des esclaves et qui après
s'est adapté à autre chose on va pas les
les maintenir dans l'esclavage ils sont
pas fait que ça heureusement mais en
tout cas où il y a des riches très
riches Bordeaux c'est pour ça que la la
guerre avant que tapis est et deiso il
crée l'antagonisme Marseille-Paris pour
des raisons de business le vrai
antagoniste c'est Marseille-Bordeaux
c'est om contre contre Bordeaux hein
c'est ça le vrai antagonis Marseille la
populaire Bordeaux la bourgeoise qui
sont deux ports coloniaux et Marseille
était construit sur les colonies fin des
années 70 ça commence vraiment à
terminer les colonies deuxième choc
pétrolier Marseille s'est foutu se met
en place pour que les gens qui sont là
ils vont pas partir hein ils sont ils
ont déjà tous fu quelque chose la fin la
guerre ou la misère ils sont tous
arrivés du pire de quelque part donc ils
vont pas partir encore bah la solution
qui est trouvée c'est de créer des des
territoriaux de partout on embauche à la
mairie des kilomètres de gens on
embauche de partout on fait des on fait
voilà des territoriaux des territoriaux
et donc on fait du clientélisme syndical
avec force ouvr hier un peu la CGT sur
le port mais surtout la Force Ouvrière
pour les territoriaux on fait du
clientélis syndical et on fait
euh une politique qui est principal
basée pour occuper les gens et il y a
pas de création de valeur aucune donc
c'est une ville pauvre sans création de
valeur même si ça s'améliore pour
Marseille aujourd'hui c'est quand même
pas Lyon parce qu'on a jamais été aidé
par l'État parce que là il y a le plan
Marseille en grand plan Marseille en
grand il lâche pas un centime ils
annoncent mais il lâchent rien donc donc
shirac avait annoncé un milliard 5 qui
est jamais venu
Sarkozi avait annoncé le même milliard 5
qui est jamais venu et là Macron annonce
un milliard 5 qui vient pas et les gens
additionnent en disant [__] on donne
beaucoup à Marseille oui mais ça vient
jamais ça vient jamais c'est onaditionne
pas c'est le même milliard 5 qui se
déplace en fait donc on ajoute ce
clientélisme là qui s'installe qui va
paupériser la ville parce qu'en fait on
on est en survie en survie politique
perpétuelle il y a pas de création de
richesse donc ce système clientéliste il
est pas il produit rien donc ça s'use
les les logements sociaux petit à petit
tu pistonnes plus pour y rentrer tu
pistonnes pour en sortir donc c'est plus
difficile le petite l'emploi à la ville
tout ça l'emploi à la métropole au
département à la région il y en a plus
c'est plein donc tu fais des petits
emplois de vacataire tu fais des petit
la merdouille la merdouille donc c'est
clientlis de la misère moins les gens de
choses plus tu les achètes avec rien
avec des cacahuètes le problème c'est
que cette paupérisation là elle va finir
par dégrader les quartiers physiquement
ce qui fait que a l'effondrement de la
rue d'Aubagne le 5 novembre 2018 où des
un immeuble s'effondre d'un coup et tue
h personnes qui sont dedans euh on va me
dire c'est arrivé ailleurs non pas sous
ce pas dans ce phénomène là c'est-à-dire
un phénomène politique un délaissement
volontaire
politique des avertissements des des des
des spécialistes qui disent ça part en V
des gens qui font des mails en disant
s'il vous plaît ne passez pas mon
immeuble en péril parce que sinon il va
plus me rapporter d'argent bah ça abouti
à 8 morts alors on pourrait se dire
c'est c'est dramatique déjà pour
commencer mais on pourrait se dire c'est
anecdotique presque ça fait partie de de
l'histoire dramatique d'une ville il y
en a eu beaucoup Marseille en a eu
beaucoup d'autres mais c'est tellement
représentatif de ce que j'appelle la
paupérisation volontaire ou en tout cas
si elle est pas volontaire si elle est
pas calculée elle est elle est il y a un
laissé faire parce qu'en fait la
paupérisation permet une destruction qui
permet une asceptisation je crois pas
l'entrification la septisation c'est le
roué quartier populaire marseillais du
10e arrondissement euh qu'on a laissé se
dégrader on l'a détruit donc noyau
villageois hein trois fenêtres
marseillais c'est très beau on adore ça
on est dans un film à gedigan c'est
super la vie marseillaise comme on aime
les gens sur le trottoir ça discute un
truc a disparu dans les autres villes
qui existe à Marseille on rase ça et on
fait monter des immeubles avec Red de
chaussé parking pour pas qu'il y a des
gens dehors et Netflix dans les étages
comme ça au moins les gens ils sortent
pas et pendant ce temps tu fais pas de
gestion d'espace public c'est pas la
peine ils sont plus dehors donc ça ça a
commencé au rouer on l'a fait à la
Capelette ça c'est une asceptisation
parce que dedans tu mets la même
population enfin tu mets des cafistes
plus précisément tu mets des primos
accédentss donc des jeunes mais les
jeunes dès qu'ils ont des petits qui on
5 6 ans faut les mettre à l'école et
l'école
elle est dégueulasse à Marseille il y a
pas eu de il y a pas eu de les écoles
elles ont été délaissées il y a eu c'est
dramatique vous imaginez même pas le
lEtat délabrement on est dans le pays du
carmonde donc les écoles sont telles que
Ben ceux qu' qui ont pas de piston pour
les mettre dans un privé parce que le
privé c'est substitué mais même le privé
est dégueulasse c'està dire qu'il faut
il y a deux ou trois privés deux ou
trois niveaux mais quand tu arrives pas
quandas ni les sous ni le piston surtout
pour mettre dans le bon privé tu es mort
les jeunes ils s'en vont ils vont la
perte et là tu as la paupérisation c'est
parti tu commence à avoir des
copropriétés dégradées c'est même pas
des bailleurs c'est copropriétés dégradé
donc là on en a plein on en a énormément
à Marseille Félix P parlais ça la cité
corau Maison Blanche
calisté sont des lieux où petit à petit
dégradation dégradation puis après ils
sont patients prend 10 15 ans rénovation
en rue des milliards d'euros arrivent
pour le BTP et le BTP il a besoin de de
cette rénovation alors l'en rue c'est
bien mais l'en rue répété tout le temps
au même endroit c'est bizarre c'est ça
le truc mais l' rue c'est super on so je
pas entier en rue mais le parce que l'
rue c'est aussi un peu d'argent du BTP
qui est donné c'est pas que de l'argent
public he il y a le BTP qui qui qui met
à la poche enfin qui qui cotise et qui
met en rue donc il y a pas que de
l'argent public mais c'est de l'argent à
euxmême en fait derrière travail il faut
savoir que trop souvent on a le
banditisme qui obtient les marchés qui
va faire travailler ensuite des société
du BTP donc je ne dis pas le BTP verreux
je dis un certain banditisme fait
travailler le BTP de gré de force et va
même raquetter c'est-à-dire le BTP le le
le le le banditisme obtenir un un un
projet de deun construction d'un
immeuble et ils vont faire travailler
des gens du BTP mais il vont leur dire
en plus vous payez pour travailler Bich
tu es vrai hein les combats de chiens
moi c'est au parc Coro c'est pas au parc
Coro d'ailleurs je j'adore le nom de ce
parc le parc de font obscure on a
l'impression à Marseille l'impression
qu'on est dans Harry Potter ils font des
ils font des des des combats de de
chiens là là-dedans et des fois il on
trouve un chien qui cé parce qu'il a
tellement pris que il le brûle bon
eTTH évidemment que quand tu es dans ces
sociétés là ultra comment on dit
maintenant masculiniste en fa virile là
où on n pas des tapetttes quoi il faut
il faut toujours montrer ses muscles en
fait c'est les gens c'est des gens qui
sont vulnérables et faibles qui se
montrent fort donc comme tu as une
vulnérabilité sociale il faut avoir une
force au moins physique et et et
d'apparat quoi donc là tu vas avoir
quelque chose o c'est que dans le combat
la bord combat de rue ce genre de truc
donc évidemment que ça apparaît il y a
il y a rien de rien de surprenant il
faut moi je suis pas choqué par ça je
suis pas surpris c'est évident et donc c
et donc ça accélère la popérisation il y
a même eu et là je vais pas dire de nom
des familles compliquées connues comme
étant compliqué des bouquans quoi hein
en parle comme de Marseillais c'est-à
dire qu'ils sont ils vont tout le bordel
quoi qu'il arrive ils sont pas nombreux
hein il y il y a quelques familles sur
Marseille 10 hein mais dès que tu as
besoin de de de de de faire partir des
des classes moyennes d'un quartier tu
les mets dedans tu attends 5 à 10 ans
tout le monde est parti après tu
récupères la famille tu la mets ailleurs
du logement social ailleurs et tu as
récupéré le quartier ça c'est fait dans
le 3è arrondissement là où j'ai grandi
moi à saintmouron ils nous ont mis une
famille Ben ils ont mis la famille en 83
mes parents sont partis en 89 c'est plus
possible et donc euh et ça ça ça perdure
enfin c'est pas une stratégie
marseillaise on va le trouver partout
hein c'est pas donc tu as besoin cette
popérisation permet avoir un jeu parce
que le pognon il se fait principalement
par l'immobilier hein quand on parle de
l'OM maourte on dit ah il perd des sous
perd des sous il perd pas des sous
maourt il perd des sous a l'OM il on
gagne énormément avec l'immobilier en
fait le le truc le nerf de la guerre
dans ce pays qui produit plus grandchose
c'est l'immobilier donc tout n'est pas
verreux non tout n'est pas verreux loin
de là mais ce que je je en fait je dis
pas que c'est verreux je dis que le
système est tel que
paupérisation donc pour la bonne cause
on rénove souvent détruit reconstruit ça
c'est le top hein c'est le moins cher et
puis et après come on remet les mêmes
populations dans les mêmes conditions
avec alors parfois on est passé par les
primo accidents après on a mis des
cafistes et après on a mis carrément des
c'est primo accident cafistes c'est ceux
qui vont toucher la CAF et au bout d'un
moment on met même plus des cafistes on
met des le le bout du bout c'est des S
papiers qui se font raquetter quoi
quelque part ça c'est le bout du bout ça
arrive pas partout mais voilà c'est
c'est le truc un peu caricatural c'est
ça tu as paupérisé ton ton tu as
paupérisé ton ton quartier tu as plus
qu'à l'assptiser tu fais monter des
immeubles bas de plafond carré le
minimum possible en terme de
d'architecture et qui vont se détériorer
à une vitesse fulgurante tu les vois se
détériorer et c'est reparti la cité des
flamaments construite en 77 rénovée en
84 rénovée ensuite et R rénové récemment
c'est pas vieux 77 il y a des immeubles
qui tiennent non rénové en permanence on
va me dire c'est les gens ils font
n'importe quoi non à la rigur les boîes
aux lettres et moi j'y crois pas si sur
boî aux lettres je vais m'expliquer mais
la plupart du temps ces immeubles c'est
surtout ils ont tellement de mal faaçon
qu'au bout d'un moment ça suff fure de
partout donc les gens qui ont trois sous
les gens qui ont des possibilités de
partir ils se barrent et ils restent que
les boucans dedans quand je dis les
boucans c'est presque affectueux par que
comme moi je parle comme à marseillais
il faut que je fasse attention
c'està-dire les gens qui sont dans une
dans un tel état social des cassos ouais
j'oserais pas dire ça mais ils sont dans
un état soci
tel que ils sont que dans le le dans le
dans le sentimental tout le temps et ils
sont dans la pulsion en permanence et
ils sont hyper sensible mais dans le
sens s'énervé engrainé sans arrêt
insulter puis au contraire tu le sang tu
mon frère la demi-heure d'après tu le
pire psychiatrique alors ça ça va
arriver ça il y en a ça ça c'est un truc
important mais juste pour finir la les
passages
àceptisation ça permet en permanence
donc de générer de de du fut d'argent et
donc le dealer lui il va être on le
laisse pas faire parce que on voit aussi
ça crée des morts ça crée des situations
de drame je dis pas qu'on laisse faire
mais je dis que on nessaie pas
d'attaquer le mal
euh réellement d'où il vient c'està
direire on laisse les lésions sortir on
essaie d'enlever les lésions on se les
dealer quand même s'il pouvait ne pas
être là si ça pouvait se détériorer sans
les dealer ça serait pas mal c'est dire
que pour moi le le le le problème c'est
une sorte de j'ose pas dire la maladie
parce que les gens qui l'ont ils en ont
marre d'entendre ça mais une maladie
grave
qui euh qui qui a comme comme symptômes
des léions des pustules des boutons qui
sont les trafics de stupe mais en fait
la prostitution la prostitution je vais
y venir aussi donc on va dire une
délinquence une criminalité je parle de
celle-là celle de quartier celle-là pas
la criminalité internationale c'est
autre chose tu m'autorises à te couper
juste une seconde il faut des fois c'est
vrai dis-moi tu as pas l'impression
aussi qu'on a laissé s'installer le le
le trafic de ceup pour à la fois sédater
la population et calmer la population
qui est dans une région où ça ça produit
pas de richesse c'est-à-dire un deuxième
filet pseudo social on a laissé les
politiques de gauche ont tourné la tête
parce que ça faisait vivre un peu parce
que ça sédate les gens parce que les mec
qui fument du cheit qui fument de
l'herbe la plupart du temps ils sont
dépressifs il y a très peu de récréatif
qui qui fument tous les jours tu as pas
l'impression qu'il y a quand même un
facteur de on tourne la tête parce que
bah ça fait rentrer un peu de blé moi le
résultat il va dans l'autre sens
c'est-à-dire que c'est le même résultat
mais moi pour moi c'est plutôt on ne
sait plus quoi faire de ces quartiers
les communistes savaient tant que
c'était des des ouvriers pour des
raisons bassement politique hein dire tu
travailles tu as ton assaut tu votes
pour moi je te fais une assaut de ballon
une assaut de club d'échec une assautù
tu vas voir des films ça s'appelait la
culture populaire c'était super on les
apprenait à être des bons des bons gars
de gauche quoi ou de gauche gauche quoi
on les apprenait à être ça les
communistes fin 80 fin des années 80
Game Over les socialistes prennent la
main un petit peu avant he ça s'est
chevauché eux ils sont sur touche pas
mon pote le bon petit beurre tu es mon
ami et ils font le clientélisme
associatif vote pour moi mais sur un
clientélisme associatif c'est pas encore
trop malsin dans le sens où ils font
quand même un peu mais on maintient
quand même ses populations dans ce
qu'elles sont parce qu'en fait il y a eu
un changement il y a plus d'ouvriers on
change les ouvriers c'est pas une
question de de de de nationalité parce
que des ouvriers algériens il y en
avaient à Marseille en avait plein hein
et euh ils étaient communistes hein dans
les dans les mines lançoises il y a eu
des Algériens hein donc c'est c'est pas
marseillais hein
et d'un seul coup tu te retrouves avec
une population soit d'auto-entrepreneurs
soit de commerçants soit de chôeurs
principalement et de sans emploi
chômeurs ils ont travaillé et tou
quelque chose principalement sans emploi
la plupart contrairement à une idée
reçue une grande partie des gens ne
demandent même pas les les les aides
sociales dont ils ont dont ils pourraent
bénéficier parce qu'ils ont pas les
compétences pour les demander soit ils
savent pas que ça existe soit ils savent
pas le faire parce que on est quand même
dans une une baisse du niveau qui est
monumentale à cause des écoles à cause
du fait baisse du niveau c'està-dire que
tu te retrouves avec des
populations c'est qu' maîtrisent que 400
mots de vocabula ou ça parler et qui ne
comprennent pas aussi çavent plus
construire une une un raisonnement et
donc quand tu ne peux pas exprimer ce
que tu ressens qu'est-ce qui se passe de
phénomènes le massif c'est l'apathie
rien l'apathie donc la fumette la picole
à Marseille ça commence à peine mais
dans d'autres régions et picole et un
autre phénomène c'est la violence qui
est moins moins gros mais qui est
visible mais principalement l'apathie
c'est vraiment ils comprennent plus et
ils savent plus ben en fait une grande
partie une partie de la population on va
grand analphabètes ou des grands
retardés non non non c'est pas ça c'est
pas ça c'est
euh c'est des gens qui n'ont pas la
culture populaire que pouvaient donner
les communistes quand c'était des
ouvriers donc ils n'ont pas la
connaissance de leur droit quelque part
et en même temps c'est des gens qui à
qui on a fait arrêter l'école tôt parce
qu'on leur dit de toute façon il y a
plus de travail toi tu vas faire
mécanique au mieux généralement sarrête
tôt je te parle même pas ceux qui
rentrent dans les stup ceux qui ont une
parcours normale et donc tous ces
gens-là ils vont se retrouver à à une
certaine époque regarder la télé
maintenant regarder les écrans a tombé
le jeu la bouffe le tacos c'est la
première des c'est l'addiction
d'aujourd'hui he le sandwich le sucre le
gras le jeu c'est des voilà le le jeu le
le le l'autosportif tout ça moi je joue
pas du tout je connais pas grandchose
grattage tous c'est tous ces grattages
il joue il joue il joue à tout parce
qu'en fait c'est une addiction c'est
c'est une manière de de laadopamine
manière d'exister aussi donc ça c'est
vraiment un moteur aussi important mais
après ils sont pas idiots il y a aucune
raison qu'il ait une bêtise ou quoi que
ce soit au contraire même j'ai plein de
gamins Mo enfin je dis gamin parce que
dans mon dernier Liv je parle de gamin
mais il y en a qui sont plus gamins
aujourd'hui ils sont malins comme des
singes ils sont très très intelligents
dans l'intelligence de dans dans la dans
la dans la pensée c'estàdire ils sont
capables de créer une pensée par contre
sont pas capables de créer un
raisonnement parce que ça paraît rien
mais créer un raisonnement faut avoir un
petit peu soit être allé à l'école mais
c'est pas obligé soit avoir évoluer dans
un milieu où il y a du raisonnement pour
parler un petit peu là toujours je
prends ma casquette de Marseillais de
quartier quand j'étais Mino on voyait de
temps en temps des des jeunes qui
étaient des boucins et on se disait tu
imagines quand ils seront parents bah ça
y est ils sont parents voilà et donc ça
donne des des des gens qui derrière mais
c'est compliqué ils veulent bien éduquer
leurs enfants ils font au maximum ce
qu'il faut mais ils ont pas les outils
pour et donc c'est ce que dans le social
on appelle les compétences
psychosociales voilà c'est le nom
ronflant et c'est vrai que il faudrait
investir dans les compétences
psych-sociales c'est-à-dire qu'avant ce
que faisait le Parti communiste via des
assauts ce qu'on fait ensuite des
assauts ce qu'on fait l'école tout ça
plus personne ne le fait parce qu'on dit
il faut que la famille le fasse mais
personne nous on s'en rend pas compte
quand tu es de milieu classe moyenne ou
ou encore plus classis mais classe
moyenne ou ou ou basse ou de de banlieu
pavillonnaire la réalité c'est que tu as
des profs tu as des trucs tu tu es quand
même dans quelque chose où il y a un
raisonnement au quotidien mais quand tu
es délaissé ton raisonnement il
disparaît donc il faut surtout pas dire
sont plus con que d'autres c'est pas ça
mais il y a une perte de raisonnement et
quand tu raisonnes pas tu perds c'est là
je viens sur ta question sur est-ce
qu'on les maintient sous sous cloche
mais déjà tu votes plus tu votes plus
parce que moi quand je leur demande
c'est quoi la différence entre le
communisme et et et les communistes les
et le capitalisme ils ont aucune idée
mais aucune idée alors des fois on
rigole c'est quoi un communiste et il
gberge et la meilleure réponse que j'ai
dit c'est quelqu'un qui a la commune
d'Istre et quelque part c'est pas très
loin parce que commune communisme au
moins il était pas mal quoi mais tu sens
qu'en fait il y a pas cette histoire de
d'un côté on donne on donne à un
gouvernement qui partage je dis dans
dans l'utopie hein un gouvernement qui
partage de l'autre côté chacun a sa à
son à son à son bien son capital et va
le redistribuer par des salaire je parle
des deux utopies comme si ça marchait
bien ils pensent même pas comme ça ils
pensent pas là-dessus donc c'est pour ça
que quand on te dit les banlieu les
quartiers populaires vont se révolter
moi j'y crois absolument pas je vois pas
où est la révolte parce que pour se
révolter faut avoir une conscience
politique et là la conscience politique
c'est le dégoût c'est on s'occupe pas de
nous je peux je peux te recouper tu
m'autorises je t'autorise B tu es trop
bon tu es trop magnanime avec moi est-ce
que tu as suivi un petit peu les émeutes
quand il as eu le gamin qui bon on a dit
c'est les gens qui vont faire des petits
age de superet est-ce que tu as eu la
même lecture que nous c'était les c'est
les émeutes de la pauvreté oui quand
même alors je vais répondre à ta
question et en même temps finir de
réponse à l'autre parce que ça va se
coller fais-toi plaisir c'est-à-dire que
ces Cartier populaire est-ce qu'on les
maintient sous cloche en leur donnant du
poon de de des stupes en gros ça veut
dire de l'argent facile je vais venir et
pour que en gros pour qu'il nous gonfle
pas déjà et après je vais venir sur les
émotes quand tu fil quand il y a une
cité qui a un réseau de stupe plus le
réseau est gros plus ça se voit quand
cette cité là est saturée par la police
pendant un mois c'est une opération pour
moi ça sert à rien mais au moins ça
permet de voir quelque chose le mois
suivant en effet il y a des impayés dans
les loyers donc tu peux penser dans un
premier temps tu peux avoir l'apparence
que le les stupes soutiennent l'économie
mais en fait ça c'est pensé à très court
terme parce que quand la même la
paternelle c'est c'est une cité à
Marseille qui a qui a connu les guerres
Yoda des mafia qui est monté très haut
et aujourd'hui c'est une cité pour une
raison symbolique l'État met des moyens
considérables dessus pour qu'il y ait
pas de stup qui se remettent alors il
dépense beaucoup dessous parce qu' il
faut que symboliquement on n pas de
meurtrre là-bas de réseau donc
aujourd'hui il y a plus de réseau de
stup là-bas donc on peut voir ce qui se
passe et bien à ce coup réapparaissent
des commerces réapparaît une vie de
quartier avec de l'Association des fêtes
des des des où il jou du tamtam où ils
font des des ils font des comment
s'appelle il y a à la fois le tamtam et
les trucs de Bobo aussi là comment
s'appelle les trucs de
brésilien les bandas là je sais pas quoi
là ouis voilà ils font ça batouada il y
a des batouada dans les quartiers nord
où tu y a des gens du centreville qui
viennent faire des Batou c'est bien en
fait c'est une mixité qui se refait tu
te rends compte que des gens qui avaient
plus d'emploi on retrouve et finalement
il y a plus d'un payé parce qu'en fait
le réseau de stup empêche le
développement et le réseau de stup a le
même fonctionnement que le clientélisme
du pauvre il maintient en vie
quelques-uns je t'aide un peu mais tiens
mon service mais dès qu'il est plus là
donc il y a de la galère de 3 mois et
très rapidement en fait il y a un
développement qui se fait assez
naturellement on a même pas besoin de
l'État quand il y a pas de réseau les
mecs sont dégourdis ils bricolent des
bagnoles au début puis après ils monte
un vrai garage et puis après ils monte
un truc de transport puis après ils
achètent de taxis de VTC enfin
évidemment c'est ça les boulots he ils
deviennent pas tout de suite ingénieurs
les ingénieurs ils restent parfois il y
a beaucoup d'ingénieurs dans les qui
viennent des quartiers populaires il y a
quand même une partie des jeunes des
quartiers populair qui arrivve à faire
des études grâce au comment on appelle
ça la
laimulationascenseur social
discimulation positive ça a marché hein
c'est bien ça a permis à beaucoup de
jeunes de de faire des des des des
cursus de réussite alors comme il
s'appelle tout fix généralement c'est un
peu plus compliqué mais certains y
arrivent quand même à Marseille tu
arrivent parce que même en taappelant T
fi tu peux trouver du travail ce qui pas
le cas partout
et et donc il y a quand même du succès
faut le rappeler quoi il faut pas
focaliser que sur les les les que sur la
misère absolue je dirais que la misère
c'est c'est 30 % mais c'est beaucoup 30
% hein mais il y a 70 % qui vont avoir
une vie hein il va se passer quelque
chose on en parle pas parce qu'il y a
rien à dire finalement parce qu'ils ont
une vie à peu près comme tout le monde
avec leur galère et le leur leur
stigmatisation leur leurs problèmes mais
dans le dans la la cité une fois qu'elle
est qu'elle est que les stupes sont
partis si ça dure ben elle va elle va
elle va revivre et en plus les
institutions vont pouvoir y mettre des
des en place des choses et tu vas avoir
un retour des des des je sais pas moi de
commerce de proximité de de de de de
tout ce qui est nécessaire à la vie ce
que nous on a dont on se rend même pas
compte quand on sort et eux ils l'ont
pas parce que aujourd'hui qu'est-ce
qu'ils ont ils ont des centres de soins
dans des centres commerciaux histoire
que on regarde un peu leurs dents et
pour voir si les filles ont le cancer du
sein c'est ça hein grosso modo ils sont
tellement éloignés de tout euh c'est des
déserts médicaux les quartiers hein donc
aujourd'hui çable un peu à la campagne
française c'est totalement pareil c'està
dire je ne vois pas de différence entre
le rural le plus pauvre et le la la cité
je vois pas de différence moi je suis de
de de de Corse et la Corse je m'appelle
plus jeune mais Benedetti du côté de ma
mère donc j'ai j'ai écrit un livre qui
s'appelle altaroc sur la Corse et donc
j'ai une bonne connaissance aussi de la
Corse et la Corse région la plus pauvre
de France juste Corse côté Coré côté s
hen ça s'appelle donc le sud le centre
du Sud sen c'est vraiment si on prend le
sud enfin hen c'est vraiment le centre
la microrégion s'appelle
altaroc y a de tout là-bas des
intellectuels des
bandit comment il s'appelle le désert
qui est tout
làhaut desagriat c'est bien et euh ça y
est on commence l'école là pour voir non
mais ça va je vais tenir là-dessus et
euh d'habitude je connais que les lieux
où il y a des équipes de foot tu vois je
suis plutôt dans cette géographie très
marseillaise mais pour la Corse je m'en
sors un peu plus
euh la Corse milieu milieu enfin voilà
et donc qu'est-ce qu'ils ont quoi la
Corse milieu milieu pauvre très très
pauvre mais mais Cato ultra Cato donc
comme quoi ça pas de ça pas de lien
qu'est-ce qu'on a en Corse beaucoup
d'armes alors ça c'est culturellement ça
date de ça date romain non ça date
de de génois au au 13e siècle il y avait
tellement de chiens erants que les
bergers fallait qu'il butent les chiens
cétait leur loup à eux et il y avait
encore quelques ours qui avaient été
amenés par des montreur d'ours donc il
fallait buter quelques ours et donc il y
avait les armes et comme les bergers
c'est les cow-boys he les bergers hein
oh c'est pas des cowboys non c'est les
cowboys dans le sens c'est ceux qui font
les cowboys TR voilà c'est ça que je
veux dire pas des cowboys dans le sens
flingueur c'est c'est bergers c'est ceux
qui vont d'un point A à un point B de la
montagne à la mer en Corse pour et donc
benah il fallait un petit peu quand tu
avais à faaire aux paysans qui étaient
les ennemis des bergers que tu passais
sur leur terre il fallait un peu de
temps en temps montrer les trucs comme
c'était comme la Corse c'est une culture
de vendeta ça ça vient de la Kabilie
quand quand les Kabiles et les
Mauritaniens sont sont venus en Corse il
y a eu des invassions on a gardé la la
la on a gardé la la vendetta comme comme
fonctionnement politique parce que la
vendetta c'est aussi un fonctionnement
politique on a gardé couteau aussi il y
avait la pointe ça c'était génois et et
le couteau Vendetta et et donc la Corse
a garder cette culture qui donne deux
choses sont très importantes le secret
c'est-à-dire que quand il a en Vendette
il faut pas tout raconter là où des
Marseillais vont plus parler on a moins
cul du secret parce que c'est pas le
même il y a un intérêt à parler alors
Queen Corse il y a pas d'intérêt à
parler parce qu'il y a la vantette
vantette c'est un mouvement po c'est pas
un mouvement c'est un c'est une méthode
politique c'està-dire c'est quand avant
il y a pas uniquement on va tuer à celui
qui a tué avant d'État il y a un P de
Chéri c'est-à-dire quelqu'un qui va
rendre la loi tu as violé ma F ma ma
sœur donc dorénavant soit tu te maries
avec et tu me donnes des terres et tout
soit tu me donnes tant de terres tant de
truc tant de là et si ça se fait et s'il
y a pas d'accord onigouille c'est un
mouvement politique c'est on trouvait ça
en Albanie on trouvait ça c'est quelque
chose il y a un film qui s'appelle
l'homme l'homme qui voulut être roi qui
raconte ça très bien mais plutôt du côté
du Pakistan mais c'est exactement ce qui
était la Corse au au 18e siècle hein
donc ça c'est resté et une des cultures
en cor qui est resté c'est le fait de ne
pas quand on voit les Corses il sont
l'inverse des Parisiens quand quand il
faut payer la la note ils se battent
pour payer les Corses là où les
Parisiens ils font semblant de chercher
les les ils font semblant de chercher
leurs pognon pour que chacun pay pour
payer B pourquoi ils se battent pour
payer parce que le clan le clan c'est
dans la vente d'État c'est important le
clan c'est une famille forte comme une
famille de seigneorie hein qui va avoir
des sous-familles qui à son service toi
quand tu tu es une famille une
sous-famille tu peux pas te montrer
pauvre tu peux pas te montrer faible
sinon tu vas être avec un clan de tocar
vois pas de clan du tout donc tu es
obligé de montrer que tu existes donc il
vaut mieux bouffer rien du tout pas
grandchose des pommes de terre et se
montrer
euh
généreux ce qui veut dire qu'en fait
aujourd'hui plus personne ne pense ça
enc mais ça vient de là ça vient de de
de de cette de ce besoin de se montrer
puissant enfin en tout cas suffisamment
puissant pour faire partie d'un clan ce
qui veut dire qu'enc tu vois pas la
misère elle est pas montrée et pourtant
première première première région la
plus misérable de France et moi qui l'
cô toi c'est maot aussi hein oui ah
ouais alors de de France métropolitaine
mais les cors ils se disent pas
métropolitain sujet qu'on ne va pas
aborder
euh donc quand quand tu tu tu tu tu vois
ça pourrait dire c'est différent de
Marseille mais non les petits cors qui
grandissent culte des armes comme les
comme comme ce des cités ils ont des
soucis ils ont eu l'emparo là il y a eu
tout récemment une tuerie assez si
c'était arrivé entre arabe dans une cité
à Marseille on en aurait parlé hein
l'emparo c'est d'un seul coup pour un
regard tu m'as regardé tu m'as
regardé tous les jeunes 17 entre 17 et
22 ans ils dégainent ils sont tous ils
sont tous calibrés mais soiré le soir
dans un bar he c'est un bar l'arois Jaco
et p p p ça tire et il y a un mec qui
meurt au passage et et ça a traumatisé
beaucoup de gens encore il se disent
attends on en est là maintenant et oui
on en en est là ça ressemble à aux cités
mais en fait c'est des cités qui
ressemblent je sais pas j'aurais pas
dire qu'il ressemble à quoi c'est qui
qui va sur l'autre en fait c'est c'est
un fonctionnement qui va être logique
donc culte des armes ça c'est lié un
petit peu à l'histoire Corse culte des
armes que tu vas avir dans les cités
c'est ce côté viriliste où il faut faut
se montrer puissant parce qu'on est
faible donc ben les armes parenthèse
j'en fait beaucoup mais la kalalashnikov
l'usage de la kalalachnikov c'est les
petits calibres du banditisme qui
utilise les gros calibres le gros
calibre utilise du 9 mm précis pom pom
c'est gros gros il utilise quoi et le
très gros il utilise la politique il
utilise la politique ou la finance le
très gros et s'il le faut de temps en
temps ils font tuer quelqu'un mais ça va
se faire très subtilement et ils vont
pas faire tuer un petit ils vont faire
tuer un gros donc ça va se faire c'est
compliqué faut faire écraser un
hélicoptère enfin c'est pas simple hein
mais mais le gros calibre c'est pour les
petits bandits il faut se montrer fort
donc quoi de mieux que la calache mais
n'importe quel voyou un peu un peu
expérimenté te dit que la calach c'est
pas l'idéal en fait l'idéal c'est du 9
mm c'est voilà les spécialistes d'armes
sûrement qui nous écoute c'est les armes
son va voir si tu as un vrai Corse ouais
c'est quoi le grain noir ah ben je sais
pas gr noir tuas peut-être un accent
aussi un peu oh de pin c'est çay de de
pinsout de pinsout je sais pas une balle
de 22 dans le trou de balle d'accord ben
je connaissais pas une une balle de 22
en suppositoire bien tirer tu sais ce
que ça fait non une hémorragie et oui
parce que le taux de pénétration d'une
balle de 22 il est plus fort que les
autres armes donc on peut tuer à la 22
et pourtant c'est en vente libre mais
bon donc donc en Corse qu'est-ce qu'on
voit on voit sortir ce ce banditisme là
cette délinquence et on le voit sortir à
Dijon et on le voit sortir à Rennes et
on se dit merde c'est une marcellisation
une cartellisation non non non non tu as
un problème de société tu as une misère
qui s'est mis en place tu as un abandon
social qui va favoriser parfois le
politique parce ça lui permet de
communiquer alors l'extrême droite ser
régale avec ça la droite extrême gauche
aussi quand même je vais y venir je vais
faire tout le spectre l'extrême droite
se régale avec ça parce que les immigrés
on a laissé rentrés les immigrés mais
ils sont pas immigrés ils ont jamais
connu ils savent même pas ce que c'est
le bled quand ils vont au bled ils
veulent rentrer en courant ils sont pas
les Marseillais sont marseillais s'ils
sont pour l'Algérie c'est l'équivalent
des Italiens qui est pour l'Italie en
fait dès qu'il dès que la France marque
un but ils sont à fond ils sont derrière
l'OM voilà à part être enti PSG et et à
Paris àarître antiom il y a pas de et en
plus ça c'est complètement autre chose
et il y a rien enfin c'est c'est j'y
crois pas du tout moi ça hein et
euh j'ai perdu le film spectre oui donc
euh l'extrême droite se fait l'extrême
droite se régale dessus c'est facile
hein c'est facile hein tu tu tu tu as
besoin de voile puisque la misère fait
que il y a des stigmatisations que tu es
rejeté ben pour ça en réaction bah tu
vas faire exactement ce que l'autre
déteste tu vas te faire pousser la barbe
tu vas mettre une grande GABA et tu vas
mettre de la musique de la musique du
bled ou de la musique avec un autotunes
qui ressemble à au bled c'est exactement
comme les bourgeois punk anglais qui se
sont mis à faire la crête à à à faire du
bruit en faisant en reprenant le tango
et la musique tradie de l'époque mais
bourrin histoire de dire aux parents
bourgeois et au bourgeois allez vous
faire [__] ben c'est l'équivalent
alors je te dis pas que c'est des punk
parce que les punk il y a de la poésie
de l'idéologie derrière eux ils sont pas
trop là-dessus il y a quand même une
religion derrière du comp à Crète moi la
crête moi j'ai eu les cheveux verts
pendant 2 mois de ma vie mais j'avais
des cheveux verts par contre je pourrais
avoir tu sais le non tu sais c'est
c'était celui de propel red là il avait
je pourrais faire ça mais je suis pas
sûr de vendre autant de livres au
contraire c'est regarde il a un écrivain
il s'est fait tomber les dents moi je
pourrais me faire pousser
lesbe s'est fait tomber les dents moi je
pourrais me faire pousser les de de crê
tuas quand même vachement plus
beaucoupbec oui mais je v moins c'est
vrai j'ai j'ai j'ai vu des j'ai le même
par contre tu me donas le numéro de pour
faire
venir j'ai vu des vidéos de toi quand tu
étais jeune ça été mieux maintenant ah
ben écoute c'est c'est avantage les
bonhommes il se après comme je passe à
la télé je fais attention peut-être
c'est un peu ça le trucz ton histoire
mais donc donc l'extrême gauche
l'extrême droite je dit euh le le la
droite elle va avoir aussi un discours
traditionnaliste mais elle va surtout
dire la droite aucun développement
économique n'est possible sur ce sur ce
secteurl à cause des trafiquants à cause
de cette
jeunesse qui qui a l'argent facile myth
pense-moi me demander l'argent facile ce
myth là çaen n'est pas euh donc la
droite va dire nous on va pas là-dessus
euh tant que c'est pas nettoyé donc le
nettoyage il sera sécuritaire et
uniquement tant que c'est pas nettoyé on
ne fera pas développement économique et
sociale et on se servira de de ces
lieux-là à des fins politiques à chaque
élection en fonction de la
gradation du niveau de cynisme on
utilisera tel ou tel coin alors le 93
c'est plutôt pour l'Islam Marseille
c'est plutôt pour banditisme au Mirail à
Toulouse ils font un peu des deux je
vois qu'ils utilisent Strasbourg
maintenant ils se mettent à utiliser
reine je sens bien qu'il y a des que
chaque endroit s Grenoble est très utile
Grenoble il utilise énormément il y a un
B parce que Greno c'est une ville
ouvrière avec des industries fortes et
quand ça s'est effondré et ben il y a eu
du banditisme de survie et comme on est
à proximité de Lyon où il y a un
banditisme en colle blanc monumental
très discret qui lafferme qui fait
énormément de pognons et dont on ne
parle jamais et comme il une proximité
avec la Suisse Grenoble est très bien
placé et donc et vu que tu es untro ben
ça te donne ce truc et en plus Sarkozi
allait faire son discours de Greno sur
les Romes tu sais pas pourquoi d'un ce
coup les Romes apparaissent il y a un
danger les Romes ils sont 800 à
Marseille ils doivent être 3000 en
France te dis si on a peur de 3000
bonhommes on est dans la merde hein
surtout que les 3/4 ils veulent
travailler alors ils veulent travailler
3 mois de l'année repartir 3 mois c'est
faisable he ça'appelle les saisonniers
on le fait nous en France hein ça he
donc c'est faisable hein intermitant du
ou les intermitant
oui les s'ils font de la trompette les
vagabond tout c'est un groupe un groupe
marseillais qui super bien de Rome et eu
ils peuvent être intermitant
malheureusement je pense qu'ils le sont
même pas bon déjà les Romes ils on
statut quoi mais ils ont même pas le
droit de travailler en Europe on va pas
partir là-dessus ça fait trop de
digression
euh la droite politique la droite elle
fait ça je viens bon la macronie elle
est trop récente pour l'analyser mais
elle a un fonctionnement un peu comme la
droite elle puise un peu
partout elle a essayé de un moment de la
macronie a besoin que les quartiers
populaires ne vote pas parce qu'ils
voteront jamais pour eux donc s'il Vote
pas C'est le top donc maintenir cette ce
ce truc là permet d'avoir des gens qui
votent pas ça c'est le top hein la
gauche type socialiste de ver alors les
vers ont un peu de mal avec les
quartiers populaires ils essayent enfin
de de de de d'écouter parce qu'il y a
quand même des gens qui ont une
une une une petite un flair hein dans
les quartiers populaires sur les
questions écologiques il y en a il y a
il y a des gens qui font on des jardins
partagés alors ça date de l'époque
communiste puis maintenant c'est même
plus des cocos ils savent même plus que
c'est les cocos qui ont créé ça mais ils
ont ce côté un peu cycle court et
compagnie et donc les vers ils sont en
train de temps en temps d'essayer de se
greffer dessus pour essayer de faire de
la politique dans les quartiers ils ont
raison c'est une bonne stratégie mais il
ont ils ont beaucoup de retard hein ils
ont beaucoup de retard ils ont essayé
par exemple ils ont fait rentrer chez
eux un un jeune de de dans le fil dans
le frère a été tué dans un règlement de
compte à Marseille qui s'appelle amine
kessassi et qui est rentré chez les vers
et qui était un des candidats pour les
européennes puis après députés il a pas
gagné mais tu sens qu'ils essaient de
prendre leur leur quartier un petit peu
pour essayer de gagner ça stratégie
comme une autre c'est pas malsin hein
c'est c'est à peu près sincère je dirais
c'est évidemment électoraliste c'est
vraiment avec une pensée électorale mais
ça on peut pas le reprocher au monde
politique pour gagner il est pas là pour
pas là pour autre chose he tu gagnes
après tu fais ton idéologie si tu n'as
qu'une idéologie moi c'est facile he tu
t'appelles philiip Poutou tu as ton
idéologie tu fais des punchlin à la télé
et elle se fera jamais et tu essayes pas
de gagner c'est faisable tu t'appelles
de l'autre côté dans l'extrême droite il
a Filippo tuappelles Philippo tu
gagneras jamais tu parles tu gagneras
jamais c'est faisable du Pignan il y en
a plein mais mais si tu veux gagner faut
faire de la politique ou il y en a
beaucoup en fait ouis Sandrine Rousseau
elle est du à à là aussi on va pas faire
de digression là-dessus et
donc les les les les les verrs ils se
débrouillent avec ça les communistes ils
sont toujours sur
l'approche ouvrier monde du travail
quand il y a le monde du travail ils y
arrivent martig a encore des
travailleurs c'est communiste quand il y
a pas le monde du travail il n'y
arrivent pas ils ont pas ça dans leur
ADN et c'est dommage hein c'est un
manque hein qu'on soit de gauche pas de
gauche pass à la question les
communistes arrivaient à structurer ces
quartiers aujourd'hui c'est plus le cas
la France insoumise a une stratégie qui
me semble un peu hasardeuse mais qui
s'entend c'est euh allons chercher les
colères les quartiers populaires sont en
colère et ont de bonnes raisons de
l'être je suis d'accord jusque là
pourquoi on dit quartier populaire et
pas quartier
pauvre parce que c'est alors on pourrait
dire quartier pauvre ou quartier de la
relégation à Marseille ils appellent ça
les quartiers nord mais comme comme les
quartiers nords ils sont moins pauvres
que le centre-ville et comme dans le sud
de la ville le quartier la le quartier
le plus au sud de Marseille à côté de la
super calang de sormw c'est la caayole
et la caayole c'est très pauvre et c'est
la cité la plus au sud donc Marseille
c'est un peu comme le ying et le yang
c'est-à-dire qu'il y a plus de pauvres
au nord plus de riche au sud même c'est
pas riche non plus et tu as un peu de un
peu de riche au nord et un peu de riche
au sud donc moi ce truc quartier Nord ça
me plaît pas donc j'appelle jamais
quartier Nord parce que là c'est quand
je dis quartier pauvre ben tu les vexes
les gens ils ont raison on les ramène
toujours à la misère à la pauvreté c'est
c'est c'est humiliant à force quartier
populaire je trouve que c'est plus il y
a quelque chose populaire parce que moi
je les trouve beau ces gens dans mes
films je l' dans dans mes parce que mes
films c'est l' de mes livres mes livres
je dénonce je suis très dur c'est très
très dur mes livres sur mes films je
montre comme j'ai fait un film qui
s'appelle dans les jeux des miens sur le
supporter alors c'est sur l'OM mais
franchement tout le monde s'y retrouve
et je raconte c'est une sorte de de film
à la à la kelnche quoi sur sur les
différents milieux sociaux et je raconte
la misère sociale et comment l'OM ça les
fait survivre en fait comment le foot
donc pour moi l'OM mais à l'Ance ils ont
la même chose même à Paris ils ont la
même chose comment ça les fait survivre
et fait survivre contre la douleur genre
contre la la morosité le peuple voilà
ouais j'iris pas jusqu'à l'opium parce
qu'ils sont moins con que ça ils sont
pas là
l'OM au contraire si je raconte comment
l'Olympique de Marseille plutôt le
supporterisme et le dernier endroit où
on fait de la politique on revendique je
veux plus cet entraîneur je veux cet
entraîneur le directeur il s'en va le c
est là on veut les et puis en plus ils
s'unissent c'està-dire les ultras de
Paris et les ultras de Marseille se
tapent sur la gueule puis d'un seul coup
il faut faire une réunion d'ultra pour
dire on veut les fumigènes d'ailleurs
moi je suis pour les fumigènes euh il se
mettent ensemble et ils savent
s'entendre ils savent ne pas se taper
sur la gueule quand il y a le chef de
l'un et chef de l'autre qui vont porter
un message qui est nous supporters on
veut les fumigènes et je trouve ça très
bien ça s'appelle la politique c'est du
syndicalisme même et en fait c'est des
syndicats les les les clubs de
supporters c'est les syndicats qui
défendent quelque chose et donc toute
cette toute
cette j'ai perdu le fil à force c'est
vrai he spectre politique gauche droite
voilà et les filles ils vont chercher
les colères le problème de de de de
d'aller chercher les colères c'est que
tu considères que les banlieux les
milieux populaires les milieux pauvres
ce que tu veux ils sont déjà tu sépares
le rural le péri urbain du de la cité
moi déjà je suis pas pour ça déjà je
trouve qu'à l'usage il y a des des ne
serait-ce que quand ils jouent au foot
ils vont jouer les uns contre les autres
tout conin heureusement qu'il y a le
sport ou dans d'autres dans d'autres
régions rugby il vont jouer les uns
contre les autres au basket tout ça euh
quand tu vas acheter ton canapé j'ai
généralement tu vas en Bonlieu
parisienne parce que parce que il faut
un parking tout ça de toute façon les
gens ils bougent et et cette ségrégation
qu'on met politique qui dit moi je vais
aller voir les gens des tours les gens
des des cités déjà elle elle est pas
bonne dès le début elle va elle va
peut-être qu'elle est stratégieelle est
volontaire parce qu'un bureau de vote il
est à l'échelle d'une cité donc comme il
pense bureau de vote il tu vois ils ont
une pensée qu'un pensée de stratégie
politique au bureau de vote donc puisque
tu penses bureau de vote bah tu vas
penser citer et tu vas ma is est à cité
pour remplir le bureau de vote remplir
ça veut pas dire tricher forcément même
si la triche existe pour tous les partis
mais je dis qu'elle sanile parce que
comme tout le monde triche un peu
finalement à la fin c'est pas massif
quoi c'est c'est on l'a vu quand il y a
eu Godin contre Guerini qui était deux
très beaux tricheurs en
2008 ils ont perdu à 800 voies Guerini a
perdu à 800 voies il a fait un recours
sur une tricherie Godin 800 voix et
Godin a fait un recours en disant mais
moi j'ai 800 vois de Guerini donc ça
s'est arrêté là ils sont ré la main tu
as gagné en fait il
c'est je peux couper les politiques les
financements est-ce qu'il y a du stub ou
de l'argent des stubs qui financent les
politiques en
France comme c'est plus subtile je vais
y venir directement ça s'est fait avec
la French Connection qui finançait
notamment pour des réseaux marseillais
euh qui ont financé directement ça a été
écrit qui ont financé directement le RPR
dans les années 80 je pense que les
socialistes avaient les leurs mais comme
je les connais pas je m'arrête là mais
il y en a qui qui qui ont financé le RPR
euh c'est pour ça qu'on retrouve un
pascois qui devait savoir des choses à
minima je rappelle que pasquis était un
commercial de de Ricard et que Ricard
c'est les premier à s'être fait choper à
l'époque pour du pour des voitures qui
étaient farcies alors tout ça c'est
peut-être le hasard hein parce quoi il
il venait plutôt de l'OAS et de et de la
France-Afrique mais bon on sent que même
si Pasqua était pas directement en
trafic j'irais surtout pas jusque- là
mais en tout cas il y avait des des des
triangles des trucs à trois quatre
bandes qui se jouaient là ça c'est sûr
aujourd'hui c'est plus subtile par
justement on n'est plus dans ce système
quasi mafieux on est dans un système que
je dis uérisé aujourd'hui on est dans
une corruption ce que tu dis c'est la
corruption on est une corruption de
contact c'est-à-dire la corruption elle
est pas profonde c'est pas ils sont pas
capables d'acheter un juge sont pas
capables d'acheter un député c'est
compliqué euh en tout cas pas pas pas
toute façon un député seul ça sert à
rien il faut un juge il faut il faut il
faut un proc ça aujourd'hui en France il
une protection c'est compliqué un
directeur de la police ça peut arriver
mais ça va être des car il y a eu celui
de Lyon qui était tombé neré si je me
rappelle bien son nom je suis pas sûr
mais je crois que c'est ça neré mais
neré c'était plus compliqué que ça
l'affaire neré c'était à la fois un peu
de de ripou mais à la fois un type qui
travaillé tellement bien qu'il s'est
laissé aspirer aussi c'est pas le ripou
corrompu façon film américain c'est plus
subtile c'est un mec qui bosse bien puis
au bout d'un moment on lui offre des
choses et il se laisse aspirer et voilà
quoi donc donc c'est c'est pas non plus
une corruption si simple j' a de la
corruption par contre il y a du
clientélisme donc ça donne quoi le
clientélisme ça donne le réseau de stup
fait deux choses créer une assaut qui
est porté par quelqu'un qui est très
bien euh et il y a plusieurs
possibilités cet assaau là va être
subventionné cet assaut là va être une
assaut de
quartier qui va et puis au moment des
élections elle fera ce qu'il faut pour
que les petits dealers qui savent même
pas pour qui voter vont aller voter al
ça fait gagner un bureau de vote ça fait
pas gagner une élection c'est là qui se
Tromp les élus qu'en fait tu gagnes pas
une élection avec ça tu gagnes un bureau
de bureau mais des fois ça sert grosso
modo mais mais je pense qu'ils perdent
plus à faire ça qu'ils gagnent mais eux
ils pensent à court terme tout le temps
ils pensent à 2 ans à 3 ans il pensent
jamais à plus
et après l'autre stratégie c'est de
monter des boîtes de bâtiments de kebab
alors ça c'est le blanchiment c'est
autre chose mais de bâtiments et de et
de sécurité et tu all les marcher donc
là aussi c'est des moyens un petit peu
mais est-ce que tu es dans de la
corruption non tu es dans un
clientélisme qui tire vers la corruption
donc tout ça existe il y a des affaires
qui sortent régulièrement on le voit euh
des fois par exemple il y a des
syndicats moi qui s'approchent de moi
qui me disent put le port il y a de plus
en plus de bois de sécurité un coup
c'est telle cité c'est telle cité il
s'effrait de ça parce que le syndicat
d'habitue avait la main m sur son truc
d'un ce coup il l'a plus donc donc il y
a des jeux de pouvoir permanents un coup
la police va agire dans un sens dans
l'autre la justice surtout mais il y a
pas de corruption profonde tu vas
trouver de temps en temps des ou ou ou
un élu il va prendre un peu de sous pour
une campagne rarement à des fins
personnelles pour et et il va pas aider
le réseau du genre je lu d il est pour
toi c'est rare qu'un élu il y a eu un
cas là il y a pas longtemps il y a eu
une élu elle était carrément nourrice
bon ben elle on va voir la faire quand
elle va sortir mais ça sera compliqué
été nourri s' y avait des lingots d'or
il y avait du CH mais tu sens que elle
il va y avoir une histoire derrière où
ils la tiennent je sens venir le le ce
qu'on appelle le chantier c'est-à-dire
que au début on t'aide et puis d'un seul
coup tu as plus le choix je sens qu'on
va être on va être plutôt ce qu'on
appelle un chantier dans le monde du
manditisme c'est-à-dire on on te on te
tourne autour on t'attrape et tu es
foutu mais je sens pas parce que alors
elle est d'une naïveté exceptionnelle tu
es obligé de te faire avoir donc donc
c'est une corruption de pied niclé un
peu hein donc donc et c'est pas c'est
quelque chose qui peut arriver par
ailleurs mais la corruption vraiment je
t'achète toi l'élu tout ça oui ça peut
permettre à un moment un réseau il a
besoin de garder cet immeuble cet
immeuble il il lui va bien l'en rue est
prévu on a prévu de casser l'immeuble
ben tu vas avoir un élu qui pendant des
années va mettre des freins pour que
l'immeuble se casse pas et il va avoir
un gain via des assaut il va rarement se
faire payer il est pas con leslu ça va
rarement ça ça ça peut arriver il y a
j'ai eu un cas tiens un truc tout bête
donc moi j'ai j'ai eu ce cas une fois
mais on peut penser que ça arrive
d'autre fois là c'est il y a pas d'élu
là c'est le monde de l'immobilier euh à
Marseille ça doit arriver ailleurs il y
a beaucoup de recours c'est-à-dire un
projet immobilier est là et tu a une
assaut qui se forme de de de d'habitant
on fait un recours et ça bloque le
projet pour 3 4 5 ans des fois pour de
très bonnes raisons des fois il des
recours pour une bonnes raisons et des
fois il les recours tu vois bien que
c'est pour casser les couilles quoi et
ben là ils vont faire un recours avec un
réseau de stup qui une assaut fais un
recours va voir le le promoteur et le
promoteur il en foign loin on voir le
promoteur en disant voilà mon poulet
nous on a 200000 € à blanchir on fait un
recours on va à l'amiable et à l'amiable
tu nous don 200000 € mais en fait tu
nous les donnes jamais c'est-à-dire nous
après il faut avoir quand même des gens
qui sont compétents pour faire des des
trucs hein il faut falloir dans les jeux
d'écriture va falloir quand même des
deux côtés des gens compétents donc
c'est pas non plus le premier venu qui
va faire ça mais voilà un truc tout bête
où 200000 € a été blanchi alors il y a
des pertes au milieux a des taxes et
tout de toute façon le blanchiment tu
perdes toujours 20 % c'est rare de
perdre moins ça arrive mais c'est
rarissime et donc voilà encore un
exemple qui doit arriver par ailleurs et
il y a beaucoup de trucs comme ça le BTP
par exemple ça c'est très marseillais il
y a pas que les stupes qui font ça mais
une un réseau de stup va monter une
boîte de PTP la boîte de PTP va va va
ceux qu' on roulit à Marseille sont
rendu compte qu'il y a beaucoup de
tranché et on se dit mais ils sont cons
ou quoi ils sont pas capables de faire à
la fois les tuyau la fibre l'électricité
non ils sont pas cons au contraire il y
a un truc qui s'appelle euh les bons de
commande c'est-à-dire que il y a sans
passer par des marchés tu vas voir sur
un territoire donné je dis n'importe
quoi pour la somme 1 million d'euros qui
a loué à trois rues si tu les dépenses
pas ben l'année suivante il y a moins
donc faut les dépenser et pour les
dépenser il faut creuser donc il faut
sans arrêt refaire donc il faut se
tromper il faut prendre des tocars ou
tocar volontaire ou tocar tocar qui vont
dire ah [__] on a pas pensé on a mis
la fibre on n pas pensé à mettre les
câbles [__] on est dans la merde et
des fois tu prends des vrais gag et des
fois tu prends des des des des gens qui
sont et donc tu passes ton temps à
recommencer et donc ça fait que tu as
premier temps ta belle ta belle route là
tu roules dessus tu es content là ça
vibre pas tout ça puis il faut pas de
moin tu commences à voir le premier truc
puis le deuxième puis après c'est et en
fait ça les les les les les les
entreprises parfois je pas généralisé
mais tuas des entreprises de de
terrassement elles vont t'annoncer ils
sont payés au coup de pelleteuse le
terrassement tu prends telle somme sur
un coup de pelleteuse et on va avoir 400
400 coups de pelleteuse seront
nécessaire pour faire ça et à Marseille
c'est compliqué tu comprends il y a
toujours des
pierres plus qu'ailleurs nous on a
beaucoup plus de pierres que dans les
autres villes et donc combien la feu de
coupuse 4000 c'est invérifiable et là tu
fais rentrer de l'argent sal parfois
là-dedans dans ce réseau là tuas 4000
coup de pteuse il en a pas eu 4000 on va
payer des gens mais en fait on les paye
pas vraiment c'està dire il a déclaré
4000 on a déclarer qu'on lui a donné je
dis n'importe quoi 1 million alors qu'on
lui a donné 800000 et donc lui il a
200000 au milieu voilà il y a plein de
jeux comme ça donc ça demande quand même
de la compétence à chaque fois tu payes
des taxes dessus donc tu perds de
l'argent mais le blanchiment c'est la
perte d'argent après voilà ce qui veut
dire que si tu veux lutter contre les
stupes cette partie làà des stupes donc
du blanchiment et ben il faut mettre non
pas des juges mais il faut
mettre des c'est pas funky hein ce que
je veux dire mais c'est vraiment l'aide
des des comment s'appelle IgA là le
leinstitut l'inspection générale de
l'administration al c'est vraiment des
mecs on Coster crabat pas marrant c'est
pas tu vas pas faire une série télé
dessus hein mais ils vont être efficace
tu vas mettre la Cour des comptes mais
Cour des comptes on les a tué comme ça
ils emmerdent plus mais la Cour des
comptes tu auras des résultats si tu
mets des juges pour qu' a un juge faut
qu'il y ait des faut qu'il y ait à un
moment une mallette qui était donnée
mais il a jamais une mallette c'est à
trois bandes c'est-à-dire que tu obtiens
un marché il est légal par contre tu vas
être surpayé sur un autre marché mais on
a le droit de surpayer après tout ah
vous l'avez payé beaucoup ah bah ouais
on s'est trompé on avait mal lu on est
con c'est très bien les Marseillais
savent très bien faire ça le con tu fais
tu rigoles et en fait tu fais [__] et
donc c'est à trois bandes un juge il le
voit mais il peut pas te condamner par
contre le cour de la Cour des comptes à
l'époque où la Cour des comptes avait la
possibilité sanctionner parce que
maintenant ils peuvent plus il faut
qu'un avis en gros la Cour des comptes
envoie un truc à une entreprise en
disant ce que vous faites c'est pas beau
l'entreprise répond vous avez raison
mais j'en ai rien à [__] tout ça avec
des mot poliis mais c'est la même chose
donc Cours des comptes faut remettre des
moyens les inspections il y a plein moi
je connais déjà mais il y en a beaucoup
d'autres tu met tu remets des moyens et
là tu auras des résultats
donc c'est c'est le blanchiment kebab le
blanchiment onglerie c'est le même
principe hein tu vend 5 kebabs tu en
déclares 35 tu en déclares 300 mais en
fait c'est des petites sommes tu
blanchis 3000 € par-ci 2000 par là tu tu
c'est c'est c'est c'est puis ça va se
voir puis tu vas te faire choper puis
toute façon sil te chop pas par le par
le blanchiment ils te choperont par
l'hygiène ils te choperont s'ils veulent
te [__] ils te niqueront donc de toute
façon les durées de vie on le voit de
ces DEES de ces établissements ils sont
courts les kebabs sont sans arrêt ça là
aussi il faut pas faut pas fantasmer
hein c'est c'est la survie les ongleries
c'est autre chose vous remarquez que il
y a énormément d'ongleries de partout
alors je veux bien qu'on se met des faux
ongles maintenant les les les les les
influenceuses ont amené ça mais il y a
pas de quoi faire vivre autant
d'onglerie il y en a partout des
onglerie les coiffeurs aussi donc il y a
la mode des footballeurs le truc mais de
là à te faire quand même tourner autant
de monde donc il y a un petit peu de de
de déclaration aussi de travail au black
hein c'est pas uniquement des stupes en
fait déclaration de tout argent un peu
sale mais là c'est du petit blanchiment
j'ai envie de dire c'est remettez de la
DGCCRF des répression des fraudes ils
vont le trouver tuas pas besoin de de
mettre de la police là-dessus je peux
touvir de
l'administratif quand tu vois que ça
commence à scammer au plus haut sommet
de
l'État qui a un député qui
utilise son indemnité pour acheter du
stup qui achète du stup à un mineur
quand tu vois qu'il y en a qui sont en
midriaz non mais ça connu hein que
souvent le nez dans le milieu dans le
milieu politique il y a il y a de la
cocaïne ben là aussi il faut se rappeler
d'un truc la cocaïne a du popur si y a
toutes ces saloperies quoi il y a ça il
y a il y a principalement la cocaïne
quoi le le le principal c'est la cocaïne
parce que la partie poper se ne vait pas
aller dessus et donc la la la on peut
pas tout dire non plus hein et et c'est
quoi c'est une dro qui fait bien rigoler
si tu en prends trop ce te grille le
cerveau et dans les milieux homosexuels
c'est utilisé pour la dilatation de de
de de du sterre la cocaïne ça fait quoi
comme effet la cocaïne c'est la
performance tu te sens maître du monde
et euh
tu te
sens tout puuissant et tu l' réellement
dans le sens tu as pas besoin de sommeil
tu as l'impression que ton cerveau
marche plus vite mais par contre on se
rend compte aussi que les gens qui sont
sous coque vont trop vite et n'ont plus
la réflexion nécessaire donc ça du pour
du qu par contre c'est un problème pour
le cœur ça va te faire monter rit
cardiaque ça va te faire de
l'hypertension et comme la cocaïne est
très pure aujourd'hui elle est de
meilleure qualité que par le passé quand
elle n'est pas coupée et ben tu et que
tu crois que tu as ta cocaïne habituelle
alors moi j'ai jamais touché à la coque
hein mais quand tu penses que tu as une
cocaïne à 60 % ce qui est à peu près
normal et que tu es une 92 % ben tu peux
faire un arrêt du cœur et donc quand
dans les quartiers quartiers riches
marseillais mais c'est pareil partout on
voit à l'hôpital arrivé un un jeune ou
moins jeune en en fils de bourge ou
bourgeois en arrêt cardiaque on a
compris il a signifé une coque à 92 là
où il pensait ce ni fait une 60 et donc
conseil pour ceux qui prennent de la
coque on essae toujours une toute petite
petite quantité avant pour savoir si on
a le produit de feu ou le produit
habituel parce que interdit par la loi
c'est totalement interdit mais je pense
moi justement qu'il faut aller vers de
la prévention qu'il faut pas se mantir
c'est-à-dire que la coque est de très de
très mauvais pour la santé mais les gens
en prennent donc autant raconter comment
on fait c'est ce qu'on appelle les
salles de shoot très mal nommées on
aurait jamais dû appeler comme ça on
aurait dû appeler ça des centres de
prévention et de de de santé publique il
faut que on essaie d'empêcher les gens
d'aller à la consommation mais sous
forme médicale cesser les addictions pas
pas je vais te mettre une amende ils s'
fout une amende s'il a cro il reprendra
par contre voilà donc moi quand je su
passer ce message je dis pas prenez de
la coque je dis si vous prenez de la
coque faites gaffe pareil le cannabis si
le cannabis cannabis c'est un truc très
important cannabis quand il arrive dans
mon parcours quand il arrive au début il
est très pur aujourd'hui avec les OGM on
fait un cannabis à 38 % record d'une
cité marseillaise C lèbre qui gagne
chaque année le concours au cannabis
Social Club madrilen qui gagne depuis
plus de 5 ans le record de de de du de
la B qui a le plus de de THC 38 % c'est
infumable tétra hydroanabinol voilà
c'est c'est la la partie drogue du du du
cannabis partiee psychotrope partie
psychotrop le C CDB ou BD CBD CBD
celui-là il il est devenu légal et le
THC n'est pas légal le THC est à 38 %
dans le dans les plus grosses trucs %
c'est pas fumable c'est de l'opium c'est
c'est c'est le malaise assuré c'est le
fot c'est là c'est la drogue dure de
toute façon toute drogue est dangereuse
hein canadabis compris donc qu'est-ce
qu'ils font ils la coupent celle-là il
la coupe il y a plein de méthodes il y a
plein de trucs où tu as l'impression que
tu as une tête mais c'est pas une tête
alors quand il la coupe avec du hé c'est
pas grave c'est un antifongique mais
quand il la coupe avec la silice après
voilà quand c'est du
cheit à chaque fois qu'il va être
revendu dans chaque étape qu'une cité va
en revendre à une autre puis après tu
vas avoir un tu vas avoir un comment ça
s'appelle un un un détaillant qui va
vendre un mec qui est un peu un
auto-entrepreneur du cheit là qui qui
est plus en galère qu' chose il y en a
plein à la fin ils sont un kilo par c un
kilo par ça ils essayent c'est ceux-là
des fois qui sont tués parce queils vont
essayer de prendre le terrain d'un autre
ça c'est c'est c'est exactement comme
nos délivr et nos uber c'est les mêmes
c'est c'est les les Niquet du système
quoi le bout du bout on te dit sonont du
fric oui quand tu passes à la télé 10 je
fais 500 € par jour c'est mytho tu fais
rien du tout tu fais des emmerdes pour
pour le restant de ta vie et comme en
plus il n'arrive pas à garder de de
d'argent de côté pour pour la plupart
ben ça se complique c'est très facile
interpeller ces gens il suffit de
commander hein donc ils finissent
toujours par se faire choper à un moment
un autre ça prend 3 ans mais ils sont
chopés et donc chaque fois qu'il y a une
étape on coupe le cannabis au début
c'est du né antifongique pas de problème
après tu vas avoir du charbon de bois
c'est pas encore grave là tu commences à
voir le pneu là ça se complique en bout
de chaîne dans les réseaux les plus
cramés
euh où le tarif est extrêmement peu cher
ù c'est les populations les plus
précaires les populations les plus
précaires là c'est plus le le le le bobo
hein de toute façon les bobos ils fument
pas plus que les autres dire c'est
généralisé la consommation ce délire de
c'est les bobos qui qui fument et qui
provoquent ça c'est un truc délirant la
réalité c'est que la population qui fume
c'est le la sociologie française VO
c'est c'est tout le monde donc des bobos
et d'autres mais les bobos les montent
du doigt parce qu'on veut politiser le
truc on veut dire vous les gauchau vous
fumez après vous non tout le monde tout
le monde fume et donc en bout de chaînne
les cramés dans certaines cités
marseillaises et ben ils vont fumer un
cheit où il y a presque plus de THC
dedans et quand ils se rendent compte
des fois ils vont y mettre ils vont en
bout de chaîne le pire du pire ils vont
y mettre du du du des anxiolitiques
dedans pour avoir un semblant de de de
d'effet et moi j'ai eu vendre une cité
je peux pas la citer je peux pas la
nommer j'ai mis dans mes livres mais je
vais pas le dire euh ça fait de la pub
en fait ils avaient repéré un jour un un
un gamin avait été enfin un gamin un
jeune avait été mis en en en en foyer
dans les Alpes et il était tombé à un
endroit il était tombé sur faut savoir
que nos vaches elles sont toutes
dépressives et il y a des
antidépresseurs pour les vaches c'est
des gros cachetons comme ça et lui il a
vu ça quand il est revenu il a dit donc
ils sont allés faire le cambriolage ils
ont récupéré des cachetons et coupé avec
le cacheton comme ça il coup le cannabis
avec ça ce qui veut dire qu'après quand
tu fumes ça le mec de toute façon
défoncé du matin au soir prend deux
autres drogues il prend des fois du du
des fois du rthanol il est il est plri
PL addiction hein bon il prend ça ça lui
fait un truc je dis ça va c'est bon bah
c'est pas cher hein il sent que c'est du
lowcost hein mais ça va c'est bon donc
ça ça détruit la tête déjà le THC sur la
durée fait du mal au cerveau
particulièrement des cerveaux pas
terminés de de jeune jusqu'à 21 ans
c'est ultra dangereux de jamais fumer
avant 21 ans fumer le plus tard possible
pour ceux qui vont fumer jamais fumer
tout court mais si on est amené à fumer
parce que là aussi faut pas être naïf le
plus tard possible à partir de 21 ans
ton cerveau au moins il est complet dans
le sens où il y a plus de neurones qui
se font donc il y a moins d'action
dessus mais qu'il y a quand même des
actions tu vas avoir de la perte de
mémoire tu peux avoir du Parkinson plus
tard alors c'est comme l'alcool tu fais
mjoin de temps en temps ça va pas être
dramatique tu devient une addiction et
en fait le dealer a besoin d'une
addiction le dealer pour vendre il lui
faut des gens qui achètent régulièrement
celui qui prend que le vendredi soir
c'est pas suffisant il faut un mec qui
qui est dans la
diictionicque vas-y je m'arrête hein
sinon non mais t'inquiète alors on est
parti les politiques qui tapent quand il
il légifèrent s'ils se prennent pourou
les avocats ou les trur économist on est
dans la performance après tu veux parler
d'un point de vue moral d'un point de
vue politique politique et moral là il y
a Piol de Grenoble qui veut généraliser
les contrôles antistup mais c'est ce
qu'il fait il sait très bien que dans
son milieu ça ça ça tapin il le fait
exprès justement donc ça cacheetonne ça
tape de la C euh ça tap chose moi je
pense que c'est pas à faire de toute
façon je pense que
euh je m'attaque pas plus aux politiques
finalement que que que qu'au mecs du BTP
qui parce que le BTP maintenant a déjà
eu un président de la République qui
tapait des traces longues comme le bras
ou bien est-ce qu'on a déjà eu un
président de la République qui tapait
pas des traces euh oui il y en a eu
quelquesuns au 18e siècle non non non il
y a eu quelquesuns je crois que Sarkozi
contraement à ce qu'on pense il a jamais
touché Holland je crois pas et et après
mutéran peut-être je sais même pas mais
après tu as jamais de certitude parce
que tu fais ça à la pupie tu fais ça au
mouvement tu as pas de certitude il y a
pas de prise de sang tout ça tu fais ça
au symptômes là aussi puis toute façon
pour moi c'est pas c'est un non problème
dans le sens où de toute façon faut
poser la question dans l'autre sens
c'est pas une question morale tu te
drogues alors que tu tu es un [__]
c'est pourquoi on en arrive à se droguer
on en arrive à se droguer parce qu'on a
besoin d'être toujours là un président
un élu un un directeur de cabinet il
faut faut être là quoi c'est des métiers
son on peut ne pas les aimer si on veut
mais on peut pas dire qu'il
s'investissent pas hein et donc cet
investissement ben parfois dans plus que
dans d'autres secteurs ben ça passe par
la drogue et en plus quand tu prend
beaucoup de cocaïne il faut ensuite
redescendre il faut dormir de temps en
temps donc soit ça passe par des Médoc
soit ça passe par le cannabis donc
souvent c'est des
multiadictions mais euh finalement quand
je vois que dans le milieu de
l'immobilier on s'est mis à prendre de
la coque parce qu'il faut trouver du
foncier ils appellent ça trouver du du
terrain du crâne trouver de des trouver
de des stupes ils appellent ça trouver
de la cam c'est leur jargon et donc ils
sont concurrents tous les uns envers les
autres ils vont pas s'entretuer
physiquement c'est pas comme le réseau
de stupe par contre s'ils peuvent se se
être le premier aller voir la vieille
qui à la maison mais madame moi je vous
aime beaucoup on envoie une petite
poulette en miniupe ai ça c'est pour le
vieux pour la vieille on envoie mais il
faut il faut être à fond en terme de
performance tu dors pas d'ailleurs ils
prennent que des jeunes un certain âge
ça s'arrête souscoque et après quand il
faut redescendre souvent ils ont des
enfants quand il faut redescendre ben il
y en a qui vont jusqu'à fumer de
l'héroïne pour redescendre alors ça
c'est des cas rares mais surtout fumer
du cannabis pour redescendre et en fait
tu es chimique tu montes tu descends tu
montes tu descends quand tu dans le BTP
ben tu es maltraité c'est dur et que un
réseau du centre
de d'une zone industrielle à Marseille
c'est spécialisé dans le BTP
c'est-à-dire que il sont ouverts de 6h
du matin à 10h après ils vont réouvrir
le soir à partir de 16- 17h pour le pour
le public traditionnel je dirais mais de
6h du matin à 10h on dit il se lève pas
tôt ouais ils dorment on se moque des
dealers ils dorment il dorment il
dorment que dal si' y a du business à
faire il se réveille hein donc de 6 à 10
tu vas avoir des Minos enfin tu vas
avoir un réseau qui est ouvert tu as des
mecs qui viennent en camion qui vont
aller à la plateforme du bâtiment
derrière mais qui avant viennent prendre
prendre leur coque pas parce qu'ils vont
faire la fête parce qu'en fait il faut
les porter ces gravas et il faut et tout
ça en plus avec des cadences pas
possible et et donc il y a ça tu as le
milieu de l'hôtellerie de des bars tout
ça mil tu es beaucoup exploité pareil
restauration la restauration les avocats
les avocats c'est pas que des sal types
ils prennent de la coque non mais c'est
un monde concurrentiel monde des avocats
même histoire faut être au top tu as pas
le choix donc pour être au top tu
prendre la coque et cetera et cetera
l'audiovisuel donc en fait moi je
journaliste alors par exemple province
ça prend peu de coque parce qu'il y a
moins de concurrence et à parisah il y a
beaucoup de concurrence donc tu vas
avoir un certain journalisme qui va
prendre de la coque les mecs de terrain
c'est plus dur tu un journaliste de
terrain tu arrives agressif c'est bon
laisse tomber tu auras pas uneino donc
c'est plus dur donc c'est un certain
journalisme qui peut se permettre
pendant une partie de sa carrière de
prendre de la coque al on va pas si si
je dis quel journalisme on va cibler
trop tout ça mais on le sait il y a eu
des affaires il y a eu des gens qui on
ont été connus pour ça mais on est
plutôt dans un journalisme où tu as
besoin de de sans arrêt être être
omniprésent dans tes équipes ou tu es ou
tu es laquitamine ça fait quoi pardon
laquétamine je sais pas l'anesthésion
pour les chevaux là
ah en fait ça te donne un effet le le ça
te quand c'est fumé ou quand c'est ou
quand ils le prennent alors c'est plutôt
pour retomber ça prend beaucoup de coque
il faut retomber faut ça il faut bien le
comprendre quand tu prends beaucoup de
coqu il y a un moment tu maîtrises plus
grandchose là en ce moment ils font des
sais
records notre société devient de plus en
plus entre guillemets concurrentielle ou
va tellement mal que les gens se battent
pour pour récupérer les derniersres
mièes qu'il y a à prendre sur le
terrain les paramètres énergétiques
mondiaux nous indiquent que on va avoir
d'autant plus de récession d'autant plus
de de problèmes à à à créer en terme
énergétique et donc avoir de la calorie
facile le le constat qui tu nous a fait
de gangraine de propagation de vecteurs
de
d'infiltration jusque c'est principe de
la mauvaise
herbeous la place en général la mauaise
c'est pas une mauvaise herbe c'est la
plus résistante et la la plus résistante
c'est ça c'est mal nommé c'est vrai donc
le le les paramètres de soutenabilité de
nos sociétés thermo-industrielles
occidentales sont en train de vaciller
on le voit géopolitiquement parlant on
est en train de se taper pour des
ressources mais on dit qu'on apporte la
démocratie pour les petites filles que
c'est pour sauver une minorité bon
résultat à chaque fois 90 % du temps
c'est pour les ressources comment tu
vois le commerce du stup des
narcotrafic des des des cartels des
mafias d'ici les trois qure prochaines
années avec des paramètres des
fondamentaux qui vont être de plus en
plus délétaires et toujours avec mon
approche qui est une approche grossiste
tout ça où je divise je dis pas les stup
ça pas de sens même mon mon Félix biangi
là celui qui vient se faire interpeller
qui était un gros bonhomme plutôt
intelligent en même temps violent enfin
voilà qui qui va prendre beaucoup de
prison même s'il avait des sous on va
sûrement lui trouver des des des
dizaines de millions d'euros qui vont
lui servir d'ailleurs
malgré tout il a des années lumières de
ce que de ceux des cartels il est très
très très loin où là c'est pas du tout
les mêmes sommes c'est pas du tout les
mêmes réseaux c'est pas du tout la même
capacité de corruption la même on parle
pas de on est sur des planètes
totalement différentes hein on parle de
millionnaire et milliardairire quoi
c'est pas du tout pareil alors c'est sûr
par rapport au peurs de quartier c'est
encore différent en fait le réseau de
stup a besoin de gens vulnérables pour
deux choses il a besoin de de gens
vulnérables pour les recruter pour avoir
des travailleurs pauvres et c'est là que
la question sur le kalashnikov ce que
j'appelle le kalashnikov le rive de la
le rêve de l'ascension sociale par le
crime qui est vraiment une une une un
mythe et un mythe terrible parce que
justement c'est l'inverse c'est un
moteur c'estàd on a les les les les les
trafiquants ont besoin en passant par la
chaîne que j'ai dit d'avoir des des une
armée mais ils veulent pas une armée de
concurrents ils veulent une armée de
tocar tant qu'à faire et qu'on enfin
tocar dans le sens banditisme qui va pas
remonter jusqu'à eux et il veut quand
même des gens un peu compétents et il
veut en même temps des gens qui vont pas
me prendre trop de sous voir pas du tout
et donc tout est organisé pour aller
chercher de la dette on veut endetter
les gens et donc plus tu descends bas
dans mon dans dans ma chaîne plus il va
y avoir de la dette plus on va endetter
on endette de plein de manières on crée
une dette fiscale et je vais répondre à
ta question on allant par là on va on va
créer une dette on va créer une dette à
à quelqu'un en lui disant un gamin ti le
truc de base qu'on fait c'est le le
point de départ c'est une police rentre
dans un dans un réseau de de stup ça
crie à là le fameux crie pour dire
attention et une fois que que que que la
voiture est partie il y a pas eu de
saisie ben si dealer il a envie à un
moment de de commencer à à prendre la
main sur ses sur ses trafiquants sur ses
gateurs on va dire les gars à cause de
vous notre charbonur il a faill se faire
choper vous êtes pas payé aujourd'hui ça
c'est le premier truc tu es pas payé
tous les jours la police dans toutes les
cités de France rentre sans exception
tous les jours la police rentre on te
dit la police rentre plus non elle
rentre tous les jours elle rentre elle
se fait un peu criertu il y a r alors
kayasa je vais expliquer pourquoi c'est
pas autant qu'on le dit ça c'est le
syndicat Alliance qui dit ça hein c'est
extrême droite qui dit ça la le film
bacnord prenez bacnord prenez l'inverse
et c'est la réalité voilà manord c'est
exactement l'inverse de la réalité pour
une raison tout à fait logique moi je
fais pas d'angélisme je suis pas du tout
là pour ça je pense je pense comme un
dealer en fait voilà mais je je juste je
finis sur la CAL et après réponds à ta
question et je feras penser à bacn
euh le le le le le le donc ce myth de
l'argent facile permet d'avoir des
jeunes qui se disent ben moi je vais
aller faireer faire mes sous dans les
stupes sauf que rapidement ensuite on va
par exemple te donner une une une
promotion on va dire tiens toi
aujourd'hui tu vas être collecteur
collecteur c'est que tu vas chercher les
sous au trois au trois charbonneurs donc
tu vas avoir 3 fois 4000 € euh et tu vas
faire 15000 € 3 fois 5000 € tu vas tu
arrives avec tes 15000 € donc au passage
font des photos qui mettent sur FaceTime
he sur sur snapchat tu as vu comme je
suis un bidon dans mes dans les les
trucs là je vais me faire cartonner
là-dessus mais sur snap sur telgram sur
signal tout ce qui est un peu fermé
euh donc ils font les trucs a l'argent
ils savent très bien se mettre en scène
ils sont très modernes hein ouais je
suis en place la Moula tout ça en place
que DLE les sous c'est pas les tiens
quand tu sais qu'en plus le premier
charbonneur il a fait ça déjà il s'est
pris en photo avec les sous puis après
l'autre il va se prendre en photo les
sous il se prennent tous en photo avec
les sous et à la fin ça arrive au au
comptable qui va le remonter le
comptable lui-même fait sa photo il en a
beaucoup plus et après va y avoir
quelqu'un qui va les payer donc mon
collecteur il a l'impression que c'est
une promotion parce que c'est un poste
on croit en toi he tuas tu as 15000 €
sur toi hein faut cavaler au bon moment
s'il le faut faut pas taper dans la
caisse c'est pas un poste de de rien du
tout hein le lendemain tu arrives tu
crois que tu es le roi du monde tu as
fait le mariool partout et on te fait au
frérot il manque 3000 € là il manque pas
3000 € mais il manque 3000 € toi tu es
rebelles tu non non non non je suis sûr
je suis sûr je suis sûr je suis sûr le
petit il a 15 ans hein ah non on le
fracasse à coup de point et après on lui
dit maintenant tu nous dois 3000 € tu
vas te Giler gratuit pour 3000 €. et on
va lui accumuler sa dette une fois que
la dette est bien importante il se passe
deux choses soit il g éternellement
gratuit il se passe trois choses soit il
d clairement gratuit soit il va dealer
pour un autre réseau il va faire de la
cavalerie mais inversée pas de la
cavalerie pour gagner de l'argent pour
gagner la dette il va travailler pour un
autre réseau pour essayer de faire du
fric en se disant cette fois je me ferai
pas avoir et je vais rembourser le
premier mais en fait il se fait souvent
[__] là et après il a une cavalerie et
là et là il a 4 C réseaux au cul avec du
20000 30000 € de de dette là il est mal
barré alors là souvent il se rend au
flic et on essaie de trouver des
solutions pour l'exfiltrer tout ça ça
marche pas souvent hein mais bon voilà
là c'est compliqué c'est un vrai sujet
hein d'ailleurs euh donc ça c'est la la
première solution c'est travail gratuit
éternel et après il y en a ils vont se
dire ben moi je dois 20000 € à tel
réseau faut que je le bute he faut que
je le bute he et c'est là que ça part en
guerre ou alors autre chose au f à
mesure que je parle je trouve d'autres
trucs c'est vrai ils vont se faire
avancer du du du stup pour le vendre et
ça c'est une stratégie commerciale c'est
pour élargir sa jaune de chalandise
c'est-à-dire que les les terrains où on
vend ils sont ils sont déjà pris ils
veulent trouver d'autres terrains c'est
pour ça que ça va s'étendre de temps en
temps dans du rural ou du Pé urbain on
va fuer 20 kg à Mino on va lui avancer
et on va lui dire tu vends et tu me
remboursera ce que tu me dois sur ça
avec la et tu ganderas ta marche si en a
une et le Mino le problème c'est que les
terrains où tu vends il y a déjà
quelqu'un il faut se battre et les
terrains où ça vend pas ben ça vend pas
il y a pas de client et tu tu peux
attendre hein les endroits s' y a pas de
clients il y a pas de client tu vas
vendre trois barrettes mais tu vas pas
mettre en place un réseau donc en fait
ils sont pris dans tout ça je parle du
bas du terrain c'est-à-dire quand on dit
les dealers attention il a c'est vaste
hein les dealers he c'est il y a
beaucoup de pour moi c'est pas des
dealers d'ailleurs je les mets pas dans
les dealers pour moi c'est les exploités
et le pire du pire je les appelleent les
cramés il s'appelle entre les cramés
d'ailleurs et donc tu vas avoir
d'ailleurs toute une phase
d'exploitation de jeunes
il y a 20000 jeunes qui sur une année
vont travailler à Marseille 200000 en
France vont travailler dans les stupes
il y en a 20000 en gros qui travaillent
à Marseille pas un instanté un instanté
il y en a 7 8000 mais sur une année avec
des mouvements a 20000 sur ces 20000 il
y en a 2 3000 qui vont être des esclaves
ils vont travailler en étant enfermés
dans des squats on va les sortir des
squats ils vont bosser on va les
remettre dans les squats et quand ils se
rebellent on les brûle on les tape on
les on empêche qu'il dorme parce que
quand on dort pas on perd complètement
sa sa notion et et et on les met à des
postes où tu te fais interpeller s'en
bat les couilles généralement ce sont
des jeunes qui sont échappés de foyer à
travers la France et qui se disent ben
moi je vais faire moi ils arrêtent pas
de dire à la télé que on gagne 3000 €
quand on est dealer 8000 € des chiffres
farfelus que tu vas trouver dans toutes
les chaînes d'infos et qui sont passés
par le syndicat Alliance extrême droite
he et qui sont tirés à partir de
feuilles de calcul de de dealer de
feuill de de compte mais les feuilles de
compte ça enlève pas tout ce qu'il a
soustrait et toutes les les fausses
dettes qu'il a mis si tu fais une un
produit en croix tu obtiens des
chifffres qui sont erronés qui sont faux
ça prend pas aussi en compte le fait que
la drogue c'est la même qui est vendu
plusieurs fois donc ça te donne des
chiffres énormes qui sont pas aussi
énormes donc en fait il y a pas 3000 €
pour un guetteteur il y a 3000 € de dett
pour un guetteteur et donc sur sa
carrière je dire pas sur une journée he
pas sur un mois et et
donc le le le kalashnikov dreams qui te
fait rêver que les
rappeurs accentuent parce que eux-mêmes
ils ont peut-être pour certains intérêt
avec les stupes et moi je suis là je
suis du quartier la C c'est la meilleure
ici tout ça les Marseillais font pas
trop ça par ailleurs mais voilà ce genre
de chos que tu peux trouver aussi ben
c'est les Chargers de com pour certains
les Chargers de com n stup euh tu vas te
retrouver de temps en temps avec des
jeunes qui descendent à Marseille c'est
l'Eldorado là-bas tuas à la fois il y a
il y a le rêve de de de la vie
provençale barbecue calan ça existe hein
et en même temps la rêve de la vi cité
le rêve de la vie cité sacoche stupe il
y a les deux mythes qui vont ensemble
sauf queux ils ont pas de droit au
mythes hein eux on les chope à la gare
saint-chles tu viens d'où de chartre toi
tu viens nous Dean allez viens on a un
endroit tu vas te gaver hop on lui
trouve une une dette en 2 TR jours et
après ça y est squat il a pas de Tonton
il a pas d'éducateur il a pas de de de
de de prof les flics le connaissent pas
il a personne pour le sortir de là et
des fois il faut des semaines
généralement ça dure quelques semaines
mais des semaines d'enfer d'enfer de
torture les tortures comme on trouve en
Syrie hein c'est ça hein c'est des
torture dramatique où où il y en avait
un qui écrivait son nom au couteau sur
le front de de des bonhommes pour dire
il m'appartient euh il y a des
scarifications il y a enfin voilà c'est
c'est c'est alors c'est pas les 2000
comme ça mais tu vas trouver des cas
comme ça des brûlures brûlures c'est la
base des plant alors il y a piquer au
couteau ça piquer c'est c'est vraiment
tu tues pas tu vas piquer la peau il a
tout de su il y a la jambisation
jambisation on a le terme carrément
c'est dire tu rends infirme quelqu'un en
lui tirant dans la jambe alors ça la
jambisation c'est plutôt un
des c'est plutôt un des une des étapes
de la diplomatie la jambisation c'est
avant le meurtre avant avant plus grave
avant avant la la séquestration longue
ou la torture lourde on va te te te
handicaper en fait et ils ont ils l'ont
nommé jeamb bigation c'est pas très beau
hein mais donc en fait tu as tu as ce
que je pour pour venir à ta question
générale sur les cartels ou les vrais
trafiquant internationaux qui existent
vraiment quel intérêt ils ont à ça par
qu'en bout de chaîne tant qu'ils ont de
la chair à canon ben c'est bon ils ont
une armée pour vendre et en plus il leur
faut aussi d'autres vulnérables on l'a
dit tout à l'heure les consommateurs et
je met dans vulnérable non pas les
pauvres gens je mets dans vulnérable ce
don qu' cité les politiques si tu veux
ils sont
vulnérables puisque ils ont un besoin de
performance fort et s'ils veulent
continuer à être à leur poste il faut
être performant donc donc il y a ça
c'est une vulnérabilité et donc tant
qu'il y aura des vulnérabilité pour la
consommation et que tu auras des
vulnérabilités pour l'armée et bien ça
va permettre au réseau de vendre leur
stup au vrai au vrais trafiquants donc
plus tu vas avoir une popérisation plus
tu vas avoir une société qui va pas
partager j'ai le travail mais où tu vas
avoir des gens qui travaillent comme 10
et d'autres qui ont rien mais plus tu
vas avoir un besoin de drogue en fait
qu'on a créé toute pièces et donc les
réseaux vont se régaler et au milieu de
tout ça pour peu quiil rentrre un petit
peu et ça je suis moins compétent dans
les questions géopolitiques
c'est-à-dire caisse noire financement
voilà ça va ça c'est carrément au niveau
politique mais même géopolitique au
niveau mondial bah ils vont ils vont en
plus avoir un rôle parce qu'ils vont
être les puissants du moment ils vont
peut-être avoir parfois des armées des
milices qui peuvent servir ça c'est le
côté que je connais le moins c'est le
côté internationale mais donc ça veut
dire que pour arrêter ça il faut partir
du terrain pour moi pour moi il faut
travailler sur les vulnérables dans le
sens le plus large du mot vulnérable je
mets dans les vulnérables quelqu'un qui
est violent c'està c'est un peu
contreintuitif on imagine vulnérable
quelqu'un de faible rouler en boule non
la vulnérabilité c'est une faiblesse qui
s'exploite si tu as une appétence à la
violence c'estàd que tu aimes bien le
violent quand tu viens des quartiers de
classe moyenne bah tu vas juste devenir
un petit camp plus tard tu seras le
casse-ecouille du service de de telle ou
telle entreprise sera celui qui s'énerve
tout le temps celui qui qui a la la
claque facile mais c'est pas grave c'est
pas dramatique par contre les gens
toxiques ont entrepris c'est dramatique
alors c'est vrai mais c'est pas toujours
des gens violents d'ailleurs souvent
c'est des gens malsins c'est c'est des
c'est des pervers voilà toxique toxique
mais par contre un mec a une appétence à
la violence dans un milieu dans une un
environnement je te disais que j'ai une
approche Mo écologique des choses dans
un environnement qui est hostile surtout
qui va qui
va donc l'environnement va rechercher la
compétence qui est face à lui tu as un
gamin qui a une appétence à la violence
et je donne des exemples euh il y a des
gens dans dans mon Mouquin que je
raconte je mets leur nom là-dedans mais
sur sur on les a recruté jeunes à 12 13
ans parce qu'on voyait qu'ils étaient
violents sent pour sûrement pour des
histoires de trauma familiaux souvent il
y a une raison avant enenfance sauf que
les réseaux de Stu vont plus vite que le
social le social le repère ils essayent
mais le temps qu'on trouve le truc puis
voilà le ch fait ça dans la vitesse avec
les moyens qu'on leur donne je jette pas
la pierre ils font ce qu'ils peuvent le
réseau lui il est rapide lui là tu lui
mets des claques donc un petit de 13 ans
il va avoir un petit de 16 ans qui va
lui mettre des claques à longueur de
journée on le voit là il les mettre par
terre il est il est donc humiliation
humiliation humiliation puis un jour le
petit de 13 ans va mettre par terre un
petit de 15 ans il va gagner et là il va
être survalorisé tout le monde va sauter
en les vois dans les vidéos ils sont là
bravo bravo survalorisé d'un ce coup tu
es quelqu'un [__] ta violence ça t tu
es quelqu'un tu es plus GEG là tu tu es
quelqu'un ensuite on va lui donner de la
coque ensuite on va faire on va lui dire
tu vas casser la jambe à lui tu arrive à
lui casser la jambe il y en a pas mal
qu'arrête déjà là hein faut pas se dire
que ça monte pour tous c'est c'est
pyramidales là petit à petit tère ben tu
vas se scarifier ce mec ah bah il faut
un peu me planter celui-là j'ambisation
à celui-là et maintenant il faut tuer
l'autre tu as exploité une faiblesse qui
est devenue une vulnérabilité et tu as
créé un tueur un bébé tueur et donc ça
sous le coup de la loi évidemment prison
évidemment le processus mais pour qu'on
est plus moi je pense plutôt au coup
d'après pour que le petit qui a 5 ans
aujourd'hui ce soit pas le tueur de dans
10 ans il faut qu'on traite dès qu'on
sent qu'il y aura un truc il faut qu'on
utilise cette connaissance là pour se
dire on repère sa faiblesse on veut pas
que ça devienne une vulnérabilité
faiblesse qui s'exploite c'est une
vulnérabilité donc la faiblesse tu pe
l'avoir et ça il y a un travail à faire
hyper urgent et les réseaux de stupe eux
ils ont tout à gagn à ce qui qui est ça
de toute façon les réseaux de stup sont
tenus par des gens qui ont été eux-mêmes
ça c'estàd ils reproduitent ce qu'ils
ont été et ils vont sans même le
réfléchir le
refaire on parlait de Capsi ah oui la ça
c'est très important
la évidemment le gamin dont je parle là
quand on lui enlève son empathie qu'on
lui met en place sa capacité à la
violence on tombe dans quelque chose qui
va être pardon c'est maintenant que je
commence à parler on on tombe dans
quelque chose qui va être je vais
rprendre un peu on tombe dans quelque
chose qui va être l'ordre de la du de la
déviance psychiatrique j'ai pas les
termes exacts hein on n'est pas encore
dans un on est au moins dans la névrose
dans un premier temps et ensuite on va
aller dans un Capsi ensuite on va aller
peut-être dans des pathologies et cetera
il y a toute une gamme aussi qu'un
spécialiste dirait mieux que moi mais
euh euh il y a plusieurs phénomènes
c'est-à dire que par par essence un un
un problème quelqu'un qui a un problème
si va être vulnérable déjà il va
consommer de la drogue parce que le
premier des dé contractants c'est le
Stup c'est c'est le shit al c'est Jaz
épin le Xanax il y a beaucoup de trafic
alors c'est j'aime pas le mot trafic
parce c'est quasi illégal il y a
beaucoup de de mouvements de de cachés
de ils appellent ça la jzpin ils
appellent ça les bonbons dans certains
quartiers et en fait ils sont sous xanax
c'est pas la main c'est pas tous les
quartiers mais si c'est 20 % ça fait du
monde hein il y a je répète je préfère
toujours le répéter il y a bien 80 % des
gens dans les quartiers populaires ils
ont une vie normale he ils sont pas
concernés par ce que je suis en train de
dire je parle de ces 20 % là qui sont
dans le qui sont dans une misère sociale
intellectuelle
psychologique euh purement financière
aussi euh et et et des fois
d'instruction tel que on est dans une
situation
compliquée donc là quand tu tiens
puisque la vulnérabilité ça va t'amener
soit à la conso soit à la à la pratique
soit au deux à la pratique des stup soit
au deux bah les les les Capsis c'est les
premiers qu'on va recruter en fait alors
simplement des névosés des fois hein
mais après jusqu'à la pathologie et donc
là de de une nouveauté hein que que
j'avais pas senti venir moi je suis dans
dans le travail sur les stupes je vais
dire comme journaliste puis 2003 et
après en tant que qu'habitant jamais
étaé très consommateur moi un tout petit
peu de de cannabis très très jeune mais
alors vraiment c'est c'est loin derrière
he moi j'ai jamais acheté de drogue ce
qui était pas bien j'ai jamais acheté de
drogue au 20e siècle hein depuis le 20e
siècle 21e siècle j'ai rien acheté je
consomme pas moins mais j'ai toujours
fréquenté ces milieux là à la fois des
copains du milieu où j'étais à la fois
ben voilà quand tu des quartiers
populairire tu vois ça en fait tous ceux
qui ceux qui sont dans ces quartiers le
voient quoi et
sur sur j' j'étais sur venhabité sur PSI
en fait le le le la au niveau au niveau
psy un truc que j'ai découvert que
j'avais pas vu c'est que les gamins on
le voit c'est valorisé dans tous les
clips de rap mais d'une manière générale
c'est mondial ça il faut qu'il fasse des
rou arriè en moto ou à vélo en moto tout
ça sur c'est un côté très c'est du
priapisme c'est un côté la valeur le
bien droit truc clairement ça le symbole
priapisme ça TER mal oui B ça se termine
mal pour eux justement parce qu'ils sont
comme ça toujours ce GEG en avant ça
montre la puissance la force souvent des
gens qui ont des problèmes d'ailleurs
parce que ceux qui sont puissants ils ne
montrent pas ça ils en ont pas besoin en
fait et donc ro arrière ro arrière ro
arrière mais faut pas croire dans les
clip ils tombent pas mais dans la
réalité ils sont toujours leoccup par
terre et donc ils se connent la tête ils
se connent la tête quand tu es Mino tu
t'es Cognis la tête mais un N
incalculable de foi et donc ça donne
quoi quant au rugby moi jeis un joueur
de rugby quand tuas une commotion quelle
place au rugby j'étais 15 quand et donc
j'en ai pris des coups parce que les 15
à l'époque cétaaient pas protégé le
ballon arrivait en l'air bom tu te
faisait fracasser et c'est pas mon nez
officiel là je me suis fait opérer
plusieurs fois tu vois passé ta
l'honneur un peu non non j'étais que que
que arrière moi et donc j'ai pris
beaucoup de coup dans le nez et donc
quand il y a une commotion une commotion
c'est un bleu dans le cerveau comme
quand on se cogne à la jambe on voit le
bleu apparaître sauf que là c'est dans
le cerveau au rugby tu a 6 semaines
d'arrêt parfois plus 6 semaines où tu as
plus le droit même pas de t'entraîner il
y a des trucs spéciaux mais tu peux pas
euh quand tu es tombé dans la cité tu
t'es connis la tête tout le monde est
mort de rire tu te lèves si tu es
relativement vivant on te filme un gros
bambou un gros joint donc un gros joint
sur une commotion cérébrale chez un
petit trésant ça finit par avoir non pas
des des problèmes psy mais des problèmes
neurologiques et là on tombe dans autre
chose c'està direire on a des parties du
cerveau qui sont détruites et ça c'est
avec une neurologue de de des de de
l'hôpital Nord donc un hôpital dans les
quartier Nord qui est très gros très
très très performant et en discutant
elle m'a dit mais ce que tu me racontes
ça correspond à ce qu'on ce qu'on a et
elle avait pas mesuré qu'elle avait
autant de cas neurologiqu vus des
quartiers je dit mais oui ils ont ils
ont la
tête ils ont ils se cognent partout mais
en fait on voit ils ont des cicatrices
dans tous les sens parce leur temps se
freracasser la tête et en fait ça c'est
un des phénomènes qui amène ça c'est pas
le seul c'est un des phénomènes qui
amène benah des problèmes neuros donc on
a plus de bipolaire plus de de de Capsi
ils sont pas plus con d'autres au départ
ils na'issent pas avec des problèmes ils
sont dans des envir environnement pollué
ils sont dans environnement de drogue en
fumant les drogues que j'ai décrit tout
à l'heure en fonction desquelles tu
fumes au plus jeune âge ça va avoir une
atteinte sur toi des environnement
traumatisant puisque violent parfois
traumatisant en FAM miliaux mais ça
c'est dans tous les milieux c'est pas
propre au quartier populaire donc quand
on a des des familles de de de gens qui
sont arrivés de de migrants depuis peu
c'est les plus vulnérables les migrants
c'est ceux qu'on utilise dans les stupes
et qu'on et qu'on tort le plus c'est pas
du tout ceux qui prennent la main
prostitution aussi aussi prostitution
mais pour les garçons le tapin mais le
pas le tapin de la prostitution le tapin
des des le tapin des des des stupes pour
moi c'est du tapin et euh bon ben là on
a des des des gamins qu' on traversé on
est pour on est contre j'en sais rien
mais quoi qu'il arrive ce qu'ils ont
traversé psychiatriquement parlant c'est
pas bon et comme en plus derrière euh au
niveau de l'accueil psy là aussi
volontairement on les laisse parce que
là volontairement parce que on veut
parce que si je prends les BOUCHES DU
Ron parce que je parle de ce que je
connais ils ont été condamnés plusieurs
fois pour ne pas s'occuper suffisamment
des des il préfèrent payer les amendes
que que que s'occuper des migrants des
des problèmes PS des migrants c'està
dire avoir des centres d'accueil et
essayer de faire ce qu'il faut je pense
qu'il y a l'envie à un moment qu'un
migrant fasse des conneries et on pourra
dire regardez hein vous avez vu le
Malien ce qu'il a fait ah bah oui le
Fada clairement à un moment ça peut le
faire hein et donc s'il y avait une
prise en charge psychiatrique de ces
jeunes qui le mérit pour protéger nous
protéger nous hein si si au moins on n
pas empathique et et on pose pas un
regard
euh humain sur ces gens et et je dirais
moral au moins pensant qu'à nous
pragmatique si tu veux pas avoir des
problèmes toi il faudrait s'occuper de
donc en fait cette vulnérabilité elle va
être toujours exploité on va toujours
chercher le plus vulnérable et donc les
problèmes si c'est une des
vulnérabilités et pour moi c'est une
urgence pour moi il y a un travail
d'urgence parce que là autant pour
certains des problèmes que j'ai dit il
faut 5 10 15 ans pour les résoudre je
pense que tout peut se résoudre mais il
faut du temps autant pour la problème si
c'est des moyens à mettre de façon très
très localisée c'est-à-dire je parlais
des migrants il y a quelque chose à
faire les jeunes qui tombent il y autre
chose à faire quand ils sont repérés les
jeunes qui ont des des appétences à
violence des déviances on doit on doit
faire des choses pour tous il y a
quelque chose mais aujourd'hui il y a
pas de moyen Édouard Toulouse c'est le
l'hôpital psy de Marseille a eu une
réduction des lits énorme et on a
carrément les trafiquants qui vont faire
du trafic dans Édouard Toulouse parce
que ils ont à domicile les meilleurs
consommateurs du monde ils ont tous les
tous les Capsis possib donc et et et les
médecins sont obligés de faire avec et
il y avait une antenne au centreville à
saint-murand à Bellem ils l'ont fermé
donc là c'est un choix politique dire
qu'à un moment tu dis on a plus les
moyens tu as plus les moyens mais
derrière tu vas avoir des problèmes qui
vont te coûter plus cher c'est absurde
mais je te rassure on a fait partout ça
on a fait 1000 milliards de dettes en
plus avec le gouvernement Macron les les
capacité à redresser l'économie du pays
se réduisent comme pot de chagrin on
tient par de la dette quand quand ça va
commencer à calancher ça va être open
bar pour tous ces réseaux je vois mais
le paradoxe aussi parce que je veux être
positif ce que tu disant d'êre positifis
tu tu dis là je t'ai entendu deux fois
dire le syndicat Alliance les policiers
et l'extrême droite c'est le syndicat
all s' serbe c'est le syndicat Alliance
qui est pour toi et d'extrême droite ou
c'est le syndicat Alliance et l'extrême
droite ouais c'est plutôt la deux
syndicat à alliance va avoir des gens
d'extrême droite et des gens qui sont
très à droite mais ils sont pas tous
extrême droite tu comprends que en plus
ououi tu comprends que les flics ils en
prennent plein la gueule aussi mais
pourquoi les flics aussi on on les
maltraite à ce point c'est-à-dire
que les flic ce sont les infirmiers de
notre maladie grave ils viennent penser
les PL ils vont pas la maladie grave le
monstre ce que j'expliquaé corruption
enfin tout ce que j'explique là les
corruption clientélisme choix politique
foireux monde économique qui s'en bat
les couilles qui fait son côté et cetera
tout ce genre de truc donc ça euh ça
c'est le monstre pour pas le nommer
mafia parce qu'une mafia c'est pensé ça
c'est pas pensé ça se fait de manière
c'est fluctuant c'està dire d'une année
sur l'autre tu as pas exactement les
mêmes puissances par moment c'est des
lobes par moment c'est des c'est c'est
c'est du cantéliste dans secou a la
corruption ça ça bouge tout le temps
c'est monstrueux quoi mais
euh la police donc ce monstre là il a
des lésions et les trafics de stup les
PL c'est PL qui va les soigner qui va au
chevet de ses PL la police absolument
nécessaire alors il y a deux polices là
aussi faut pas mélanger police d'enquête
donc ça c'est très très important il
faut leur donner toujours plus de moyens
et vous recevrez sûrement des gens qui
sont bien plus compétents que moi pour
savoir en police d'enquête ce qu'il faut
mais en effet il faut faire toujours
plus d'informations et renouer avec
l'infiltration qui qui a été un peu
abandonné sous Sarkozi même siils y
retournent mais ça il va falloir y
retourner en donnant des moyens des
cadres juridiques il va falloir y aller
là et après il y a la police de de
d'ordre public de sécurité publique
d'intervention et là il y a des des des
des choix à faire il a des types de
police différents là aussi je vais pas
prendre parti moi j'ai mon avis mais je
vais expliquer ce qu'il y a il y a la
police qui qui fait de de la prévention
c'est-à-dire qu'empêche que les cas que
les que les faits se fassent et y a la
police qui fait du saute dessus qui fait
de la de la du comment on appelle ça de
la du pris sur le vif là de la du et
avec des des des des gilets jaunes pour
montrer qu'en fait ils sont là et après
on a la police alors je dis pas qu'il en
faut une plus que l'autre mais il faut
bien penser ces deux types de police
c'est peut peut-être la mixer un peu
nous on a quasiment délaissé la police
visible tout la police est
délaissé il Bos dans des commissariats
qui s je très vulgaire vous m'ex
excuserez ils posent dans des truc il
sentent de la piss ils ont des des
bagnoles qui sont complètement ils ont
pas d'essens ils ont pas d'essens ça pu
c'est n'importe quoi ils sont pas
suffisant suffisamment nombreux pour
faire des des des unités à 3 des fois
ils sont qu' deux dedans ce qui est pas
légal normalement mais ils le font quand
même parce qu'ils sont courageux parce
qu'il sont besneux sont pas si bien
payés lanceperre je pense que là il faut
pas faut pas abuser mais ils sont payés
avec des primes ils sont payés avec
alors il y a plus en théorie les primes
de de les primes au résultat mais elles
ont pris une autre forme mais c'est
moins grave que sous Sarkozi quand
même les conditions de la police doivent
être largement amélioré les moyens
alloués à la police doivent être
largement améliorés mais surtout la
redistribution des des missions de
police doivent être totalement changé
aujourd'hui la police perd son temps à
videré la mer à la petite cuillère pour
les réseaux de stup ce que fait la
police ne sert strictement à rien non
pas parce que ils bossent mal ils
bossent très bien ils font ce qu'ils ont
à faire sont volontair ils font tout ce
qu'il faut faire ils font alors certains
par jeu d'autres par engagement d'autres
par carrière on s'en fout en tout cas
ils font ce qu'il faut la majeur partie
c'est quand même par dévotion par
dévotion parce qu'il faut parce qu'en
fait ils ont des vies brisé ces gens il
y a des divorce il y a des au bout d'un
moment c'est c'est très dur il y a aucun
doute là-dessus c'est il y a a les flics
et est-ce qu'il fument bah le problème
c'est que le problème qu'il y a c'est
que ils ont des contrôles quand même et
si à un moment ils font une connerie ce
qui peut arriver ou qu'on les soupçonne
de faire une connerie s'il y a une prise
de sang tout çaah l'affaire de la BAC
Nord les les les les les gars de la BAC
Nord ils ont eu la chance quand ils ont
eu les prises de sang de pas avoir pour
auquun de stupe ça aurait pu arriver
qu'il y en a un dans le tas qui prenne
un peu de coque ou du un bambou ça peut
arriver il y a personne c'est pour ça
ils ont les cheveux court tu vas pas
chercher dans les moi c'est pas pour ça
que j'ai ch cour pour une autre raison
c'est une raison esthétique mais mais
euh
euh oui ça doit arriver mais c'est pas
non plus c'est pas un sujet massif oui
évidemment dans les flics tu vis on a
voir qui tape mais si tu as des postes
où tu peux être contrôlé vaut mieux
picoler en fait c'est c'est con hein
mais vaut mieux picoler parce que
quelque part ça on va te laisser faire
toi en tant que journaliste
d'investigation quand tu vois autant de
flic euh euh se suicider avec arme de
service ben voilà c'est exactement ça
puis quand tu te suicide avec l'arme de
service souvent sur les lieux de travail
c'est un message hein c'est pas c'est
pas le divorce hein donc ça c'est
primordial les conditions de la police
sont très complexes ça s'est accentué
depuis qu'en plus on leur fait faire un
travail inutile et que au fond d'eux ils
sont conscients que c'est inutile ils
savent très bien que ça va revenir ils
savent très bien que quand tu vas dans
un réseau il y a un effet plus mot ils
vont aller à côté ça serait bien que
quand tu prélèves c'est leur jargon
parfois une dizaine de petits Chouf ben
il y en a 10 qui vont arriver derrière
que quand tu prends un patron un un de
mes semirossistes et ben il y en a un
qui va devenir patron sachant tout ça
eux ils en sont conscients encore plus
que que le journaliste que je suis
c'est-à-dire que ils le voient ils ont
pas eu besoin de lire mes livres ils
sont conscients de ça après ils font
leur métier ils sont les infirmiers ils
vont penser les PL en permanence ils
vont penser les PL ils vont apporter
même je vais même plus loin je vais même
aller dans le bon sens ils vont apporter
du soin à la population il rentre dans
une cité quand il y a des grosses un moi
je suis pas pour les les les opérations
coup de point on arrive à 500 on sature
opération médiatique opération
médiatique
un intérêt sur une semaine quand même
bon c'est très coûteux pour une semaine
d'intérêt mais on va quand même le dire
c'est un intérêt sur une semaine c'est
que d'un seul coup on a enlevé les
épaves le résseau de stupe a été un peu
désarsonné on a lavé les cages
d'escalier les cages d'escalier il y a
des chariots il y a des choses qui sont
mis dedans pour empêcher la police de
monter parce que ça permet à notre
charbonneur celui enfin celui qui a la
sacoche d'aller se cacher dans une
nourrice dans un appartement et si tu ne
sais pas où est l'appartement tu peux
pas rentrer au hasard chez les gens
c'est la loi française et
donc c'est pour ça que les les les
escaliers sont saturés de trucs ça c'est
pas pour autre chose c'est pas pour
empêcher les gens de passer mais au
final ça empêcher les gens de passer
donc d'un seul coup pendant une semaine
[__] ils monent tranquillou il sont
pas fouillés à l'entrée ils sont pas il
y a pas des gamins parfois qui leur
parlent mal parce que souvent c'est des
gamins d'autres cités qui sont des cités
et des fois il y a pas de souvent même
il y a pas de d'acquintance alors que
par le passé les dealers et les gens ils
se connaissaient de moins en moins donc
c'est vrai que ces opérations coup de PO
ça apporte du soin c'est un truc
d'infirmier c'est l'infirmier qui vient
te soig tes PL qui te parle un peu tu
parles bien tu t'en vas et toi avec ta
maladie grave tu as pas c'est un bon
moment tu es bien pendant un moment mais
bon va falloir reprendre ça demain sauf
que l'infirmier là il revient pas dès le
lendemain et euh euh je peux te lire un
commentaire qui a un commentaire
question sur notre forum serait-il
possible de ne pas pleurer sur le sort
de la police qui n'a jamais eu autant de
blinder armes autorisation de mutiler et
bornier
d'accord c'est autre chose là on me
parle moi on me parle une police par
rapport au stup là on me répond sur une
police de de d' de comment s'appelle
l'ordre rubain de manif oui ok ok la
doctrine policière adoptée depuis les
dernières manifes avant même les gilets
jaunes moi je la trouve particulièrement
choquante mais bon moi on me pose des
questions sur les stupes je réponds sur
les stupes si on me pose des questions
sur les manifs les
grenades le le le les flashball LBD qui
sont tiré au lieu d'ê tiré comme ça ou
dans les jambes qui sont tirés
directement pour choper une tête bon je
suis complètement d'accord là c'est
c'est plutôt perturbant à minima là je
suis d'accord moi j'ai répondu sur les
stupes donc toujours pareil c'est comme
comme les dealers faut pas dire ils sont
tous dealers les flics ils ont pas les
mêmes métier hein un CRS qui fait de
l'ordre public c'est pas un c'est pas un
bqueux et c'est pas un mec de police
judiciaire c'est des métiers qui ont
complètement ils ont juste la même la
même institution et la même
administration hein ils ont la
commission d'emploi mais c'est pas les
mêmes donc oui la police n'a jamais eu
dans l'ordre public autant de moyens sur
le modèle de l'armée pendant la guerre
d'Algérie après c'est pas notre sujet
hein mais après on va digresser dans
tous les sens hein mais oui la police à
ce niveau-là on peut on peut contester
mais la police sur le trafic de stup moi
je pleure pas dessus je sais que la
police est dans des conditions
compliquées d'autant plus que ce qu'il
font ne sert à rien et qu'en plus ça les
détourne de d'autres missions qui sont
importantes qui vont être toute on va
dire toute la voix publique
cambriolage violence au personne tout ce
qui pourrit la vie du quotidien et qui
fait monter en plus la la xénophobie
parce que évidemment quand tu cambriolé
ben quand on chope le mec c'est un mec
de cité et aujourd'hui les mecs de cité
bah c'est plutôt des Maghrébins mais
parce que de notre histoire colonial et
ouvrière amené des
magrébins dans les années 60 on avait
d'autres personnes on a je pas les citer
ils vont tous raller mais en gros chaque
chaque vague d'immigration a eu ses
c'est c'estes bandit y compris les
piedsnoirs bandi piedsnoir je rappelle
que le Belge il est né je rappelle plus
des bandit portugais dis-moi alors il y
a eu alors est-ce que tu as eu une forte
immigration portugaise je suis pas
certain band du portugais tu as
peut-être raison par contre des
Espagnols j'en ai vu beaucoup à marseill
il y en a eu beaucoup des des des
Italiens alors carrément on les appelit
les Apaches ils avaient le même nom
qu'on donne aujourd'hui on les appel les
appaches on disait qu'ils égorgeaient
les gens ce qui jamais arrivé par
ailleurs après céit des banditisme dur c
un banditisme de terrain comme on dit
donc mais pour la police si on parle si
on pose la question sur les stupes ben
les stupes sont des sont des sont des
son c'est un ça vide la police ça épuise
la police et ça et ça en plus c'est
contre-productif par
contre voilà l'ordre publicique oui là
il y a un souci majeur il y a d'autres
soucis hein dans la police hein on pour
il y a un problème de racisme dans la
police hein on a fait rentrer quand
Sarkozi fait sa RGPP paradoxalement
alors qu'on s'attend à ce qu'il fasse du
sécuritaire ça casse la police il y a un
nombre de personnes il y a il y a voilà
tous ceux qui partent à la retraite
pendant tout son mandat ben il sont pas
remplacés donc la police est
particulièrement à la rigueur les
Parisiens sen rendent pas compte parce
qu'ici il y a un nombre de policiers
inimaginable c'est les chiffres sont
hallucinant et par rapport à Marseille
qui fait quatre fois la taille de Paris
he en superficie même c'est pas dense
euh à un moment on avait 400 flic qui
faisait qui sur sur sur la la voie
publique aujourd'hui on a on a on en a
beaucoup plus mais à un moment dans le
pire du moment on avit 400 quand Holland
arrive sval son premier ministre à
l'époque est plutôt insécuritaire et
rapidement le syndicat qui force
Ouvrière unité police à l'époque dit on
est on tire la langue on est à la rue he
surtout à Marseille et là il faut il
faut recruter 200 personnes rien que
pour Marseille mais il en faut 200 200
autres à travers la France plus les de à
400 que tu mets à Paris chaque année
donc et on a des écoles de police qui ne
font que 200 personnes par an donc en
fait tu es dans un cass-etette pas
possible il faut 2 ans de formation donc
en fait on prend des ADS à jeune
sécurité donc on prend toute une série
de persones où on fait du ramassage
scolaire à sur 20 ou 5 sur 20 pour
rentrer B en fait grosso modo à partir
du moment où tu as pas de casier tu peux
devenir flic et où tu es capable de
passer deux trois tests physiques tu
deviens ADS alors la plupart des ADS
vont bien travailler faire toujours
attention va pas dire les ADS des Toka
c'est pas ça l'histoire mais dans la
masse monstrueuse des ADS on a pas de
formation et on a des gens qui sont pas
aptes normalement tout de suite à être
policier et ces mecsl quand ils vont
monter ben je suis désolé mais l'extrême
droite elle se nourrit de de ignorance
et quand tu tuas une forte proportion de
policiers qui viennent en dessous comme
ça mais tu vas te retrouver avec des
officiers qui sont dans un certain
cindicat et tu vas te retrouver avec
force ouvrière qui va petit à petit se
faire dégommer et alliance qui va passer
devant après alliance ils ont fait un
travail syndical près des gens aussi al
je vais dire du bien d'alliance force
alliance ils ont toujours être équilibré
non mais que parce qu'il faut pas non
plus être politiquement que sur ça
alliance ils ont compris un truc c'est
que ça tournait mal pour
le le travail le qutidien de des agents
là où force ouvriillar a été un peu plus
politique et s'est dit on va essayer de
de de garder avec soi les élus on va
essayer d'avoir une population qui nous
aime quand même comme la population elle
est pas proflique quand même donc ils
ont essayé de jouer un jeu où il
ménageit tout le monde alliance s'est
dit moi je vais défendre mes je vais
défendre directement mes bonhommes
bonhommes qui sont là des ces comme ça
qui sont jamais remboursé leur leur qui
ont tellement de de de de qu' partent à
la retraite de ou 3 ou 4 ans avant quand
ils partent à la retraite pour certains
même pas tu vois donc donc alliance a su
faire ça alliance a eu cette
intelligence là particulièrement à
Marseille d'ailleurs le patron
d'alliance qui est un type que
j'apprécie de de Marseille David Olivier
RGI Davido il a été nommé il a pris des
fonctions importantes à au niveau
national c'est pas pour rien c'est c'est
c'est voilà quand après alliance a
tendance aussi à à essayer de vouloir
avoir plus d'armes alors qu'on a pas un
problème d'arme on se tire pas dessus et
puis quand ils disent on se fait tirer
dessus c'est pas vrai il y a pas de ils
font quand même tiré dessus j'ai pas vu
ça ils font tiré dessus au mortier ah
voilà al là pareil au mortier Harry
Potter quoi Harry Potter non mais
regarde les vidéos c'est Harry Potter tu
as l'impression de voir d'accord joli à
l'image tu t'es déjà pris un coup de
mortier moi je pr un coup de morti oui
bien sûr bien sûr que c'est dangereux le
feu de bingal un peu plus oui c'est
dangereux oui c'est dangereux mais de
toute façon une pierre dans la gueule
C'est dangereux un un oui c'est
dangereux maintenant je vais fonctionner
comme un réseau de stup et je vais te
raconter avec ça sabac nord et les
scènes où tu as l'impression que tu tu
as été dans World World War Z tu sais
des zombies qui se jettent sur la
voiture on dirait qu'ils veulent bouffer
les flics j'arrive pas à comprendre ce
qu'ils veulent dans le film ils sont là
ils satent sur la voiture te dis mais
qu'est-ce qu'ils fait il veulent les
manger ou quoi en fait un réseau de stup
il veut pas d'emmerde un chef de un chef
de plan il va voir tous c tous ses tous
ces bonhommes il va dire les gars si
elle est condée je parle comme eux vous
les laisser rentrer
on s'en va en courant surtout on protège
la sacoche hein on protège un tel et
ensuite ils st bon et lui en plus il
s'en servira comme je disais pour
endetter un peu les
gens si il bloque l'accès au flic mais
tu vas avoir du renfort c'est
automatique et maintenant il y a des CRS
qui sont spécifiques à ça et ils vont
venir te casser les couilles pendant 2 3
jours et tu vas plus travailler auou
moins bien parce que le client il a peur
parce que toi si tu t'adaptes si tu le
client il arrive avec sa petite voiture
il voit il voit des CRS partout il se
dit attends attends attends moi je vais
dans l'autre cité hein et il s'en va de
toute façon c'est au client c'est la
destination c'est le client quand on te
dit il s'adapte et que tu as des caméras
qui les filment 3 minutes après ils sont
déjà à côté oui ils sont déjà à côté
mais ils vendent de quoi ils vendent ils
vendent au cramer locaux mais le le le
gars qui vient acheter son truc habituel
il se dit oh il a trop de flic là donc
ça pose problème donc ils veulent pas
qu'il y ait de problème comme ça donc
ils ont tendance à empêcher les
caillassages c'est l'inverse je donne
une anecdote qui est arrivé dans une
cité marseillaise il y a pas longtemps
ils avaient mis un mec un poste de vigis
c'est un poste important dans certaines
cités il est au sur le toit d'un
immeuble et il regarde et quand il y a
vraiment la voiture de de police qui
arrive il crie et c'est le premier qui
qui parle et on avait mis un nouveau et
un nouveau qui sétait fait monter la
tête par du rap par deci par de là était
là con con con mais il avait pas compris
c'était pas à marseillais il avait pas
compris qu'en fait c'est calmos on pense
business on pense pas rap et il a pris
un un extincteur et il a jeté sur la
voiture de police les flics qui
fréquentent cette cité depuis 3000 ans
qui sont au courant que que ils vont se
prendre quelque chose d'habitude ils
prennent une pomme sur la voiture c'est
juste un message pour dire cassez-vous
on est chez nous pour les plus cons ils
vont tirer une pierre qui va un peu
c'est pas bien mais qui vont un peu
abîmer la voiture là c'est un extincteur
qui est tombé sur le capot avant qui a
fait un trou énorme si ça peut tuer
quelqu'un là les flics ils l'ont mal
pris hein et ils ont raison normal ah
non mais c'est plus que normal mais en
fait c'est très concret ils ont fait
venir dans un premier temps du renfort
et après ils ont dit là on vous met la
misère on part plus on part plus tant
pis on perd notre travail dans d'autres
cités mais vous on vous met la misère au
bout du 4e jour les deal on les dealers
sont rentrés dans le commissariat en
tenant le mec qu'ils avaient fracassé et
en lui disant voilà il est là c'est lui
c'est un abruti il est pas au courant il
sait pas comment on travaille il est là
ils l'ont posé et les fes ils ont encore
tenu un ou de jours parce qu'il faut pas
non plus baisser hein et ils ont ils ils
ont fini par se retirer et le gars il
avait pas pigé c'est la discrétion qui
compte alors il y a quelques exceptions
c'est ce qui va donner lieu à nos vidéos
qui vont être exploité derrière
surexploité si des mecs ont un arrivage
de 10 kg 5 kg ou 10000 € sur eux 15000 €
là il faut sauver ça donc là il va y
avoir des jeunes qui vont essayer de
sauver le gars de l'interpellation et si
c'est possible parce que tu y as qu'une
unité de de de de bas il sont que trois
ou une BST là ce qu'on appelle souvent
les otiers bon ils vont tenter le coup
et regardez ils vont jamais aller ils
vont pas faire de trop de violence ils
vont faire attention ils vont rarement
enfin ils vont rarement lycher un mec
parce que la police derrière va te
retrouver tu vas prendre cher hein euh
violence sur personne dépositaire de
l'autorité publique tu vas prendre cher
et c'est normal hein je dis pas que
c'est pas normal ce qui veut dire qu'en
fait ils sont conscients des de la loi
ils sont conscients de l'attente des des
des dealers de leur chef et voilà s'il
faut sauver un mec qui est important
parce que c'est un chef s'il faut sauver
une somme d'argent ou du produit s'il
faut sauver une cache d'armes une cache
un truc là où ils vont agir c'est là
qu'on voit les vidéos tout ça mais la
plupart du temps c'est allezy rentrer tu
parles de réglementation qui connaissent
très bien la loi quand tu te fais
attraper avec un de cannabis une tonne
ou 500 kg si c'est du 38 % tu prends TS
mais si c'est du 12 % tu prends la même
chose oui c'est pas est-ce que est-ce
que les les mecs ont compris et c'est
pour ça qu'on a du cannabis à 38 % au G
c'est pour la coupe c'est pour la coupe
on fait plus à la fin CP parce qu'en
fait tu as 1 kil au départ qui va
devenir 2 kg qui va devenir 4 kg et en
bout de chaînne ça vair 6 kg il y a plus
rien
et en fait le 38 % n'est pas fumable
pars il va y avoir trois trois rastas
qui vont dire il est pas fort mec mais
al sorti de Cuxa il y en a pas quoi il
est pas fumable et donc on se débrouille
à le couper de manière à à le aîné le C
le là pour que ça devienne fumable et
puis et puis tu vends tu vends ça et ce
que je disais quand on coupe à l'huile
de vidange heureusement c'est pas
l'huile de vidange c'est vraiment les
réseaux les plus pourris hein on n'est
pas dans les les les bons réseaux hein
mais bon ça peut arriver de fumer
l'huile de vidange ceux qui fument ça
peut arriver et notamment quand on a euh
celui qui est alors ils ont des noms
différents d'un réseau il y en a qui
appelleent ça l'Afghan d'autres qui
appellent ça le pollen d'autres qui
appelleent ça la crème en fait c'est un
cheit qui est dit très bon parce que il
est il est il est crémeux il est tu tu
le et donc quand c'est de la qualité en
effet c'est du cheit très très très bon
en THC qui va pas te t'agresser qui va
monter doucement ou bien qui va pas te
te faire de mauvais trip donc les
spécialistes ils ont des ils ont ils
sont subtiles hein il y a des zologues
du du du du du cheat hein et
pour donner cet effet là des fois ils
mettent de l'huile de vidange dedans en
coupe et donc tu as cet effet en effet
tu comme ça j'en ai vu moi j'en ai eu
dans les mains j'ai même vu comment il
coupé ils m'ont montré comment il fait
une cité je raconte dans c'est le début
de mon livre La Fabrique du monstre
c'est comment il coupe donc il mixe tu
prends du cheat tu le tu le tu le mixes
tu le coupes en en morceaux tu mélanges
avec ton produit de coupe tu le chauffes
voilà tu le chauffes alors soit tu
chauffes au bainmi soit tu le chauffes
au au au micro-ondes alors ça pas le
même effet le B mari c'est mieux hein
c'estàd qui font ça bien il font auain
mari donc c'est cuisiners les gars et
après tu le places sous des planches et
il y a des réseaux où ils ont carrément
des compresseurs ENF je sais pas comment
ça s'appelle qui sont utilisés dans le
BTP souvent et il y en a c'est un mec
qui s'assoit dessus moi ce que j'ai vu
c'est un réseau de du pauvre le gars ils
ont pris le plus gros il s'appelit boule
ils l'ont mis il s'ass dessus je
commence mon livre comme ça la fabrique
du mon et ce qui m'a étonné c'est qu'en
plus les mecs ils fume un bambou avec le
produit qu'ils ont coupé je dis les gars
pourquoi vous fumez pas avant ils m'ont
répondu cette phrase célèbre qui est on
s'en bat les couilles donc on s'en bat
les couilles ça veut dire c'est bon on
est perdu de toute façon ils en sont
conscients c'est bon ils sont perdus ils
on ils sont perdus c'est bon ils s'en
foutent ceux-là là les cramés cramés ils
ont ils sont déjà sur un un un destin
brûlé vif ils sont déjà sur la fin ça
dure ce que ça dure ils ont pas
d'illusion ceux-l les cramés les
quelques 2 3000 5000 à Marseille cux
c'est bon on prend ce qu'on prend là on
voit ce qu'on voit un moment une fille
un moment donc euh
euh voilà c'est c'est ces produits de
coupe c'est vachement euh c'est
vachement important hein dans dans dans
le business hein
euh question
internet je j'en attrape une je la lit
de l'œil droit j'en profite pour vous
dire n'oubliez pas de nous soutenir sur
tipi c'est grâce à vous qu'on est
indépendant c'est grâce à vous qu'on
peut faire autant d'interviews première
question je suis marocain et depuis
quelques temps j'ai une théorie qui vaut
ce qu'elle vaut sur une question que je
me suis longtemps posée le Maroc a-t-il
besoin de soutenir la production et
l'exportation du cannabis dans le but de
récupérer des devises intégrées aux
réserve de change afin de garantir la
stabilité du diram essentielle au regard
du volume d'importation du pays
interrogation alors je vais pas faire
semblement de m'y connaître dans le
domaine je veux faire la réponse que je
peux faire à mon
niveau ce qui est sûr c'est que la
coopération internationale avec le Maroc
c'est c'est une solution en terme de
production avec la Colombie c'est
presque impossible c'est presque
possible de faire
arrêter le coca mais par contre avec le
Maroc il y a eu des discussions qui ont
été faites plusieurs
fois c'est un choix géopolitique c'est
un choix géostratégique c'est-à-dire
est-ce que on se débrouille à faire que
les marocain se mett dans une
agriculture légale et gagn au temp et
après et après on fait un gros travail
sur ce qu'on a de de de de grosse
délinquence marocaine he de de je sais
pas j'oseis pas les appeler param c'est
un mot un peu galvodé mais gros caï euh
euh voilà là moi mes mes compétences
géopolitiques s'arrêent là quel est
l'intérêt est-ce que en effet il y a pas
de l'argent qui revient comment ça se
passe est-ce que le roi du Maroc est
complice j'y crois pas trop en tout cas
pas directement ou en tout cas plusieurs
bandes si c'est le cas moi j'y pense je
pense pas et est-ce que on est sur un
laissé faire ça permet autre chose je le
sais pas voilà je je pas mais en tout
cas ce qui est sûr c'est que les la
réponse elle est géopolitique on parlait
des flics et les pauvres qui sont sur le
terrain je parle de Cuxa les pauvres qui
vident la mer à la petite cuillère mais
la mer en fait elle arrive par là c'est
c'est c'est c'est l'embouchure pour le
pour le chit c'est le Maroc donc est-ce
qu'on doit pas travailler sur sur
l'embouchure oui clairement est-ce que
c'est possible là c'est des diplomates
qu'il faut demander ça là
c'est des diplomates il en reste en
France il en reste peut-être sûr
question internet bonjour expérience de
pensée vous avez absolument tous les
moyens et pouvoir quelles sont les trois
décisions extrêmement concrètes que vous
appliquez en premier pour tenter de
régler le problème c'est une très bonne
question
euh ben je vais prendre trois axe il
faut avoir un axe sur le côté policier
je vais répondre un axe sur le côté
consommation et un axe sur le le le le
côté dealer de terrain
euh donc le un axe légalisation ben ça
va rentrer là-dedans ce que je vais dire
va va prendre les trois trucs parce que
légalisation je pas ayat légalisation
elle est inéluctable on peut pas ne pas
la faire et on serait le seul pays
quasiment au monde à pas la faire donc
on la fera mais légalisation ou
dépénalisation la dépénalisation est un
mot qui veut parler de qui veut partir
de la prohibition à autre chose
dépénalisation c'est un mot valise où tu
mets n'importe quoi tout il y a plein de
des pénalisations possibles légalisation
c'est le système hollandais tout est
légal on fait ce qu'on veut ça on sait
déjà que c'est très mauvais donc on a
pas besoin de le faire par contre des
des pénalisations ça nous donne plein
d'axes poss possible euh
moi sur le premier truc que je fais
c'est de l'aide sociale forte mais
contrôlé c'està-dire on remet du
social dans les quartiers populaires et
je la je la soutiens l'aide sociale
c'est gentil dit comme ça on a
l'impression qu'on va qu'on va donner
l'omone il faut pas que ce soit ça il
faut que ce soit du développement
économique il faut qu'il y ait du
travail donc la question c'est tu à tous
les moyens donc je je suis un peu dans
l'utopie mais il faut surtout en ce
moment es archi dans l'utopie voilà sauf
que moi je pense que la solution demain
elle vient des quartiers populaires les
jeunes ils sont où aujourd'hui sont les
quartiers populaires quartier Nord
quartier pauvre est ce que tu veux mais
la solution elle est là tu veux produire
mais ceux qui étaient les ouvriers
d'avant c'est ceuxl tu veux on parle de
refaire des industries refaire des S B
ils sont là à Marseille on a les
spécialistes dans le banditisme mondiaux
de la carte bleue le jour où où il je
veux pas dire la cité mais il travaille
sur les cartes bleu on a c'est eux qu'
ont créé au début le collet marseillais
qui est connu dans le monde entier et
carrément quand il y a le colollet
Marseillais qui est fait en Asie ils
appellent une unité spéciale qui
s'appelle la BRA brigade brigade de
répression des atteintes au bien et qui
est spécialisé dans la carte bleue ils
ont une une une une une sorte de de de
de plateforme d'écoute pour le monde
entier tellement les Marseillais il se
sont développés là-dedans et aujourd'hui
ils travaillent dans tout il a il
travailleent avec des hackeurs roumains
dans dans cette cité là et ils
travaillent sur sur du hacking donc des
compétences autres que wesh le le a tout
ça il y en a ben euh utilisonsles un peu
formons vraiment des gens aujourd'hui
les formations les écoles elles sont
dégueulasses elles sont dégueulasses pas
à cause des profs ils se battent ils
sont rent plus ils se battent ils font
ce qu'ils peuvent mais en fait tu
rentres tu es dans des écoles dès le
début c'est des c'est une sorte de
ségrégation scolaire enfin voilà il y a
tout à revoir là-dessus donc
développement économique et donc ça veut
dire beaucoup de choses moi je suis
exprès de choisir quelque chose qui est
chapeau parce que c'est puisque j'ai que
trois vœux he à ma fait donc
développement économique ben ça veut
dire qu'il y a beaucoup d'options à
faire ça c'est pour le côté soutien au
au quartier populaire et je dirais qu'il
faut faire ça aussi au rural parce que
je ne sépare pas du tout le populaire du
rural et pour moi c'est de des milieux
populaires milieux pauvre milieux pauvre
et euh ensuite pour le le
côté
policiers travailler à l'international
beaucoup plus encore plus je dirais
parce qu'ils le font déjà avec de la
coopération et surtout de encore plus de
travail d'enquête retravailler
l'infiltration arrêter avec les cellules
de ciblage c'est une blague une cellule
de ciblage c'est pour justement
compenser le fait que maintenant on
contrôle plus les les conttaineurs avant
le douanier il en contrôlait beaucoup il
avait le flair mais le flair ça voulait
dire qu'il avait deux trois infos qui
sentait des trucs par habitude par
l'expérience aujourd'hui on a on a
normalisé la cellule de ciblage
c'est-à-dire on a des protocoles on a
soit-disant c'est pas al je suppose
qu'ils vont faire rentrer lia là-dedans
mais de toute façon il faut rentrer des
des ingénieurs si vous voulez de de du
ciblage qui connaissent en regardant des
cartes et des flux de bateau lequel est
susceptible de transporter tel cargaison
tout ça et cette C du ciblage on va
justement contrôler ce Tru là et en fait
évidemment ils ont des résultats
apparents puisqu'ils vont saisir
quelques milliers de tonnes sur à
l'échelle européenne donc c'est le
chiffre est gros la réalité c'est par
rapport au moyen et par rapport au
manque de moyens qu'on donne pour le
reste pour moi ça sert à rien c'est pour
moi l'équivalent de la vidéosurveillance
qui est une illusion on te fait croire
que ça marche alors qu'en fait
protection mais la vidéoprection mais
moi je préfère vidéosurveillance parce
que un jour euh moi journaliste
vidéosurveillance va faire que je
n'aurais plus le droit d'aller tel ou
tel endroit donc je serai plus protégé
un syndicaliste aura le même problème un
homo aura le même problème et euh euh un
gars d'extrême gauche aura le même
problème voire un gars d'extrême droite
à qui en fonction de qui prend le
pouvoir tu peux te retrouver à dire ah
non monsieur vous passez plus donc tu
peux te dire moi je m'en fous de la
vidéo surveillance la réalité c'est que
ça tombera dessus à un moment un autre
euh mais en plus on sait de sources
sûres c'està-dire que l'Australie a
montré ça ne sert pas par rapport à la
somme qui est dit c'estàdire il y a des
résultats mais par rapport aux millions
d'euros qui sont investis qui favorisent
des lobbyes bah si tu mets la même somme
dans de l'humain tu as des meilleurs
résultats tu mets la même somme dans des
enquêteurs et dans des policiers de
terrain tu as des meilleurs résultats
mais électoralement parlant avir des
caméras ça fait rêver le banditisme pour
la petite histoire arrive à voir des
gens qui sont derrière ses caméras et
qui leur qui et qui planquent pour eux
donc c'est super pour le banditisme
aussi il y a des gens qui c'est un voyou
qui m'avait expliqué me dit avant quand
il fallait planquer pour faire un casse
on resté 8 10 mois dans des coffres de
voiture à regarder on sortait c'est
compliqué on prenait des notes tu dis
maintenant tu payes un agent de de de de
la ville il est là il est un peu discret
il est malin il sait qu'à telle heure il
faut qu'il regarde qu'il mette la caméra
il il prend pas des notes sur place il a
de la mémoire on prend des mecs un peu
un peu dégourdis il ressort il donne les
quatre infos il sait jamais à qui il les
a donné il sait pas pourquoi il sait
juste qu'on l'a payé pour ça va tout
seul je te dis pas que c'est massif je
te dis pas qu'ils le font tous c'est un
outil qui est bien pratique aussi pour
le pour le itisme la visosurveillance
puis à chaque fois qu'il y a un mec qui
est là vous avez vu à molembec ils ont
tiré à la calache en pleine rue et on
arrive pas à les reconnaître et ben oui
bien sûr il met des cagoules sont pas
complètement cons et j'explique dans la
fabrique du monre comment même ils
s'organisent avec des vêtements ils vont
faire des arrachages et après il je
change des vêtements manière à ce que ce
soit confus tu as celui qui tu es en
rouge il est rouge et bleu pu et au
final juridiquement parlant tu peux rien
faire même si tu sais que tu les as le
gars il dit non non mais moi j'étais pas
là non mais j'étais pas en rouge j'étais
en bleu terminé donc ça vaut rien euh et
finalement la la pourquoi je je faisais
la la la la comparaison avec de
du de la vidéo protection avec avec quoi
déjà la vidéos surveillance la vidéos
surveillance pardon ah ouais tu vois je
rentre dans le rang la vidéo
surveillance et je faisais la la la la
comparaison avec oui avec les cellules
de ciblage cellule de ciblage c'est la
vidéo surveillance géante c'està-dire on
met des moyens considérable on a
quelques résultats de temps en temps
mais remettons des moyens un déjà dans
le contrôle tant pis si l'économie a va
moins vite tant pis si ça ad avec la CMA
CGM il fait un peu moins de sous parce
que c'est plus lent c'est pas grave tant
pis il en gagne beaucoup il gagne 38
milliards d'euros ça va si s'il en gagne
que 30 au lieu de 38 c'est pas grave et
donc tu ralentis le le truc ça il
faudrait le faire à une échelle très
grande si tu fais en France évidemment
les gens ils vont passer par la par par
les autres pays donc là aussi par
rapport au vœux à la fée ben il faut que
ce soit le plus large possible ce qu'
fait que tu remets du contrôle euh ce
que vont faire les États-Unis contrôle
aux frontières donc ça c'est le côté
policier donc infiltration à nouveau et
puis du contrôle he du contrôle
douignier la solution elle est aussi
douinière les douiniers ils ont été
complètement laminés sous Sarco alors
qu'ils sont extraordinaires et ils sont
extraordinaires les douiniers ouais mais
ils sont extraordinaires mais pas très
nombreux donc ils plus très nombreux
donc quand tu es pas nombreux tu peux
être autant extraordinaire que tu veux
tu fais pas grand-chose
et et après au niveau du du du des
dealers je vais rester sur mes jeunes
parce que les autres au niveau des
dealers pour moi il faut les faire
rentrer dans l'économie légale et c'est
faisable parce que moi tous les gamins
que je croise sans exception me disent
au frérot tu as un CDI tu es un CDI ils
veulent bosser parce qu'ils sont pris
dans quelque chose où ils voient que
c'est mort alors quelquesuns je rappelle
parce que je peux pas non plus trop
laisser penser que personne ne gagne
rien on ve dire 15 20 % des petits
dealers vont réussir à mettre de côté
vont se monquer monter une boîte j'ai
dit tout à l'heure faut pas les oublier
mais vont amorcer quelque chose dans 2 3
ans ils existent ok bien joué les gars
bravo vous avez été bon ils sont partis
la plupart ils veulent travailler quand
on dit ils gagnent beaucoup ils
travaillent pas c'est pas vrai
puisqu'ils sont endettés ils veulent
bosser et en fait ils sont loin de
l'emploi pour énormément de ce qu'on
appelle les frein périphérique à
l'emploi parce qu'ils sont dans des
quartiers où ça le fait pas parce qu'ils
ont des noms qu' font pas parce qu'ils
ont pas de formation parce qu'ils ont
pas de savoir-être quand tu as été élevé
par un réseau de stup euh à la fois il
parle des fois un peu comme Michael
Jackson ça va frérot il parle tout
gentil [__] ce coup il devient ultra
agressif plus regentil puis donc en
fait il y a quand même un passage parle
de l'inclusion sociale je sais pas
comment l'insertion je sais pas un
passage où une sorte de on va
réapprendre les codes ça marche avec
tous ceux avec qui on le fait hein à
part les cas psy les cas psy ça marche
pas et on me dit ah ouais mais ça marche
pas ça marche pas vous me prenez les
Baba vous me prenez ceux qu'il faudrait
traiter psychiatriquement
psychologiquement parlant mais ceux
c'est-à-dire la plupart qui ont pas
descsis on y arrive ça prend un peu de
temps faut un peu faire rêver faut
arrêter de dire qu'il vont être rapeurs
au footballeur euh non ils vont pas être
rppeur et footballeurs des zidanes des
des des des mecs comme ça il y en a il y
en a pas et il y a un sur 1000 qui
redevient pro dans les jeunes qui au
foot et pro ça veut dire division 2
National 3 ça veut pas dire division 1
donc il y a personne donc il faut leur
dire tu vas monter une entreprise tu vas
travailler comme fonctionnaire là tu vas
être tu vas avoir une carrière mais tu
donne ta chance la chance aujourd'hui il
y a une partie de discrimination
positive qui marche et une partie de
jeunes qui font vraiment des études qui
se battent qui obtiennent quelque chose
et qui sont souvent mis de côté parce
qu'en plus on est dans un contexte
difficile mais quand tu viens l'adresse
peut suffire hein tu viens la citer Coro
c'est mal barré hein même si tu
t'appelles bon si tu t'appelles Pujol
comme moi fil Pujol ça va le faire mais
si tu t'appelles t fi benamo tu mal
barré quoi
euh ça ça va être dur hein et donc
euh là aussi sur la discrimination faut
trouver des trucs elles existent qu'on
le eu ou non après on va me dire oui
victim se victimise tout ça non ça
existe c'est compliqué et donc un de mes
vœux c'est vraiment ça c'est
développementcon omque et on fait passer
les les jeunes dans l'égal ils veulent
un CDI et ben si tu fais un bilan de
compétence tu fais passer le côté le
côté compéten Tup de quoi tu es capable
de faire il y en a ils sont comptables
d'utres bon il y en a les compétences
sont limitées je le sais mais d'autres
ils ont des vraies compétences et tu
essayes de les faire rentrer dans les
réseaux c'est des choses qui se
travaillent que tu vas voir à Marseille
il y a des choses qui se qui se mettent
en place làdessus avec des tentatives
qui marchent évidemment l'échelle est
trop petite mais en en gros pour parler
comme un politique il faut un plan
Marchal de de des quartiers pauvre et il
faut couper cette ségrégation et essayer
de remettre une mixité sociale qui
passera avant tout par l'école et pour
ça il faut 15 ans et si on légalise le
cannabis alors la légalisation on va je
veux dire même si je suis pas un
spécialiste je m'y connais quand même
pas mal euh première des choses à faire
urgent qui coûte rien à personne même
même dans la posture morale même dans la
posture presque religieuse qu'on
certains ça coûte rien c'est le système
portugais de
décriminalisation comme je disais il y a
principalement de la consommation
d'addiction même si on la nomme pas
comme telle tiens je vais dire encore
pour les gens qui regardent quand on est
une soirée on a l'impression qu'on est
une soirée entre bobo ou entre entre
mecs qui font la fête et il y en a un il
fume du bambou il se met minable il
arrête pas quand on regarde en fait le
profil 9 fois sur 10 c'est un mec qui a
des problèmes dans la vie c'est un mec
qui a un divorce qui a qui a une petite
dépression et c'est absolument pas du
festif on appelle festif parce qu'on le
voit à ce moment-là mais en fait il fait
ça tout le temps et nous quand on se
fume le petit bonbo à ce moment-là là
c'est du festif mais c'est pas ça qui
fait vivre le réseau d'ailleurs en plus
généralement ceux qui fument du Festif
ils vont taper chez les chez ceux qu' on
l'addiction ils achètent même pas ils
vont taper sur le bambou des autres donc
en
fait il faut travailler les addictions
et pour ça faut être dans un cadre légal
tu passes en médecine du travail
aujourd'hui tu es je sais pas moi je ve
prendre un marin dans les marins on
prend beaucoup de coques un un un gars
qui est dans le un routier donc c'est
dangereux hein de la coque pour les mais
bon il faut pas qu'ils dorment les mecs
ils ont des cadences de fou pas qu'il
dorment pr de la coque hein ils font pas
être con Red Bull hein un moment ça
suffit plus hein et
donc ces mecs là il passent devant la
médecine du travail le médecin il est
pas dupe il va les pupies il voit le
truc il est il est au courant c'est bon
ils sont médecins il va lui dire est-ce
que vous prenez l'alcool alors le le mec
du BTP marseillais va dire ah un petit
jeune c'est vrai que des fois on abuse
un peu c'est vrai que c'est compliqué on
se fait un peu bon mais celui qui abuse
trop de de de de de l'alcool il va
rentrer dans un parcours de soin et ça
marche on a fait baisser la consommation
sur ces 30 dernières années de façon
énorme on boit beaucoup moins en France
que il y a 30 ans mais beaucoup beaucoup
moins c'est c'est phénoménal et c'est
principalement lié à cette à la médecine
du travail au changement de de
comportement le même gars on lui dit la
coque il va dire non moi la coque je
touche pas c'est un truc pour les
bourgeois ça il va dire ça c'est un truc
pour les bobos c'est pour les bourgeois
ça c'est combien le gram de Cook le la
coque du pauvre c'est 50 € le gramme
donc tu fais 10 rails avec c'est 5 € le
rail à Paris tu a même pas une bière
avec ça à Marseille tu en a deux et euh
euh et à à à et la et la la coque du
riche elle qui est un peu un peu de
meilleure qualité entre 70 et 100 € le
GAM mais quand on a 100 € le gram
attention elle peut être très forte je
le répète il faut se méfier et euh c'est
interdit et de toute façon quoi qu'il
arrive tout ça est interdit et donc euh
euh médecine du travail médecine du
travail il voit bien qu'il y a de la
coque mais le gars il dit non moi je
prends pas de la coque mais on le voit
mais monsieur mais je vois bien que pour
la co non moi j'en prends pas il lâchera
rien il lâchera rien ou s'il lâche il il
voudra pas que soit écrit parce qu'en
fait il veut pas être hors la loi
puisqueon on sanctionne et même s'il
rentre dans un parcours de soin
spécifique où tu es pas sanctionné mais
va pas te croire nù tu as vu que tu
crois l'institution tu crois pas
l'administration tu la crois pas jamais
de la vie tu crois pas les impôts quand
ils viennent tu crois personne donc tu
crois pas celui qui va dire non non vous
verrez donc faut être dans un dans un
cadre légal et donc tu fais la
décriminalisation c'est un truc un peu
bizarre un peu
ouais ça c'est c'est c'est vrai que tu
as pas le droit de vendre tu as pas le
droit d'acheter tu as le droit de
consommer c'est bizarre puisque tu es
pas censé avoir le produit mais une fois
que tu l'as tu as le droit de le prendre
en fait ça ne sert qu'à ça ça ne sert
qu'à appliquer
euh des des des grandes campagne de
prévention notamment par la médecine du
travail la médecine au lycée à la fac
parce que les étudiants aussi avant ils
prenaient des les étudiants qui qui
prenaient des choses prenaient avant du
pas du LSD des des acides comment
s'appelle des amphétamines là maintenant
ils prennent de la d'ailleurs chaque
université a son réseau de de coque moi
j'étais c'est dramatique ah oui c'est
dramatique moi j'étais à Saint-Charles
plein centr-eville et une époque où il y
avait pas besoin de moi j'étais étudiant
il y avait pas beaucoup de coqus il y
avait un petit peu de de mecs qui
voulaient vraiment réussir les examens
qui prenaient des enfit et il devaient
les trouver je sais pas où et à côté il
y a une cité qui s'appelle le rakati où
il y avait personne ben là le rakati
c'est tombé chez Yoda après les dés je
crois ENF je sais pas je vaux pas me
tromper de marque et et le racatis est
devenu une cité pour les étudiants à
côté c'estàd il y a une évolution les
Olivi dont je parlais tout à l'heure ils
sont à côté de la fac Saint-Jérôme
chaque fac a son à son à ses réseaux et
et et donc médecine du travail médecine
universitaire tout ça ben tu es dans un
cadre légal tu vas rentrer dans des
parcours de soins et les gens sont
demandeurs puisque les gens ils sont
dans une addiction ils dépensent de
l'argent ils ont le cœur qui bat à 3000
quand ils rentrent à la maison ils sont
obligés de fumer des bonbou pour
redescendre des fois ils mettent des
coups au petit petit Bryan en rentrant
alors que il ils veulent pas Bry
alors tu vas avoir les Gaspard les Bryan
je je pour avoir un petit peu toutes les
Kevin et Kevin VO Kevin c'est un peu
vaste maintenant donc en fait tu tu tu
tu tu tu tu as une nécessité de de
travailler sur ces addictions donc la la
la décriminalisation elle peut se faire
dans l'année là on pe on peut la décider
maintenant et après bon il va y avoir
ceux qui disent ça pour favorir la
drogue vous ouvrez nos enfants vont se
droguer mais la drogue c'est pas bien la
drogue c'est c'est destructeur mais
comme les open bar aujourd'hui ne
faisons pas semblant de dire que euh la
prohibition va empêcher nos enfants se
droguer il se drogue mais par contre on
n pas la possibilité de les traiter donc
si vraiment la drogue c'est restructeur
et qu'on est pour la santé publique ben
il faut être pour la décriminalisation
ou alors tu es pour la destruction de
tes gamins c'est ça il faut inverser
discours là-dessus et souvent moi je
parle d'un laxisme intellectuel sur la
question de il y a pas de l'xisme
sécuritaire la sécurité c'est le seul
truc qu'on fait c'est le seul moyen
qu'on donne il y a un laxisme social
alors je vais me faire à la fois des
amis et des ennemis il y a ceux qui sont
pour les questions sociales ce que je
disais le soutien aux familles parce
qu'une famille qui est très endettée B
va tomber dans lesestupes alors une
famille qui est pas endettée ne tombera
pas des stup pour moi il faut un soutien
social fort et en même temps il y a un
laxisme intellectuel c'est dire on ne
pense pas les réseaux on voit à la
surface oh ouais il gagnne beaucoup de
prix qu' lo des Ferrari ah ouais ils ont
des Ferrari oui mais ils sont 10 àelle
la loué pour la journée elle fait 1500 €
la journée il la loue à 10 il mettent
150 € chacun ils font des snaps des
snaps des snaps ils savent pas la
conduire il y a eu un fait d'hiver où il
y a un mec qui a qui a écrasé quelqu'un
avec Lamborghini là en région parisienne
parce que tu sais pas conduire tu es un
Mino de 19 ans tu es un zgeg tu fais le
mariool en permanence mais tu as conduit
qu'une Clio dans ta vie d'un seul coup
tu as une tu as une tuas tu as ton
permis depuis 1 an bon ils savent
conduire depuis 13 14 ans on va dire
mais bon ils savent pas en fait ils ont
conduit que que que que sur la play
c'est que dans GTA ils ont conduit et
d'un seul coup ils ont une Ferrari
Chapuis ou une Lamborghini ils écrasent
le bonhomme donc en fait ont tendance à
rouler à 2 à l'heure ils démarrent en 2e
VO en 3e ils vont tout doucement ils
prennent ils font des photos ils font
les marioles ben pour se montrer
puissant moi j'ai réussi je suis
quelqu'un je pas un tocard donc toi du
réseau là-bas regarde-moi je peux
travailler pour toi toujours le même
principe et donc et après ça te donne
l'illusion que ils sont ils sont gavés
de pognon il y en a qui sont gavés de
pognon mais ils roulent pas en Ferrari
ils sont pas cons hein les gavés de
pognon ils roulent pas en Ferrari hein
il rou en Ferrari quand ils vont en
vacances ailleurs mais pas ici et ici
c'est les voitures qui sontmatriculées
en polne S
parce que il y a tout un truc donc là
c'est plutôt des audit tout ça et là tu
peux avoir des dealers qui qui pour une
période donnée vont vont louer une
bagnole pour soit pour faire un coup
soit pour faire les marioles soit parce
qu'il faut impressionner quelqu'un mais
c'est de la location donc c'est temps
cours c'est pour blanchir ils sont pas
gavés de poignon j'ouvre une parenthèse
les mortiers d'artifice c'est quand ils
font un bon chiffre d'affaires les feux
d'artifice sont tirés
euh alors les feu d'artifice il y a
plusieurs raisons quand il y
a soit il y a l'ouverture du réseau
parce que maintenant il tire même de J
jour donc il y a l'ouverture du réseau
les gars on ouvre donc ça veut dire toi
tu es là comme comme je le rappelle la
clientèle elle est du quartier hein il
faut arrêter d'imaginer que les mecs il
viennent du il y en a qui viennent
d'ailleurs mais la clientèle elle est
avant tout du quartier paf on ouvre on
ouvre bon le gars il est là il finit sa
série il finit son Netflix il descend et
il va il va prendre son truc tape la
discute parce que c'est super sympa et
il retourne et après 1h 2h du matin en
fonction des réseaux paf on ferme donc
là c'est codifié de trois trois fois ça
dépend des réseaux des fois c'est blanc
des fois c'est chacun a son code après
il y a on a fait le million et ça c'est
pour dire à aux autres voyez on est là
on est dans la place on arrive on a fait
le million des fois c'est mariage
mariage au sein de de de la famille
alors là on retourne au temps des des
Lordes des des seigneurs c'est-à-dire je
suis bon à marier quoi
dans on est costaud donc là on fait un
mariage et donc mariage à 40 50 60
100000 € poum poum et là c'est artifices
qui durent et et euh par fois c'est une
sortie de prison bref on a quelque chose
à fêter ou alors il y a un arrivage il y
a aussi celui alors celui-là ils vont le
filmer celui-là pour dire là vraiment on
a on a de la purple la purple c'est ce
que chante enri purple c'est de la c'est
de la la B qui est violette et il y a un
public qui adore la purple et on reçoit
de la purple alors comme elle est
compliquée à faire
pousser quand ils en ont ben voilà on va
taper un feu d'artifice on a de la
purple où on a de la coque top du top ce
qui fait que en fait si tu es une vue
sur les quartiers nord de de Marseille
beaucoup d'endroits ben il y a un
horaire où ça tape ta claque ça sort là
ça sort là ça sort là et tu peux avoir 7
8 10 feux d'artifice mais tout petit
hein enfin des fois ça c'est c'est pas
mal hein alors moi je trouve qu'au
niveau cinématographique c'est
incroyable hein c'est ces trucs là parce
qu'en fait c'est ça te raconte un truc
il se passe quelque chose là alors ça
c'est lié ça vient le feu d'artifice
parce mant ça coûte plus rien donc en
effet c'est
utiliser feu d'artifice maintenant il y
en a beaucoup hein alors tiens il y a un
autre truc qui font j'ai jamais raconté
nul part cellelà il y a l'application
Waze et je savais pas je sais pas si
c'est Waze ou équivalent il y a une
application tu a un Waze mais qui va
être fermé c'està dire on va se mettre
nous tous ensemble là une communauté de
de 500 personnes et c'est notre WAZ à
nous et là on est 6469 en direct va êre
6469 on fait notre way à nous mais ça
fait beaucoup quand même pour ce que je
vais dire parce que ça ferait beaucoup
de dealers et en fait quand la on a
chaque petit getur est connecté sur cet
appli quand la police arrive tu dis elle
est là il faut la même chose pour les
contrôleurs dans le métro mais le mec
s'est fait attraper et en fait de toute
façon ils sont déjà hors la loi donc qu'
se fassent attraper ils fut attraper
pour ça aussi quoi et en fait tu tu as
en temps réel où se situe la police
alors c'est pas tu vois pas le mouvement
mais grosso modo tu te dis ok si elle
est dans telle cité là la police on peut
imaginer qu'elle vienne vers moi dans 20
minutes 1 heure et là tu commences à
voir les mecs qui crient ça tourne ça
tourne et là ça tourne c'est une
certaine vigilance les mecs changent
ceux qui étaaient un peu votreer se
redresse il y a tout un mouvement qui se
fait et voilà voilà la le quotidien d'un
d'un réseau c'est ça c'est dansun ce
coup il se passe des truc comme ça tu tu
parles d'application est-ce que ils ont
des des pratiques d'hygiène informatique
est-ce qu'ils utilisent du chiffré de
l'application les très gros oui
évidemment c'està-dire qu'aujourd'hui il
y a même des paiements qui se font par
des microopaiements mais là on est en
train de parler de mes semirossistes qui
eux-même travaillent avec des gens qui
ne sont pas des délinquants de métier
qui sont dans leur métier enf tique et
dans dans le conseil on va dire pour que
ce soit le plus vaste possible et que tu
vas payer pour ça parfois ils savent ce
qu'ils font parfois ils veulent pas
savoir et donc là oui là on a donc là on
est dans une forme de corruption je sais
pas si on peut l'appeler comme ça j'ai
pas j'ai pas les compétences judiciaires
pour ça mais oui là on est dans quelque
chose maintenant mes jeunes de terrain
ceux qui font ça eux ils sont plutôt
dans un usage commercial et DRH des
réseaux sociaux et donc ils sont dans un
cryptage qui est de base que n'importe
qui en regardant de de de tutos YouTube
on va trouver ces cryptages là hein donc
ils sont pas dans des trucs d'ailleurs
les flics quand ils saisissent leur
portable ils disent écoute soit tu me
donnes le code et ça soit je l'envoie à
Lyon c'est à Lyon qui a la police qui a
la police scientifique et il va mettre 4
semaines avant de revenir et le Mino
plutôt que de perdre son téléphone 4
semaine il préfèrent lâcher le code donc
donc parce que le leur téléphone comme
nos ados c'est c'est leur vie quoi ils
peuvent pas ne pas le perdre il
préfèrent prendre 6 mois de prison de
plus que que que l'cher téléphone et
donc donc voilà il y a il y a un usage
qui est très malin et très efficace et
très maîtrisé comme un peu des
influenceurs ou des ou de la vente comme
c'est la mode là c'est des ultra
capitalistes en fait moi pour moi c'est
même le lopen prolétariat pour parler
comme un marxiste c'est le le le
sous-prolétaire c'estàd ils sont ils
sont victimes du système capitaliste
parce pour moi c'est vraiment je prends
ma je prends ma casquette d'ancien
journaliste de La Marseillaise ils sont
victimes d' d'un système capitaliste qui
fait qu'à un moment il y a des pauvres
et que on va les oppresser au maximum y
compris dans le banditisme mais par
contre ils vont pas s'élever contre ce
système ils vont dire moi je veux
croquer dans le système et je veux ma
part c'est ça le lopen prolétariat c'est
ça le sousprolétaire sauf qu'avant il
était pas nombreux maintenant il est
plus nombreux c'est en ça que ce que je
disais tout à l'heure et les filles qui
va chercher les colères et oui mais
comment tu vas chercher les sous
prolétaires ils sont en colère mais ils
sont pas en colère parce qu'ils veulent
la Libération et Le et le et le truc
pour tous ils sont en colère parce
qu'ils veulent leur part donc fais
attention à la bonne colère bref tu es
pas sûr qu'ils iront dans la colère que
tu veux et et et donc le le le le le le
le voilà le ce marxisme social un petit
peu que tu as dans dans les stupid les
flagrants et donc euh je sais plus d' où
j'en étais des fois je perds le fil
quand même c'est bien grave je te pose
une autre question voilà on part sur
autre chose euh que pensez-vous du
phénomène des gazilaran entre entre
guillets les gazilaran les ballonsors
c'est les ballons protoxy d'azone
attends je te parlais de de chiffrement
de d'hygiène informatique de brouiller
les pistes plus grand chose à dire sinon
et après jeis parler gazilerant c'est
très important
euh sur sur l'informatique ils ont des
très bonnes compétences en en en en
communication c'est-à-dire que ils
passent leur temps à donner leurs
produits et ils font de la com très
moderne et c'est même très bon je
raconte un truc qu' faisait sur Youtube
sold pardon il font des soldes il font
les soldes les Marseillais sont les
premiers à le faire ça ils font les
soldes ils font malheureusement parce
qu'on va y venir j'espère sur la
prostitution qui est liée ils font des
promotions sur des [__] ils font des
pipes PIP offerte pour 5 barrettes
acheté alors ça c'est les petits réseaux
qui font ça les gros réseaux ne se
mettent pas de la prostitution sur le
dos parce que pour d'un point de vue
judicière c'est pas bon pas d'un point
de vue parfois d'un point de vue moral
aussi attention je veux pas je veux pas
en faire uniquement des des salop
pariniqu c'est pas vrai il y en a
certains d'un point de vue moral il
pourrait pas aussi les petits réseaux de
cramé à à la ramasse on va y venir
essayer de me faire penser eux par
contre ils sont ils sont complètement
dans le dans
le un jeu avec ça et donc sur les
réseaux sociaux et d'ailleurs ça me
ramène au protoxyde d'azote je ferai la
la transition euh sur les les
les les réseaux sociaux donc ils s'en
servent de promo il y a eu pendant
longtemps une chaîne Youtube qui qui a
été fermée et moi ça me faituciner elle
a duré au moins 4 5 ans c'était des
Marseillais très fort j'ai jamais su
qu'il avait fait ça mais il prenait des
pros hein qui faisait un détournement de
Star Wars donc Star Wars c'était un
remontage où tu avais Luuk Skywalker
toutes les scènes avec lu Skywalker et
matthoda qui était défoncé et qui
parlait de où ils achetaient leur le
leur bœ et il donnent que des cités
marseillaises VO tel endroit c'est la
meilleure frérot là-bas c'est des escroc
et le doublage était d'une grosse
qualité c'est pas des des des
branquignoles ça veut dire qu'à un
moment ils ont dû payer des mecs semipr
au moins euh au moins un cours de
théâtre je sa pas quoi pour faire ça il
et en fait c'était très regardé parce
que très marrant mais ça avait un
intérêt aussi tu disais va à tel endroit
c'est le meilleur et c'est ce qui va
donner les yodas par la suite parce que
Maître Yoda était là et euh euh donc tu
avais ce ce ce ce ce truc là et depuis
bon voilà maintenant ils ont toute la
comme très très moderne qu'on peut
trouver sur Instagram sur snap tout ça
très tiktoc ils vont par exemple quand
il y a un réseau quand il y a un réseau
qui change son point de vente ils vont
prendre un motard lui mettre une GoPro
sur le sur la tête et et le le motard va
parcourir le chemin en allant d'un point
très connu à Marseille jusqu'au nouveau
truc ils vont passer s en accélérer et
ça te permet de très vite comprendre où
est le nouveau point de stup ils vont
actualiser ça ils ont pas peur des flics
parce que si les flics le voit toute
façon écriront aha puis changeront le
lendemain puis les flics pour la petite
histoire il y a trois gendarmes qui
s'occupent dans les Bouches du Ron de
tous les réseaux sociaux c'est gendarmes
sur le net c'est c'est les gendarmes
donc excellent boulot en général et et
qu'il font le maximum de ce qu'ils
peuvent faire à trois quoi voilà donc
tout est dit et pas besoin d'aller plus
loin on a cinq doiniers au port autonome
on a trois gendarmes sur les trucs bon
fin de fin de l'histoire là-dessus euh
et donc ils savent faire ça et ils ont
un autre donc un truc de promo c'est
très marrant moi je m'étais abonné pour
faire mon mon dernier livre à une
trentaine de de réseaux de ce stupe
c'est très compliqué parce que moi comme
je consomme pas il voit très bien que je
commande jamais je viens jamais donc je
peux passer pour un flic donc tu as des
durées de vie courte il te bannissent
très vite et donc en avoir 30 il a fallu
que je passe par d'autres personnes que
je enfin bref c'était pas simple et en
fait c'est pas durable aujourd'hui je
les ai tous perdus que en plus je suis
plus connecté dessus tout ça donc c'est
tous perdus c'est très complexe euh mais
tu voyais vraiment ce qui se passait
donc déjà tu savais tout ce qui se
passait parce que tout est dit un tel a
tué un tel on va le venger tout est dit
tout alors au début c'est de la rumeur
c'est le grand bordel et petit à petit
ces rumeurs sont vérifiées comme le web
en général petit à petit les mecs qui
connaissent il disent ça c'est une
connerie j'y étais lui il était là lui
était en prison il peut pas l'avoir tué
lui il était là tac tac tac tac et petit
à petit la rumeur si tu regardes la
rumeur et le procès qui va avoir lieu 7
8 ans plus tard c'est c'est pas loin de
coller c'est pas c'est pas très éloigné
il y a quelques passages un peu olé olé
mais grosso modo tu es pas loin et donc
il y a une forte éch information parfois
pour se provoquer pour dire toi tu vas
mourir ils utilisent des réseaux sociaux
aussi pour menacer par exemple ils vont
filmer c'est David l ils vont filmer la
porte chez quelqu'un pour qu'il se voit
et on est devant chez toi ça j'ai plein
de famille moi qui me qui m'appelle il
me dit ils sont devant il me filme et
puis c'est public c'est plusieurs
milliers de personnes qui voient ça donc
c'est pour dire ici on a cette maison à
telle adresse il l'adresse on a quelque
chose à dire sur eux j'ai l'impression
d'être dans le styway quoi et
c'est aupressant ça vraiment et après il
y a le côté RH ressources humaines et la
RH B c'est les gars les gars on a besoin
de telle cité on recrute enfin c'est pas
tel cité eux c'est par les réseaux ils
sont souvent par cité donc tu vas être
la DZ de telle cité le la frappe de
telle cité les CDD t cité et et ils vont
dire on recrute on a besoin et là ça
répond souvent ça doit être des messages
des DM mais parfois il y en a qui
répondent directement
et c'est là que je me suis rendu compte
qu'en fait ils ont des grosses
difficultés à recruter dans beaucoup de
cités dans les cités du pauvre je dirais
c'est-à-dire l'immense majorité ben il
galèrent et c'est là qu'ils vont
chercher ce qu'on appelle des exters des
extérieurs donc des migrants des mecs
qui s'échappent de de de foyer on va
chercher des des gens qui sont moins
compétent mais on va les prendre et on
essaye et on va exploiter ces gens-là au
maximum quand il eu le covid on allait
chercher tous les gamins qui partaient
qui qui sortai de pendant le confinement
ils se sont tapés dessus dans les
quartiers populaires parce que pendant
que la bourgeoisie
parisienne principalement écrivait des
livres pour dire à quel point c'était
super de se recentrer sur soi mais dans
les quartiers populaires il y avait le
lit chaud le Licha c'estd a toujours
quelqu'un qui dort donc normalement le
petit il est la journée au collège le
papa il travaille la nuit et après il
vient et on tourne comme ça et souvent
il y a un tonton ilci à là et c'est
c'est vraiment Liu de misère sauf que là
le licho il était plus tout le monde
était en même temps donc ça dort c'estci
C là évidemment bon les petits c'est
déboucans les parents ça part très vite
les ados beaucoup d'ados sont partis
quand sont partis ils sont retrouvés
dans les les réseaux de stupe exploités
voilà voilà des gamins qui sont
retrouvés totalement exploité des
réseaux de stup euh gazilarant ballon
protoxy d'azote le gazilarant c'est du
protoxy d'azote c'est ce qu'on vous
donne quand vous faites opérer des an de
sagesse et deci de là sauf que celui
qu'on donne à l'hôpital il est de
meilleure qualité il est dosé
ok pour moi ça m'est arrivé pour une
opération tu ricanes un peu tu as une
sensation de bien-être et tu es un peu
posé c'est pas si désagréable que ça ça
te fait un peu voilà le le pour écrire
mon livre j'ai pris du j'ai pris deux
fois du protoxy d'azote et ça te fait
rigoler tu es mort de rire tu sais pas
pourquoi mais tu as vraiment la
sensation de rigolade et tu as une
sensation d'étau dans la tête et de de
d'orill qui te chauffe très très chaud
et tu sens que ce que tu prends c'est
chimique tu sens que là c'est du lourd
tu sens que ça va te cramer et tu sens
que si tu en prends beaucoup ça va pas
le faire c'est vraiment et c'est c'est
utilisé là c'est vraiment une drogue
pour c'est le CAT de Djibouti voilà
Djibouti il fait tellement chaud ceux
qui savent pas est-ce que c'est le CAT
le CAT c'est une une plante qui se mâche
et qui fait que tu ne sens plus la
chaleur tu sens plus le temps passé tu
sens plus la la douleur tu sens plus
rien mais tu je sais pas si bien c'est
pas le mot mais tu es tu es dans
laattente voilà tuattends que ça passe
tu es dans laattente donc nous le 4 ici
il peut pas pousser fait pas ass chaud
donc c'est le protoxyde d'azote parce
qu'il se commande sur internet en
faisant semblant de faire des de la
chantilly c'est des des capsules qu'on
branche sur des appareils à Chantilly et
c'est du protoxyde d'azote et ce
protoxyde d'azote il est pris par une
certaine jeunesse qui n'est pas que
celle des quartiers pauvres et
populaires qui est pris par une jeunesse
parce que c'est rigolo au début et parce
que ça te déforme la voix c'est marrant
tu es dans pour ceux qu' on des enfants
ou qu'on regardait ça tu es dans l'âche
de glace là quand ils sont à un moment
quand il ils sont morts de rire qu's
vont tous mourir ils prennent ils sont
dans des gazilérant et c'est rigolo sauf
quand tu en prends sans arrêt ça
t'atteint ton cerveau et ça te pose dans
cet état de d'apathie et ça permet c'est
ma transition donc déjà dans les stupes
ils prennent peu de ballons sauf les
réseaux pourris mais les réseaux un peu
les réseaux pourris c'est réseaux du
pauvre ce qui sont vraiment on survie où
tu prends ce que tu peux comme gateteur
tout ça les bon réseau quand tu Mino
protoxy tu F oh tu tu me prends pas tu
prends pas des ballons hein sinon tu es
pas là pour tu vas pas voir la voiture
hein donc pas de ballon pareil les
portables ils ont le même problème que
les parents les Minos sont tellement sur
les portables qu'ils ont embauché des
gamins qui surveill les Minos qui
surveill les gateteurs pour qu'il soient
pas sur les portables et eux par contre
contrairement au parents il les roulent
tellement de coup que ils comprennent au
bout d'un moment ils lâcheent les
portables mais il y a des des postes de
de surveillance pour les portables ils
ont les mêmes problèmes finalement que
que que les parents et protoxyde d'azote
donc c'est plutôt des ceux qui
travaillent pas ou qui travaillent dans
des réseaux à la con ça crame le cerveau
rapidement en quelques semaines et en
plus tu ne peux plus les amener à
l'école tu peux plus rien faire c'est
enfin il va tu peux plus pendant qu'ils
en prennent mais après il y a un autre
phénomène c'est que c'est utilisé pour
les filles et les fils pour les amener à
la
prostitution pendant le confinement
quand
euh les garçons partaient ben les filles
elles va rester parce que dans dans
voilà les les les adolescentes les
adolescents partent mais les
adolescentes on les retient parce
qu'elles peuvent se faire violer parce
qu'elles peuvent parce que de de dehors
on laisse pas partir une femme parce que
dehors c'est euh à T ou a raison par
ailleurs c'est euh c'est euh dangereux
c'est plutôt vrai parce que dans les
ce serait serait mal
passé
pardon mais en fait ce qu'il y a c'est
qu'il y a eu beaucoup de de cas de
maltraitance beaucoup de de filles qui
ont été qui ont été battues et donc les
filles battues elles ont été placées des
mineurs de 12 ans hein un peu plus jeune
parfois de 12 ans à 15 ans elles ont été
placées donc on a saturé d'un ce coup
les les les foyers sociaux d'ê social à
l'enfance la ze et on en a fait foyers
qui sont tous pratiquement aujourd'hui
en France pas à Marseille pratiquement
tous nommés les foyers des [__]
pourquoi parce que les gamins qui qui
sont endettés qui ont besoin de se
refaire on appelle ça les lover Boy ils
vont se trouver une fille alors le
profil de fille c'est
l'éducation téléréalité vous savez les
filles avaient le maquillage contouring
des décolleté inimaginables elles ont
elles ont 13 14
ans l'ultra féminisation sexualisation
elles sont là-dessus tu les faux ongles
par contre pas d'hygiène de vie pas
d'hygiène tout court c'est c'est
surprenant mais ça c'est le protoxy
d'azote ça ça c'est vraiment la drogue
je boire un coup parce que je B fou et B
fou mais donc on en profite on va
meubler pendant que c'est bon
et et donc là les les les les filles se
sont sont retrouvés en foyer les lover
Boy vont d'abord apâer une fille euh
principalement avec de la consommation
un peu un sac à main un peu un truc mais
pas tant que ça hein sur sur du stup un
peu si on fait un peu rêve un peu de
rêve un peu un resto resto ils s'en
foutent
mais ils vont pas au resto mais dans des
des trucs le truc du moment en fait ils
sont comme des ils sont comme des
influenceurs he c'est les mêmesin ils
sont totalement dans leur monde ils sont
pas à côté hein c'est vraiment c'est
l'impression des des minau de
téléréalité quoi de la consommation bête
et méchante qui peut se photographier
tout de suite qui se voit il faut que ce
soit grave faut que ce soit là quoi faut
que soit omniprésent c'est c'est ils
sont vraiment dans ce Mondel il bon
quand on dit islamisation moi je te dis
américanisation des quartiers mais
surtout pas islamisation ça devient des
Américains le tacos et le burger mais à
part ça c'est il y a pas de différence
quoi et ces fillesl
donc sont pas amoureuses mais elles sont
avec le le gars le gars au bout d'un
moment il te dit il faut que tu
travailles pour moi parce que moi je
vais me faire buter hein j'arrive pas à
vendre jeis me faire buter tu vas avoir
ma mort sur la conscience et donc il
fait travailler la fille il a mis au
tapin avec le le protoxy D' autres c'est
possible parce qu'en fait tu ressens pas
enfin les premières fois me disait c'est
les premières fois les plus dures mais
au bout de de trois fois tu arrives et
après il le gars il dit tu vas pas faire
venir tes copines les copines trouve où
au au au foyer et bien sûr elles sont
vulnérables elles sont fracassées au
protoxide elles sont gamines elles ont
pas de de de lien avec l'extérieur les
éducateurs font ce qu'ils peuvent et ce
qui se passe c'est que petit à petit ben
parfois il y en a qui des filles qui
deviennent elles-même mère macrelle
c'està dire le dealer finit par se faire
choper et elleueent et ell font
travailler les copines en pensant que
c'est du boulot collectif mais comme
c'est elle qu'organise elle deviennent
macrelle quoi et donc elle tombe sous le
coup de la loi en étant surprise ben
mince moi je suis je suis pas une je
suis pas une proxo moi si c'est proxo et
elle le
découvre ça donne quoi ça donne des
foyers massivement mais moi je tiens le
rappeler massivement des centaines de
personnes à Marseille et des milliers à
travers la France de gamines qui qui ont
des bag auans contre 12 et 15 16 ans qui
sont dans des réseaux de PR enfin c'est
pas des réseaux mais qui sont dans cette
prostitution là que qui qui est plutôt
une prostitution en plus c'est vrai que
c'est pas des réseaux c'est prostitution
à l'opportunité ça donne
que les les foyers la plupart ils
ferment à 21h c'estàdire le dernier
éducateur à un moment ils sont déjà pas
nombreux et sous payés à 21h ils partent
la plupart tentent de rester hein ils
ont un engagement énorme mais à un
moment sur une année tu arrives pas à
rester tous les soirs à 21h ils sont bon
et là là tu as un veilleur de nuit qui
garde tu as une porte blindée là bien
collée d'un côté tu as les filles qui
prennent la porte blindée à coup à coup
de chaise parce qu'elles veulent
l'ouvrir et de l'autre côté tu as les
dealers qui mettent une pression qui
peut aller jusqu'au fling pas toujours
mais qui peut aller qui est loin du côté
de de de pour le pour le verur de nuit
le verur de nuit a les sous qui prend
c'est bon quoi c'est pas c'est c'est pas
Chuck Noris quoi il ouvre la porte et ça
va dans les squats là je raconte mon
bouquin comment ça se passe dans les
squats alors je je le bouquin cramer les
enfants du monstre quellees éditions
édition jugar celui qui vient de sortir
c'est c'est le troisème qui peut se lire
en premier sans problème d'une trilogie
à la fabrique du monstre qui raconte ce
qui est le monstre comment il est fait
la chute du monstre qui raconte la
décadence politique et économique de à
Marseille vous verrez tout le monde s'y
retrouve et ensuite cramer les enfants
du monde qui racontent ce qu'on est en
train de raconter là les les gosses
comment comment ça tourne mal quoi pour
eux et aussi les bourreaux et les
esclaves je met B dedans je mets pas que
les que les victimes hein de toute façon
pour moi c'est un même point de départ
donc en fait on a la zeu qui devient un
pourvoyeur de prostitution et attention
ils le disent c'està-d il y a une
remontée des éducateurs qui disent elles
sont toutes [__] on appelle nos foyers
les foyers des [__] qu'est-ce qu'on
fait ben qu'est-ce qu'on fait
aujourd'hui ben rien ben rien on est on
a des juges qui sont emmerdés mais ils
peuvent rien faire hein est-ce qu'on la
place oui mais elle se fait fracasser
par sa mère ou par son père ou mais si
je la place elle va faire la
prostitution moi j'ai une gamine qui
m'avait dit je préférais me prendre
trois tartes par jour par ma mère que 15
passes euh et elle avait raison hein je
veux dire elle avait un rapport co
avantage qui était qui était cohérent
hein et euh euh puis ça elles sont
ruinées et en plus protoxy d'azote pour
pour aller vraiment au bout de la
question quand on prend trop ça se pose
sur la colonne vertébrale était
paralysée donc au bout du bout du
protoxyde d'azote c'est la
paralysie parfois provisoire
généralement définitive donc euh faut
prendre ça très au sérieux et c'est
valable pour ceux qui font pas de stup
hein pour qui d'azote sur la durée ça
rend ça rend paralysé donc le protoxyde
d'azote ça fait ça Emmanuel Macron vient
de rendre les sièges roulant et ben
voilà remboursé par la Sécurité sociale
il est pas bien notre
Président il a une vision il voit ça
d'avance après il y a beaucoup
d'handicap he dans les quartiers
populaires et le handicap il est plus
coûteux là-bas hein parce que les accès
sont pas bons les là aussi hein il y
aenseurs ne fonctionn pas pardon les
ascenseurs ne fonctionnent pas les
ascenseurs ne fonctionnent pas mais ça
alors là aussi c'est c'est c'est un
maronier ça écoute ça fait 3h 23 minutes
qu'on est en interview je voudrais que
tu conseilles trois livres à ma
communauté hormis les miens non je vais
pas faire ça je vais pas faire ça si si
tu peux le faire avec la VO avec la voix
de Pierre milmar
du je vaux pas le faire je vais pas le
faire non le les trois livres ça va
être les enfants du Bronx de le blanc je
sais plus son nom
qui je sais plus son prénom qui est une
plongée dans les stupéfiants euh dans
les dans des trafic porte porto ricain
aux États-Unis euh là ça c'est c'est
très bien écrit déjà pour commencer et
en plus finalement ça raconte avec un
peu d'avance ce qu'on a ici donc tu tu
tu voilà le blanc les enfants du les
enfants du Bronx ad Nicole Le Blanc
Adrian Nicole le blanc ça c'est le le
premier truc
ensuite corner de the corner de de the
corner de comment il s'appelle David
Simon CELI qui a fait the wire qu'est-ce
que tu en pense de The Wire exceptionnel
euh plus mais ça c'est pas sa faute plus
à jour mais ça il est pour rien dire ça
évolue ça évolue hein
mais voilà pour dire simple pour
m'envoyer des fleurs en même temps à
chaque fois qu'on dit je suis le David
saon français ça me fait énormément
plaisir alors que quand on me dit que je
suis savano français je me dis on a pas
compris mon travail parce que savano
dénonce beaucoup d'ailleurs il le paye
hein sabiano c'est le chaud sabiano
c'est le chaud par contre je ressemble
plus à
sabiano et et mais sabiiano c'est le
c'est le c'est le c'est il dénonce il va
loin dans dans dénonciation et surtout
il travaille sur des mafias et donc il
est menacé et moi là où je suis pas le
Saviano c'est que je ne dénonce pas de
mafia même si je mets des noms dans mon
livre mais j'ai eu des menaces oui
beaucoup mais pas dans les même
proportions on n'est pas par contre
David Simon il l'analyse et moi je suis
plus dans de l'analyse même si j'ai des
bouts de dénonciations elles sont plutôt
sur le monde économique et politique
j'ai pas de dénonciation sur le
banditisme pour moi c'est à la justice
de faire ça mais je raconte quand même
le banditisme je raconte pas le
banditisme dans temps je raconte des
vivants quand même hein mais je ne mets
pas de de façon à ce qu'il soit
condamnable et le troisème faut que je
choisisse un Mouquin là je vais choisir
faut aller sur Marseille parce que comme
je pense que Marseille c'est la
marseillologie
c'est la la la
la sociologie de Marseille de Claire
Duport et Michel perad pour les plus
ardus c'est gouverner Marseille mais
alors là c'est ardu sociologie de
Marseille c'est accessible ça raconte
très bien les
les les clientélismes comment ils sont
mis en place comment ils existent
clientélisme et ça casse beaucoup
d'idées reçu tout ça je vais te demander
de donner un conseil pour les jeunes
générations mais avant on répète la
drogue c'est pas bien c'est mal c'est
compliqué c'est
interdit c'est c'est destructeur et en
fait comme moi je suis pas de ceux qui
disent consommez pas ça je le fais sur
les snaps des dealers pour rigoler parce
que ça les M mort de rire je v pas dire
consommez pas parce qu'un consommateur
il consomme parce qu'il a il a il y a
une vulnérabilité derrière qui fait
qu'il va consommer donc moi avec mon
petit conseil les gars c'est pas bien de
consommer ça sert à rien par
contre mesurer qu'en fait il faut il
faut il faut aller vers le soin ça oui
donc la drogue c'est tellement néfaste
que quand on sort justement du rare
récréatif et la cocaïne elle est
rarement récréative il faut très
rapidement aller dans des parcours de
soins les addictolos savent le faire et
il existe des moyens de rentrer dans des
cadres légaux quand on a un médecin en
qui on a confiance et ben il faut y
aller je voudrais que tu donnes un
conseil pour les jeunes générations
autre que
celui-là euh
il y en a beaucoup il faut que je fasse
un choix les jeunes générations il faut
ouais il faut que je fasse gaffe à pas
filer un conseil à la papa là de de
vieux parce que j'en ai des conseils
mais qui vont être par rapport aux
réseaux sociaux par et ça finalement il
entendent tout le temps
mais par rapport à mathématique parce
que j'en aurai d'autres par rapport à
mathématique le conseil c'est ne pas
croire dans le kalalashnikov Dream c'est
une Fouthèse absolue et totale par
contre croire il est possible en alors
moi je suis pas dans si tu le veux tu
peux j'y crois pas ça ça c'est
capitaliste tu veux tu peux ça voudrait
dire que il y a ceux qui sont courageux
ceux qui sont pas non il y a ceux qui
ont les possibilités moi je j'aurais eu
un nom différent je n'aurais pas été
pris alberlond je me serais appelé avec
un nom arabe en ayant la même tête parce
que j'ai une tête de kabile moi c'était
possible he je il y en a qui me disent
tu comme Zidane bah voilà italien kabil
Corse c'est un peu la même gueule tout
ça les Chau regarde P jidane prends ma
gueule on peut être on peut être des
cousins proche hein donc en fait euh ah
j'ai quand même une gueule qui qui tire
vers le vers les cabiles que moi j'étais
en Algérie me parlait tout çaab sans
exception hein après je sais très bien
prendre la pause faire comme je suis un
journaliste de terrain je sais très bien
faire le prendre les les les postures
les les trucs
et conseil pour les jeunes génération
mais le Conseil ça veut dire qu'en fait
euh tu crois pas au Kalashnik of dream
mais à côté de ça il faut croire en la
possibilité faut faut faut trouver les
gens qui vont te venir en a il faut pas
repousser l'aide parce que le problème
c'est com il croi plus en rien ces
jeunes quand tu leur tends la main il la
repousseent ils croient plus en toi ils
arrivent pas à imaginer que tu puisses
les aider dire pourquoi il va m'aider
lui ils ont ils ont une approche
tellement cynique du monde mais à 12
ansin c'est terrible normalement tu
rêves à câge là tu es même naïf c'est ça
qui est bon c'est bon d'être con
normalement ado c'est bon d'être con et
là tu as pas le droit d'être con parce
que tu es dans un lieu tellement hostile
que si tu es con tu es mort donc il faut
tout de suite être comme un adulte qui
en a vu cynique et donc moi mon conseil
c'est garder un petit peu cette cette
naïveté cette enfance et quand on tend
la main après sans sans naïveté il faut
prendre la main parce que
malheureusement ils l'apprennent pas et
ils ont le kalashnikov Blum reste bien
plus fort bien plus puissant et on
arrive pas les attraper et donc voilà et
au rappeur s'il vous plaît faites un peu
des arrêtez de de de de faire du
calashnikomum uniquement arrêtez de
faire croire qu'en fait vous racontez
des histoires du monde réel non vous
racontez des mythos du monde réel et
donc à un moment faudrait peut-être
faire du The Wire en rap pour de vrai
faut qu'il meure à la fin des Mino parce
que pour de vrai il Meur à la fin des
Mino il Meur socialement à minima donc
voilà le truc c'est qu'à un moment faut
revenir au truc réel tant pis vous ferez
un petit peu moins d'argent mais un
moment il faut avoir une figure quoi
Philippe Pujol merci merci
[Musique]